ON HUMAN SECURITY WILL COME TO
ORDER. GOOD AFTERNOON THE
RESPONSE TO THE COVER NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES
WE MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND IT HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING. AND FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES AND COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE HAS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. WE ALSO HAVE ALL
PANELISTS WERE PRESENTED TO THE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY FOR A
REMARK PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE
YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS. THIS
WILL GREATLY AID ELIMINATED ANY
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. ASSET EVERY
TIME YOU WISH TO BE RECOGNIZED
THAT YOU USE THE RAZOR HAND
FEATURE IN THE PROGRAM. EACH
TIME YOU'RE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK
A POP UP WINDOW WILL APPEAR
ASKING IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO AND
MUTE. POLICE SELECTOR MU BEFORE
YOU BEGIN SPEAKING HOW ARE I. T.
PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK ON
MUTE WHEN YOUR DONE. ONCE YOU
RECOGNIZE TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME. AND THEN
YOU'RE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. I
WILL BE USING A TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR
ALL INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER AND
ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. IT WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE SIX THREE
SIX FOUR. AND THE ACCESS CODE IS. THREE FIVE THREE ONE TWO EIGHT
THREE. FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS
ON HOW THE TELECONFERENCE SYSTEM
WORKS PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE
SELECT COMMITTEE ON HUMAN
SECURITY WEBSITE. FOR TODAY'S
HEARING WE WILL BE HERE IN ALL
OF THE PANELS. OF WITNESSES ON
THE AGENDA PRIOR TO TAKING ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT ONCE WE HAVE
HEARD ALL OF THE WITNESSES WE
WILL HAVE A PUBLIC COMMENT
PERIOD FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO
COMMENT ON THE TOPICS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER OR US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY
AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK.
YOU MUST MEET THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR TO
GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE.
IT IS IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL RETAIN DECORUM
DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS DESTRUCTIVE. MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
OR HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED
. WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN
MADE TO STREAMLINE THE HEARING
PROCESS AND TO CONDUCT PERKINS
AND THAT'S CLOSE. TO THE MATTER
AS IS CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE
SOME LAG TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS
FOR JUSTIN TO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES.
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT
SO ALL INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE
HEARD. THANK YOU FOR JOINING US
OF ALL THOSE THAT ARE WATCHING
ON. ON THE INTERNET AND THE GOAL
OF THE SELECT COMMITTEE ON HUMAN
SECURITY IS TO HELP US BETTER
UNDERSTAND HER WEAKNESSES AND
CALIFORNIA'S ABILITY TO PROVIDE
HUMAN SECURITY FOR ITS
RESIDENTS. AND PRODUCE
LEGISLATIVE RECOMMENDATIONS TO
ADDRESS THOSE WEAKNESSES AND
HELP US PLAN FOR THE FUTURE.
WHILE THE WORLD AROUND US IS SHE
IS SHAPING US LESS AND WE ARE
IMPACTING THE WORLD MORE AND BY
DOING SO IT IS DESTABILIZING
MANY SYSTEMS WE DEPEND ON FOR
SURVIVAL. THE SELECT COMMITTEE
WILL LOOK AT TOPICS INCLUDING
ADEQUATE ACCESS TO WATER FOOD
HEALTH CARE HOUSING AND ECONOMIC
SECURITY THROUGH THE LENS OF
HUMAN SECURITY. HUMAN SECURITY
TAKES AN ALL ENCOMPASSING VIEW
TO ADDRESS ACCESS TO THESE NEEDS
COLLECTIVELY EVALUATED THE
NECESSARY RESPONSE AND
MITIGATION TACTICS TO SUPPORT
THE SURVIVAL OF LIVELIHOOD. AND
DIGNITY OF ALL PEOPLE.
RECOGNIZING THE VALUE OF SUCH AN
APPROACH OUR FIRST TEAM WILL
FOCUS ON THE HIDDEN HUMAN
IMPACTS THE DROUGHT HAS HAD ON A
TWO CALIFORNIANS. DROUGHTS HAVE
FAR REACHING IMPACTS INCLUDING
THE WELL BEING OF COMMUNITIES
LARGE AND SMALL. AND TOO OFTEN.
THESE HUMAN IMPACTS ARE
OVERLOOKED WELL WE ASSESS THE
HYDROLOGICAL IMPACTS AN
IMMEDIATE LOSS OF WATER TO
CITIES AND TOWNS. WE SOMETIMES
MISS THE IMPACTS THAT DROUGHT
HAS ON FOOD SECURITY HEALTH
LABOR AND THE COMMUNITIES
THEMSELVES. CLIMATE CHANGE WILL
EXACERBATE THESE IMPACTS
PARTICULARLY IN THE MOST
VULNERABLE REGIONS AND AMONG THE
MOST VULNERABLE GROUPS THAT ARE
FACING POVERTY AND ON EQUAL
ACCESS TO WATER AT THE SAME TIME
. CONTINUED POPULATION GROWTH
AND CLIMATE CHANGE IS EXPECTED
TO MAKE WORSE EXISTING WATER
STORAGES. THE WESTERN STATES
WILL BE HIT THE HARDEST AND THE
CENTRAL VALLEY IS ALREADY
EXPERIENCING THIS. AS WE ALL
KNOW WATER ISSUES ARE ALSO FOOD
ISSUES. CALIFORNIA BECAME THE
FIRST STATE IN THE NATION TO
LEGALLY RECOGNIZED THE HUMAN
RIGHT TO WATER. DESPITE THIS
OVER ONE MILLION CALIFORNIANS
LACK ACCESS TO SAFE DRINKING
WATER. ACCESS TO FOOD AND WATER
WILL HAVE GREAT IMPACT ON OUR-
FUTURE HUMAN SECURITY DICTATING
WHERE PEOPLE MOVE AND LOVE.
THEIR DIETS AND OUR ECONOMY. THE
IMPACTS OF WATER SHORTAGES WILL
BE FELT IN OUR GROCERY STORES AS
MANY OF YOU ARE PROBABLY ALREADY
EXPERIENCING AS FOOD PRICES
SKYROCKET AND FOOD VARITY AND
AVAILABILITY PLUMMETS. PRIOR TO
THE COMMON NINETEEN PANDEMIC
APPROXIMATELY ONE IN TEN
CALIFORNIANS EXPERIENCE FOOD
INSECURITY. THE COVERT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC HAS LAID BARE THE
DEEPLY ROOTED INEQUITIES THAT
ENDANGER THE HEALTH AND WELL
BEING OF ALL CALIFORNIANS.
CHRONIC DISEASES SUCH AS HEART
DISEASE DIABETES AND HIGH BLOOD
PRESSURE DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECT INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE FOOD
INSECURE. NOT HAVING ENOUGH
HEALTHY FOOD CAN HAVE SERIOUS
IMPLICATIONS FOR EIGHT ONE
PHYSICAL AND MENTAL HEALTH AND
FUTURE ECONOMIC PROSPERITY. AND
WHAT HAPPENS HERE IN CALIFORNIA
WHERE WE PRODUCE TWO THIRDS OF
THE NATION'S FRUITS AND NUTS AND
ONE THIRD OF ITS VEGETABLES.
IMPACTS OUR WHOLE COUNTRY AS
CALIFORNIANS. AS CALIFORNIA
WORKS TO IMPROVE WATER ACCESS
AND SUSTAINABILITY. AN
OVERRIDING CONCERN IS THE
POTENTIAL FOR CLIMATE CHANGE TO
MAGNIFY MANY OF THE ISSUES WE'RE
CURRENTLY FACING AND- THAT THESE
IMPROVEMENTS WILL NOT BE ENOUGH
THE BILITY TO PLAN EFFECTIVELY
WILL BE ESSENTIAL. BEFORE WE
BEGIN WITH OUR SPEAKERS. I WOULD
LIKE TO INVITE THE PUBLIC
WANTING TO BURST TO PARTICIPATE
TO CALL IT NOW FREESTYLE ONCE
AGAIN THE NUMBER IS 844-291-4364
WHAT PROMPTED PLEASE USE THE
ACCESS CODE THREE FIVE THREE.
ONE TWO EIGHT THREE. NOW BEFORE
WE MOVE IT GET STARTED WITH OUR
PANEL I WANT TO. GIVE AT THE
OPENING REMARK OPPORTUNITY TO
SENATOR MELENDEZ WHO IS PART OF
THE SELECT COMMITTEE. AND I KNOW
THAT WE ARE KNOWN AS THE- SELECT
COMMITTEE ON HUMAN SECURITY AND
I BUT I DID MAKE A JOKE AWHILE
BACK ABOUT IT BEING THE- THE
COMMITTEE A ON THE TICKET OF US
SENATOR MELISSA. GETS RIDICULOUS
IS ON THIS COMMITTEE SO THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US TODAY AND
CENTER MELINDA'S. PEACEFUL TO.
HAVE SOME OPENING REMARKS THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR IT. OKAY YES IT
IS THE MELISSA CAUCUS TODAY SO
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US. I'M
GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE AND
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR FOR ASKED
ME TO BE PART OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE. I AM VERY MUCH
INTERESTED IN TAKING A LOOK AT
THE MANY PROBLEMS FACING
EVERYDAY CALIFORNIANS. TO
INCLUDE HOUSING ECONOMIC
STABILITY PUBLIC SAFETY AND
ESPECIALLY WATER. IT IS MY HOPE
THAT THIS COMMITTEE CAN TRULY
SHED LIGHT ON THE NEGLECTED
PROBLEMS IMPACTING SO MANY
PEOPLE. IN INDUSTRIES IN OUR
STATE AND HOW THE POLICIES WE
ENACT HERE MAY EXACERBATE OR
HELP SOLVE. THOSE PROBLEMS AND
LIKE YOU MADAM CHAIR I HAVE A
VERY LARGE AGRICULTURAL AREA IN
MY DISTRICT. THAT RELIES ON
SUSTAINABLE WATER SUPPLY TO GROW
ALL OF THE FRUITS AND VEGETABLES
AND THINGS THAT WE LIKE TO EAT
IN CALIFORNIA AND SENT TO OTHER
STATES. I WAS PLEASED TO SEE THE
STATE WATER COMMISSION APPROVAL
OF MOVING FORWARD WITH THE SITES
RESERVOIR PROJECT THAT WILL
PROVIDE THE NECESSARY
INFRASTRUCTURE. TO AVOID
DROUGHTS AND WATER SHORTAGES BUT
WE CERTAINLY KNOW THAT MORE IS
NEEDED. THOSE FARMS EMPLOYED
THOUSANDS OF WORKERS EVERY YEAR.
BUT WITHOUT WATER THOSE FIELDS
REMAIN FALLOW AND ARE FROM
WORKERS KILLING HIM FLOYD. THIS
ONE EXAMPLE THE LACK OF WATER
AFFECTS NOT JUST THE FOOD BEING
GROWN IN THESE AREAS BUT THE
ECONOMIC VIABILITY OF ENTIRE
COMMUNITIES. WITHOUT JOBS
WORKERS CAN'T PROVIDE FOOD FOR
THEIR FAMILIES OR HOMES OR FOR
THEIR CHILDREN ARE HOME FOR
THEIR CHILDREN TO SLEEP IN. SO
IT IS MY HOPE THAT WE CAN HAVE
MEANINGFUL CONVERSATIONS IN THIS
COMMITTEE ABOUT THESE TOPICS.
AND SEE HOW WE AS POLICYMAKERS
CAN LESSEN THE BURDEN SO MANY
CALIFORNIANS FACE. STARTING A
BUSINESS IN CALIFORNIA IS HARD
AND IT IS GROWING INCREASINGLY
ON AND TRACK UNATTRACTIVE TO
ENTREPRENEURS WHICH IS WHY WE
SEE BUSINESSES FLEEING OUR
STATE. EVEN AS EXISTING
BUSINESSES SUFFER FROM LOOTING
AND RANDOM ACTS OF CRIME. THAT
TOO OFTEN GO UNPUNISHED. AND
THEN OF COURSE YOU HAVE THE LACK
OF GROCERY STORES CONTRIBUTING
TO FOOD AND SECURITY BUT AS
CRIMINAL ACCOUNT ACTIVITY
CONTINUES TO RISE MORE OF THESE
STORES ARE GOING TO REFUSE TO GO
INTO THESE COMMUNITIES WHO SO
DESPERATELY NEED THEIR SERVICES.
WE CANNOT HAVE A VIABLE ECONOMY
WITHOUT JOBS WE CANNOT SOLVE
FOOD INSECURITY WITHOUT
BUSINESSES FEELING SAFE AND IN
ORDERTO ADDRESS THOSE PROBLEMS
WE HAVE TO HAVE A HOLISTIC
APPROACH TO IMPROVING OUR
BUSINESS CLIMATE. HOUSING IS
UNAFFORDABLE PARTIALLY BECAUSE
ALL OF ALL THE COSTS WHICH
INCLUDE LABOR AND THE PERMITTING
IN THE ENVIRONMENT ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACT REPORTS EQUAL EDUCATION
GREEN BUILDING INITIATIVES AND
THE LIST GOES ON AND ON. AND ALL
THESE THINGS GOING TO PLANNING
AND DEVELOPMENT BEFORE SHOVEL IS
EVEN TURNING THE EARTH. AN
ENERGY IS EXPENSIVE IN ALL OF
CALIFORNIA NOT JUST IN MY
DISTRICT BECAUSE IT'S
PARTICULARLY IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA OF COURSE. YOU KNOW
WE NEED AIR CONDITIONING IN THE
IN THE DESERT PART OF MY
DISTRICT IT'S- A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY TWO DEGREES IN THE SUMMER
PEOPLE CAN'T GO WITHOUT AIR
CONDITIONING BUT OF COURSE THAT
PLAYS. PLACES A LARGE BURDEN ON
OUR ELECTRICAL GRID. WE HAVE
TRIED TO USE AN INCENTIVIZED
GREEN ENERGY SOURCES LIKE WIND
AND SOLAR WHICH WE HAVE MUCH OF.
IN MY DISTRICT BUT THEY SIMPLY
DON'T PRODUCE ENOUGH ENERGY WHEN
THE WIND ISN'T BLOWING. OR THE
SUN ISN'T SHINING SECRETING AN
ENERGY RELIANCE AND OTHER STATES
AND MAKING ELECTRICITY MORE
EXPENSIVE FOR CONSUMERS. IS
LIKELY NOT THE PATH WE WANT TO
CONTINUE DOWN. CALIFORNIANS
DESERVE TO HAVE A RELIABLE
ENERGY GRID SYSTEM AND SO I DO
HOPE THAT THIS COMMITTEE CAN
TAKE A LOOK AT ALL OF THE
OPTIONS AVAILABLE TO US. TO
ENSURE THAT ROLLING BLACKOUTS
BECOME LESS FREQUENT IF NOT.
NONEXISTENT AS A COST OF GOODS
AND SERVICES CONTINUE TO
INCREASE DUE TO INFLATION I
THINK THE TIMING OF THIS
HEARING. AND THE MANY TOPICS WE
WILL COVER THIS SESSION WILL BE
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TO MAKING
CALIFORNIA MORE SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE PLACE TO LIVE. SO I
DO LOOK FORWARD TO OUR
DISCUSSION TODAY ON WATER TO
HELP THE OTHER TOPICS ARE
BROUGHT FORWARD CAN BE ADDRESSED
IN THE FUTURE. TO ENSURE
COMMUNITIES CAN BE VIABLE PLACES
TO LIVE AND WORK FOR EVERYDAY
CALIFORNIANS THANK YOU SO MUCH
MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU SENATOR
MELENDEZ AND- AS YOU ALL HEARD
TODAY I MEAN. THERE IS A LOT OF-
IT'S GOING TO JUST ADD THAT THIS
IS THE FIRST OF MANY HEARINGS
YET TO COME THAT WILL FOCUS ON
HUMAN SECURITY THAT WILL BE
FOCUSED ON. PROTECTING MANKIND
AND I'M SO EXCITED TO. HAVE
SENATOR MELINDA IS WITH ME HERE
TODAY BUT I AM ALSO EXCITED FOR
ALL OF OUR- GUEST SPEAKERS WHO
WILL AND EXPERTS. IN IN B. AREA
FULL OF WATER AND FOOD. AND
HEALTH. HOW ARE HUMAN SECURITY
IS- IMPACTED BY BY THE DROUGHT.
I'D LIKE TO BEGIN WITH OUR FIRST
PANEL. AT AND THAT WE HAVE THE
STATE OF WATER WHERE ARE WE NOW
LET'S HEAR FROM OUR FIRST
PRESENTER RACHEL OWNS FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
WELCOME. Q. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND SENATOR MELINDA'S
RACHEL EHLERS WITH THAT
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE I'M
GONNA TRY AND SHARE MY SCREEN
HERE THIS IS ALWAYS THE SCARY
PART YOU CAN GET IT WORKING. AND
THEN IT KICKED OFF LET'S SEE.
YES. YES WE CAN OKAY- WELL
THANKS SO MUCH FOR HAVING ME I
THINK MY JOB HERE TODAY IS JUST
FOR SOME CONTEXT SETTING ON THE
KIND OF STATUS OF THE DROUGHT
THAT WERE IN AND SOME BACKGROUND
AND CONTEXT ABOUT WHAT WHAT WE
HAVE LEARNED AND WHERE WE'VE
BEEN OVER THE PAST SORT OF A
DECADE OR SO HERE AT THE STATE
LEVEL- TO PROVIDE SOME CONTEXT
FOR YOUR SUBSEQUENT SPEAKERS SO
HERE'S MY PLAN FOR WHAT I'LL
TALK ABOUT BRIEFLY IN THE NEXT
FEW MINUTES- FIRST JUST IN
HISTORY OF THE MORE OF THE MOST
RECENT DROUGHT AND WHAT WE CAN
LEARN FROM IT DONE SOME
BACKGROUND ON THE DROUGHT WE'RE
IN THE MIDDLE OF RIGHT NOW SH-
TALK ABOUT SOME FACTORS THAT
EXACERBATE DROUGHT IMPACTS WHY
IS IT GOTTEN SO BAD SO FAST.
THIS TIME AND THEN- HIGH LEVEL
SUMMARY OF SOME RECENT
LEGISLATIVE ACTIONS. SO FIRST
THIS IS THE GRAPH OF OUR
PRECIPITATION OVER THE PAST
FIFTY YEARS AND YOU CAN SEE
THERE ARE LOTS OF UPS AND DOWNS
OF DROUGHT IS NOTHING NEW IN
CALIFORNIA- BUT I THINK WHAT I'D
LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT IS THAT. THE
MOST RECENT FIFTEEN YEARS SO YOU
CAN SEE THEY'RE SMART. OR DOWN
THEN UP AND THIS AND THIS
PERIOD. WE TALK ABOUT HAVING A
SERIOUS DROUGHT BETWEEN TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE AND SIXTEEN AND
THEN NOW AGAIN IN TWENTY AND
TWENTY ONE. BUT ANOTHER WAY TO
THINK ABOUT IT IS WE'VE HAD A
REALLY DRY FIFTEEN YEARS. WITH
FIVE WAIT YEARS SPRINKLED
THROUGHOUT THERE. SO I THINK
THAT SOME HELPFUL PERSPECTIVE TO
THINK ABOUT CUMULATIVE IMPACTS
AND- WELL YOU KNOW AGAIN WHY
THINGS GOT SO BAD SO QUICKLY
HERE IS THAT WE REALLY HAVE HAD
A PRETTY DRY PERIOD OVER THE
PAST FIFTEEN YEARS OR SO.
LUCKILY IF YOU WAIT YEARS IN
BETWEEN THERE BUT BUT BUT IT
DOES HAVE CUMULATIVE CHANCE OF
SACKS- SERVICE I JUST HIGHLIGHTS
THE LAST DROUGHT AND YOU CAN SEE
HOW IT PROGRESSED AND GOT WORSE
INSTEAD OF BUNCH OF RECORDS. I'M
NOT POSITIVE ONES. I HAD TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE TO TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN WAS THE DRIEST
CONSECUTIVE FOUR YEAR STRETCH ON
RECORD. AND TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN WAS THE THIRD DRIEST
YEAR ON RECORD AT THE TIME IN
TERMS OF PRECIPITATION- SO
PRETTY SEVERE DROUGHT. SO AT A
HIGH LEVEL SOME OF THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT IMPACTS FROM THAT
DROUGHT WERE. THAT THOUSANDS OF
HOUSEHOLDS LOSING WATER THEIR
DOMESTIC WELLS GOING DRY OR
BECOMING CONTAMINATED. THAT VERY
SIGNIFICANT REDUCTION IN SURFACE
WATER DELIVERIES FROM OUR STATE
AND FEDERAL WATER PROJECTS WHICH
LED TO A DECREASE IN
AGRICULTURAL CROP. CROP
PRODUCTION AS WAS REFERENCED BY
ON BOTH OF YOUR SENATORS IN YOUR
INTRODUCTORY REMARKS AND I'M
SURE WILL BE DISCUSSED IN YOUR
SUBSEQUENT PANELS- WHAT ACTS OF
BATCH- WE IN CALIFORNIA HAVE
ALWAYS USED OUR GROUNDWATER IS
OUR SAVINGS BANK WHEN WE HAVE
DRY YEARS WE GO WITH THE DRAW
FROM OUR SAVINGS ACCOUNT IN THE
GROUND AND THEN IN WHAT YEARS.
REPLENISH BUT BECAUSE OF THE
SEVERITY OF THE DROUGHT AND
AGAIN SOME OF THESE CUMULATIVE
IMPACTS WE HAVEN'T BEEN
REPLENISHING- SIGNIFICANTLY OR
UP TO THE DEGREE THAT WE HAVE
BEEN PUMPING WHICH IS LED TO
OVER DRAFT IN SOME AREAS AND
SOME SIDE ENDS WITH THE GROUND.
YOU KNOW DROPPING AND CAUSING
DAMAGE AND WE SAW THAT- VERY
SIGNIFICANTLY IN THE LAST
DROUGHT. IN THE URBAN SAID THE
BIGGEST IMPACT IN THE LAST ROUTE
WAS INCREASED CONSERVATION
REQUIREMENTS REQUIREMENTS TO USE
LAST GOVERNOR BROWN. HAD A 25%
MANDATORY REDUCTION DURING THE
LAST DROUGHT AND WE SAW THAT
WHERE YOU STRAP AND NOT SOME OF
THAT WATER USE DROP HAS BEEN
SUSTAINED SINCE THEN THERE WERE
SOME PERMANENT REDUCTIONS FROM
THINGS LIKE. YOU KNOW TAKING OUT
LINES ARE REPLACING SHOWER HEADS
ARE TOILETS IN URBAN SETTINGS
WHERE WE'VE SEEN SOME OF THAT
REDUCTION IN USE OF SUSTAINED.
DURING THE LAST YEAR WE HAD
SEVERAL VERY SEVERE WILDFIRES
THAT WERE. FUELED IN PART BY A
HISTORIC TREE DIE OFF IN OUR
FORESTS. WE LOST A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY NINE MILLION TREES THAT
BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND TEN AND TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN. FROM DRY
CONDITIONS AND THAT CONTRIBUTED
TO A- WIDE SCALE INFESTATION OF.
BARK BEETLES WHICH KILLED-
CONTRIBUTED TO SOME OF THAT TREE
DIE OFF. AND THAT CERTAINLY
CONTRIBUTED TO THOSE FIRES- AND
THEN I HAVE SOME PRETTY SEVERE
IMPACTS TO HABITAT IN PARTICULAR
PRODUCT HABITATS FOR FISH AND
WILDLIFE AS WELL DURING THE LAST
DROUGHT. SO IN RESPONSE TO THAT
THE LEGISLATURE TOOK SOME PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT. ACTIONS DURING THE
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE TO TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN DROUGHT AND IN
A COUPLE YEARS FOLLOWING THAT
THAT I THINK ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT TO HIGHLIGHT BECAUSE
THEY ARE INFLUENCING THE
CONDITIONS WERE IN RIGHT NOW- SO
THE FIRST WAS. VERY SIGNIFICANT
FUNDING A LOT OF IT FROM
PROPOSITION ONE WHICH VOTERS
PASSED IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN
SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS FOR WATER
SUPPLY AND STORAGE. SO THAT WHY
THAT THOSE FUNDS HAVE WERE
APPROPRIATED MOST NOT ALL BUT
MOST DURING THE LAST DROUGHT BUT
THOSE PROJECTS TAKE A LONG TIME
TO. KIND OF GET PERMITTED GET
CONSTRUCTED GET GET ON THE
GROUND SO- I THINK WE'RE
STARTING TO SEE SOME OF THE
FRUITS OF THOSE PROJECTS NOW IS
THAT SOME OF THEM ARE STARTING
TO BE COMPLETED. TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN ALSO SOUGHT PASSAGE OF
THE SUSTAINABLE GROUNDWATER
MANAGEMENT ACT OR SIGMA WHICH
WAS THAT HISTORICAL AS AS YOU
ARE NOW- FIRST STATEWIDE EFFORT
TO REGULATE GROUNDWATER. THERE
WAS ALSO PRETTY SIGNIFICANT.
WATER CONSERVATION LEGISLATION A
LITTLE BIT LATER TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN TO TRY AND SUSTAIN SOME
OF THAT BUT GOALS AND TARGETS
THAT WERE SET UP DURING THE LAST
ROUND AND LEAD TO MORE.
PERMANENT WATER EFFICIENCY
PRACTICES. IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN WE STOPPED PASSAGE OF
THE SAFE AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER FUND LEGISLATION SB TWO
HUNDRED WHICH PROVIDES A HUNDRED
AND THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY FOR TEN YEARS. FOR A
DRESSING SOME OF THE DRINKING
WATER ISSUES THAT WE SAW
HIGHLIGHTED DURING THE LAST
DROUGHT I WOULD SAY THAT THE
DROUGHT EXACERBATED TO SOME OF
THOSE DRINKING WATER ISSUES BUT
SOME OF THEM ARE REALLY LONG
STANDING ISSUES. THAT WERE JUST
HIGHLIGHTED. DURING THE LAST
ROUTE SO THAT THAT NEW PROGRAM
THE LEGISLATURE PASSED TO TRY
AND ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE LONG
TERM ISSUES ARE WITH SAFE
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER. IT
WAS ALSO LEGISLATION PASSED THAT
PROVIDED THE STATE WITH
AUTHORITY NEW AUTHORITIES TO
HELP CONSOLIDATE SOME WATER
SYSTEMS POORLY PERFORMING WATER
SYSTEMS. IN CASES WHERE
VOLUNTARY CONSOLIDATIONS ARE
HAPPENING THE STATE NOW HAS
ADDITIONAL AUTHORITY TO TRY AND
MAKE THOSE HAPPEN IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT. PARTICULARLY SOME
OF THE SMALLER MORE RURAL WATER
SYSTEMS. THAT JUST DON'T MAKE
SENSE TO OPERATE AND AREN'T
FUNCTIONING WELL ON THEIR OWN
CAN BE PART OF A LARGER SYSTEM-
AND THEN FINALLY SOME NEW
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS THE
LEGISLATURE ENACTED FOR WATER
USERS JUST SO WE CAN GET A
BETTER SENSE OF THIS IS AS A
STATE. AS A STATE OF WHO'S USING
HOW MUCH WATER WHERE THAT REALLY
HELPS INFORM WHEN THERE ARE
CURTAILMENTS- NEEDED JUST TO GET
A BETTER SENSE. SO I HAD A
LADIES IN PART BECAUSE THEY ARE
HELPING US HOPEFULLY IN THE
CURRENT DROUGHT BUT ALSO JUST TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT. WHEN YOU'RE IN
THE MIDDLE OF A DROUGHT
EMERGENCY THERE'S NOT MUCH THAT
THE STATE AND LEGISLATURE CAN DO
OTHER THAN THE EMERGENCY
RESPONSE YOU KNOW GETTING
BOTTLES OF WATER TO COMMUNITIES
I DON'T HAVE THEM. BUT IT REALLY
WHAT. IS IMPORTANT TO KIND OF
HAVE THAT I. ON WHAT'S THE NEXT
ROUTE THAT WILL COME IN FUTURE
YEARS WHAT CAN WE DO NOW BECAUSE
SOME OF THESE CHANGES REALLY DO
TAKE A LONG TIME TO PUT IN PLACE
WHETHER IT'S- PROVIDING FUNDING
FOR. A NEW WATER RECYCLING.
FACILITY TO INCREASE WATER
SUPPLY- OR OR CONSOLIDATING
WATER SYSTEMS YOU KNOW THAT THAT
CAN'T HAPPEN WITHIN A WEEK OR A
MONTH THAT TAKES YEARS AND SO.
SOME OF THE POLICY SETTING UP
NEW WATER CONSERVATION TARGETS
YOU KNOW THESE THESE TYPES OF
EFFORTS CAN TAKE YEARS. SO
LUCKILY WE HAD SOME OF THE
SIGNIFICANT EFFORTS DURING THE
LAST STRAW THAT HAVE WE'RE
HELPING US NOW BUT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THING FOR. THE
LEGISLATURE TO KEEP IN MIND I
HAVE- THAT THAT WE NEED TO HAVE
KIND OF A LONGER. TERM VIEW AND
THEN SOME OF THESE CASES. TEN
OUT TO THE DROUGHT WERE IN MIDST
OF IT NOW- AT TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY AND TWENTY ONE OR GET
EXCEPTIONALLY WARM AND
EXCEPTIONALLY DRY- WE- WE BROKE
THE RECORD AGAIN WITH TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE- IN TERMS OF
PRECIPITATION OUTS THE THIRD
DRIEST. ON RECORD THE SECOND
DRIEST BASED ON HOW MUCH RUNOFF
WE HAD. SO IN RESPONSE TO
GOVERNOR DECLARED A STATE OF
EMERGENCY I THINK ACTUALLY THREE
DIFFERENT STATES OF EMERGENCY
ADDING ADDITIONAL COUNTIES. IN
EACH ONE SO THAT NOW EVERY EVERY
FIFTEEN ONE OF THE FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES IS COVERED BY THE
STATEWIDE- DROUGHT STATE OF
EMERGENCY. THIS FIGURE HERE IT
SHOWS YOU ABOUT WATER RUNOFF-
EXCUSE ME- WATER FLOW FOR
VARIOUS RIVERS IN THE STATE AS
OF SEPTEMBER SO IT'S NOT CREDITS
IT'S A FEW MONTHS OLD. BUT I
THINK THE IMPORTANT THING TO SEE
HERE IS IF YOU LOOK IN THE LEFT
COLUMN SAYS TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN. THE MIDDLE EAST TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN AND THE RATE IS
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE. SO
FOURTEEN AND FIFTEEN WHERE THE
FOURTH AND FIFTH YEARS EIGHT OF
THE OF THE LAST DROUGHT- THIRTY
FOURTH YEARS YOU KNOW THE LATTER
END OF THE LAST DROUGHT. AND TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE IS ONLY THE
SECOND YEAR OF THIS TRIAL AND
IT'S ALREADY AT AT COMPARABLY
LOW LEVEL SO I THINK THAT POINT
TO HIGHLIGHT HERE IS. IS AGAIN
HOW QUICKLY IT GOT BAD WE'RE
ONLY IN YEAR TWO OF THIS DROUGHT
BUT IT- THAT THE LEVELS GOT
PRETTY BAD PRETTY QUICKLY. I'LL
TALK IN A MINUTE. ABOUT WHY THAT
MIGHT BE- SO TURN TO LOOK AT
SOME OF THE IMPACTS OF THIS
CURRENT DROUGHT AND AGAIN I KNOW
YOUR PAIN NEXT COUNCIL GET INTO
MUCH MORE DETAIL BUT JUST AT A
HIGH LEVEL. AGAIN WE'VE SEEN
SURFACE WATER ALLOCATIONS
DRAMATICALLY REDUCED THE STATE
WATER PROJECT ONLY DELIVERED 5%
OF THAT CONTRACT AMOUNTS. LAST
YEAR AND CENTRAL VALLEY PROJECT
NO WATER DELIVERIES FOR SOME OF
THE- AGRICULTURAL. CONTRACTORS
SOUTH OF THE DELTA SH- WE SAY
GROUNDWATER LEVELS DROPPING
AGAIN SO THAT'S WHAT THIS
PICTURE HERE IN THE SLIDE SHOWS-
THIS IS A COMPARISON OF SPRING
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
GROUNDWATER LEVELS SO. THE
CONCLUSION OF THE LOVE THAT.
STRAIGHT AFTER WE HAD A COUPLE
OF THOSE REALLY WENT YEARS IN
SIXTEEN AND SEVENTEEN. SO SPRING
TWENTY EIGHTEEN COMPARED TO
SPRING TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AND
WHAT YOU CAN SEE HERE IS- ALL OF
THAT RED AND ORANGE TRIANGLES
AND BARS UP IN THE CORNER. OUR
GROUNDWATER BASINS THAT DECLINES
TO THE ROUND WATER LEVELS
DROPPED BETWEEN EIGHTEEN AND
TWENTY ONE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
AND TWENTY ONE. SO IT'S ONLY
ABOUT A THIRD ABOUT 30% OF THESE
MONITORING WELLS SHOWED LOWER
LEVELS BUT- BUT BUT YOU CAN SEE
JUST OVER THAT SHORT. AND WE'RE
ALREADY DO YOU KNOW JUST TWO
YEARS IN THE DISTRAUGHT WE'RE
ALREADY SEEING DECLINES IN THE
GROUNDWATER LEVELS. AND THIS WAS
FROM THE SPRING SO IT DOESN'T
EVEN INCLUDE USAGE THAT HAPPENED
IN THIS VERY HOT SUMMER OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE SO WE CAN
ANTICIPATE THAT THE NEXT- SET OF
READINGS WILL. WILL SHOW EVEN
FURTHER DECLINES. AT ONE POINT
TO JUST MAKE IS THE- AND I THIS
WAS IN THE QUITE A BIT SO YOU
MAY HAVE SEEN THIS. AT LEAST
DURING THE SUMMER THE WATER
CONDITIONS IN SOME CALIFORNIA
ARE ACTUALLY MUCH BETTER THAN IN
NORTHERN AND CENTRAL CALIFORNIA
WHICH- MIGHT SEEM SURPRISING
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT MOST OF OUR
PRECIPITATION ACTUALLY FALLS IN
THE NORTH SO WHY WAS IT BETTER
IN THE SOUTH COMPARED TO THE
NORTH. SH I THINK PART OF THE
STORY THERE WAS RELATED TO THOSE
INVESTMENTS THAT WE STOP FROM
PROPOSITION ONE. A FEW YEARSAGO
THERE THERE HAD BEEN A LIST HAVE
BEEN A LOT OF SPENDING A LOT OF
INVESTMENTS IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA IN BOTH ALTERNATIVE
WATER SUPPLIES- LIKE WATER
RECYCLING AT AND ALSO STORAGE.
AND SO BAD THEY THEY HAD BETTER
WATER WATER SUPPLIES ON HAND
THAT IN IN THE SUMMER. THAT
STARTED CHANGING AND THE LONGER
THAT THE DRY PERIOD WAS GOING
ALONG. AGAIN JUST TALKING ABOUT
SOME OF THE IMPACTS OF THIS
RECENT DROUGHT WE ARE SEEING
HOUSEHOLDWATER SHORTAGES AGAIN
SO THAT'S WHAT THIS GRAPH SHOWS.
THESE ARE HOUSEHOLD WATER
SHORTAGES REPORTED TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES.
SO YOU CAN HAVE WE WOULD
ANTICIPATE THIS IS PROBABLY
UNDER COUNTING BECAUSE NOT
EVERYBODY CALLS OF THAT STATE TO
TELL THEM. WHEN THEY'RE WELL
GOES DRY. BUT BUT THIS REFLECTS
THE REPORTED SHOULD THAT
REPORTING THAT THE DEPARTMENT
DID GET SO I YOU CAN SEE THE
HIGH SPIKES IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN. OR SIXTEEN. AND THEN
NOT SO MANY SEVENTEEN THROUGH
TWENTY AND THEN NOW IN TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE AND WE'RE
SEEING. A LOT MORE REPORTS OF
CASH FAST DRY WELLS BEGAN
HOUSEHOLD SHORTAGES- ALL SEEN WE
ALL KNOW ABOUT THE SEVERE
WILDFIRES THAT BREAKING RECORDS
AGAIN THIS SUMMER FROM DRY
CONDITIONS CERTAINLY CONTRIBUTED
TO BY THE DROUGHT. AND THEN
AGAIN REALLY HIGH FISH MORTALITY
I KNOW THAT THIS COMMITTEE HAS
FOCUSED ON HUMAN IMPACTS BUT I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT THE HEALTH OF THE
ECOSYSTEMS- AND FOOD WEBS.
CONTRIBUTE TO THE HEALTH OF
HUMANS AS WELL BUT ALSO OF
COURSE THE HUMANS WHO WORK IN
THE FISHING INDUSTRY AND NATIVE
AMERICAN TRIBES FOR HIM YOU KNOW
SALMON ARE REALLY IMPORTANT
CULTURAL RESOURCE FOR EXAMPLE-
CERTAINLY AFFECTIVE BI- THE
HEALTH OF OR ECOSYSTEMS AND
NATIVE FISH SPECIES AS WELL. SO
WHY DID THE DRIVER GET SO BAD SO
QUICKLY. TEMPERATURES ARE A BIG
PART OF IT WE BROKE RECORDS THIS
SUMMER FOR THE HIGHEST
TEMPERATURES FOR JUNE JULY AND
AUGUST ON ON RECORD. AND THAT
CERTAINLY HELPED CONTRIBUTE TO
WHY THINGS GOT SO DRY YOU KNOW
OUR OUR SNOW PACK IN FEBRUARY
ACTUALLY WASN'T THAT BAD IT
WASN'T THAT DRY MATTER OR THAT
LITTLE COMPARED TO. YOU KNOW
WHAT HAPPENED AND FOR EXAMPLE
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN. BUT WHEN
THAT SNOW MELTED IT DIDN'T MAKE
IT INTO A RESERVOIR ST THAT WAS
PARTLY BECAUSE IT WAS SO HOT THE
SOILS WERE SO DRY. THE SNOW
MELTED INTO THE SOIL AND DIDN'T
MAKE IT INTO THE RESERVOIR SO.
WHEN WE LOOK AT THE DEPARTMENT
OF WATER RESOURCES DOES
FORECASTS OF HOW MUCH WATER
THERE EXPECTING WILL COME IN AND
THEY OVER ESTIMATED THAT THE RAN
OFF. IN THAT- SACRAMENTO BASIN
WAS LIKE BY 65% AND IN THE SAN
JOAQUIN IN TULARE LAKE LIKE 45%
SO. REALLY OVER ESTIMATED. AT
HOW MUCH WATER WE WOULD GET FROM
THAT SNOW BACK- BECAUSE WE
DIDN'T ANTICIPATE IT WOULD SOAK
INTO THE SOIL THAT WAY SO. SO IT
GOT BAD REALLY QUICKLY AND IN
LARGE PART BECAUSE OF THOSE
TEMPERATURES- THE OTHER PART OF
THE STORY I THINK THAT'S WHY IT
GOT SO BAD SO QUICKLY IS RELATED
TO GROUNDWATER SO- THIS IS THE
SAME PICTURE THAT WE SAW EARLIER
BUT THIS IS A TEN YEAR
COMPARISON INSTEAD OF A THREE
YEAR COMPARISON SO LOOKS AT
SPRING TWENTY ELEVEN. COMPARED
TO SPRING TWENTY TWENTY ONE YOU
CAN SEE A LOT MORE RED AND
ORANGE HERE. SO THIS IS WHAT
THIS IS SHOWING IS THAT FROM
BEFORE THE LAST DROUGHT. TEN NOW
ON NET. WE ARE THE GROUND WATER
LEVELS ARE BELOW- WHAT WHAT THEY
WERE. SO OLD THAT THE ORANGE
BARS ARE DROPPED BY AT LEAST.
FIVE FEET AND THE RED IS DROP BY
AT LEAST TWENTY FIVE FEET. SO
60% OF THESE OF THESE-
MONITORING WELLS HAVE SHOWN
DECLINE. SINCE THE LAST STRAW.
SO KIND OF WE INTO DROUGHT WITH
THE DEFICIT IS WHAT THIS IS
SAYING AND THEN AND HADN'T FULLY
RECOVERED OR- NOT TO GO BACK TO
THAT SAVINGS ACCOUNT AND DEPEND
ON IT SO I THINK THAT'S ANOTHER
PART OF THE STORY OF WHY THINGS
GOT SO BAD. SO QUICKLY IS OUR
GROUND WATER LEVELS WERE ALREADY
DEPLETED. SO NOW TIME FOR SOME
GOOD NEWS- IN SWITCH SWITCHING
TO WHAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS DONE
ABOUT THIS THIS IS A SUMMARY OF
THAT YEAH MOST RECENT BUDGET
PACKAGE PASSED THIS SUMMER AND
THEN INTO SEPTEMBER. THE DROUGHT
AND WATER RESILIENCE BUDGET
PACKAGE AS YOU CAN SEE THREE
POINT THREE BILLION DOLLARS
PROVIDED FOR THIS CURRENT FISCAL
YEAR WE'RE IN THE MIDDLE LEVEL
AS WELL AS INTENT FOR AN
ADDITIONAL EIGHT HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY MILLION AND ABOUT FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION IN THE COMING
TWO YEARS THAT STILL NEED TO BE
APPROPRIATED BUT THERE'S INTENT
TO PROVIDE THAT. FOR A VARIETY
OF WATER- SUCH A LAG RESILIENCE
DROUGHT RESPONSE ACTIVITIES. THE
IMMEDIATE DROUGHT RESPONSE YOU
CAN SEE FOUR HUNDRED AND THIRTY
SEVEN MILLION IN THE CURRENT
YEAR. PART OF THAT IS FOR THINGS
LIKE EMERGENCY RESPONSE
PROVIDING BOTTLED WATER OR TANKS
OF WATER TO COMMUNITIES THAT
NEED IT- BUT ALSO A NEW
COMMUNITY WATER PROGRAM THAT I
THINK THE SUBSEQUENT PANELISTS-
MISS MESSER FROM D. W. R. WE'LL
TALK ABOUT. THAT PROGRAM. A LOT
OF INVESTMENT FOR DRINKING WATER
AS YOU CAN SEE ONE POINT THREE
BILLION DOLLARS. I THINK THE
OTHER IMPORTANT THING TO
HIGHLIGHT ABOUT THIS FINDING IS
THAT IT'S MOSTLY FROM THE
GENERAL FUND NEARLY ALL OF IT IS
FROM THE GENERAL FUND WHICH IS
DIFFERENT. FROM WHAT THE STATE
HAS HISTORICALLY PROVIDED BOND
FUNDING. SO THAT'S GOOD BECAUSE
WE'RE NOT PAYING INTEREST SO
IT'S- IT'S LESS EXPENSIVE FOR
THE STATE BUT ALSO OFFERS A LOT
MORE FLEXIBILITY FOR HOW THE
FUNDS CAN BE USED BECAUSE BOND
FUNDS TYPICALLY ARE LIMITED TO.
CAPITAL OUTLAY INFRASTRUCTURE
BUILDING CONSTRUCTION TYPE
PROJECTS IN HERE THERE'S A LOT
MORE FLEXIBILITY CAN BE USED FOR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE THAT CAN BE
USED FOR- YOU KNOW ON THE GROUND
KIND OF HELPING HELPING PEOPLE.
RESOLVE WHATEVER THE ISSUES ARE
RATHER THAN JUST BUILDING STUFF
SO I THINK THAT THAT'S THAT'S
GOOD NEWS THAT WE HAD STATE
SURPLUS THAT ALLOWED FOR THIS
TYPE. I ALSO FUNDING FOR
IMPLEMENTATION OF SIGMA- AND
HELPING DEVELOP AND IMPLEMENT
PROJECTS TO SUPPORT ABOUT THAT
GROUND WATER MANAGEMENT PLANS.
THERE WAS ALSO SOME LEGISLATION-
THIS YEAR TO HELP WITH IMMEDIATE
DROUGHT RESPONSE I THINK I WOULD
CHARACTERIZE THESE AS- WAYS TO
EXPEDITE PROJECTS IN SPEED UP
PROCESS SEES. SO NORMALLY WHEN
WE'RE ALLOCATING STATE FUNDS
IT'S OFTEN THREE- COMPETITIVE
GRANT PROJECTS OUR CURRENT
CREDIT COMPETITIVE GRANT PROCESS
SEES AND SEVERAL LOCAL AGENCIES
NEED TO PUT TOGETHER GRANT
APPLICATIONS AND MAYBE COME UP
WITH MATCHING FUNDS AND IT'S A
MUCH LONGER PROCESS SO. THIS
LEGISLATION ALLOWS THE STATE TO
PROVIDE DIRECT EXPENDITURES IF
THE IF THERE'S A PROBLEM YOU
DON'T NEED TO PUT TOGETHER A
GRANT APPLICATION YOU DON'T NEED
TO BE WEIGHED AGAINST OTHERS THE
STATE WILL COME IN AND HELP FIX
THAT SO. AGAIN THAT'S EXPEDITING
FOR MORE OF THAT EMERGENCY
CONDITIONS AND THEN SIMILARLY
IT'S OFTEN USUALLY STATE
PROGRAMS ARE SET UP ON A
REIMBURSEMENT PROCESS. WHICH CAN
BE HARD FOR ESPECIALLY SMALL
LOCAL AGENCIES TO COME UP WITH
ALL THE UP FRONT CASH TO
UNDERTAKE A PROJECT AND WAIT FOR
STATE REIMBURSEMENT SO- THIS
LEGISLATION ALLOWED FOR THE
EMERGENCY DROUGHT PROJECTS THAT-
UP 225% OF IT CAN. JUST BE
FRONTED MEDIA. LEE WITHOUT
HAVING TO WAIT FOR REIMBURSEMENT
. SO WITH THAT I'M A JEALOUS OF
HIS MASTER THAT SHE GETS TO DO
THE REALLY GOOD NEWS OF.
UPDATING ON CURRENT CONDITIONS
BUT- I GUESS. I GUESS TALK ABOUT
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS FOR WATER SO
THAT SOME GOOD. WITH THAT I'M
HAPPY TO AND ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS AND- THANKS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THAT AND WE'LL MOVE ON TO
OUR NEXT. PANELIST FOR THE
SECTION AND THAT'S- CINDY
MASTERED THE LEAD DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES. WELCOME THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND AS MY FELLOW
PANELISTS SAID I'M GONNA TRY AND
SHARE MY SCREEN AND THAT IS THE
SCARIEST PART SO. LET ME SEE I
SEE IT HERE. JUST. ALL RIGHT
WELL I'M GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND SENATOR MELINDA BUSH
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE PART OF A
PANEL OF THIS AFTERNOON AND TO
TALK WITH YOU ABOUT CURRENT
WATER CONDITIONS AND RELATED
DROUGHT CONDITIONS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE- I DID WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE GRAPHIC THAT WAS
PROVIDED IN THE BACKGROUND
DOCUMENT BUT I ALSO THINK MOST
ELDERS ALSO CONFIDED THAT IN HER
PRESENTATION THAT'S THE GRAPHIC
THAT SHOWS DROUGHT SEVERITY
THROUGH THE ENTIRE STATE OF THAT
PARTICULAR ILLUSTRATION REALLY
JUMPED OUT FOR ME BECAUSE I
THINK WHAT IT SO EFFECTIVELY
SHOWS IS. THE FACT THAT THERE IS
NO WHERE SHE'S CURRENTLY IN OUR
STATE THAT IS UNTOUCHED BY
DROUGHT THE DEGREES OF SEVERITY
MAY BE DIFFERENT BUT EVERY
PORTION OF THE STATE IS
DEFINITELY AFFECTED IN SOME WAY
. SO WHAT I WANTED TO PRESENT ON
THIS AFTERNOON OR A COUPLE
DIFFERENT AREAS- I WANT TO TOUCH
A LITTLE BIT ON HYDROLOGIC AND
WATER SUPPLY CONDITIONS AS THEY
CURRENTLY STAND. AND I THINK I
WILL PROBABLY DUPLICATE A LITTLE
BIT- WITH MY FELLOW PANELISTS
BUT I WON'T DWELL ON ON SOME OF
THOSE POINTS- JUST. WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT THERE ARE SOME
IMPORTANT. ITEMS THAT ARE
PROBABLY WORTH REPEATING AS I GO
THROUGH MY CREATION TATIAN- I DO
WANT TO FOCUS ON THE STATE'S
APPROACH- SPECIFICALLY
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES AS
WE MANAGE. THE STATE WATER
PROJECT. OF OUR APPROACH TO
MANAGING CURRENT WATER SUPPLIES
AS WE MOVE INTO THIS NEW WATER
YEAR. STARTED ON OCTOBER FIRST
SO WE'RE NOT TERRIBLY FAR INTO
THE WATER YOU'RE JUST YET- AND
WE ARE ENTERING WHAT I KNOW WE
ALL HOPE WILL BE THE WEIRDEST
PART. PORTION SORRY OF THE WATER
HERE SO STARTING WITH THIS MONTH
OF DECEMBER AND MOVING INTO.
JANUARY AND FEBRUARY THAT IS
TRADITIONALLY THE WETTEST
PORTION OF OUR WATER HERE. AND
SO I KNOW WE ARE ALL. ROSS THIS
WEEK HAS. A GREAT AT HOME FOR
GETTING SOME PRECIPITATION MUCH
NEEDED SNOW- BUT WE ARE WE DO
STILL HAVE MONTHS AHEAD OF US
THAT BRING. HIGH DEGREE OF
UNCERTAINTY AS TO WHETHER THIS
TYPE OF WEATHER WILL PERSIST
THROUGH WALMART- SO WE'LL TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT HOW HOW WE
ENTERED THIS WATER YEAR IN OUR
APPROACH TO. MANAGING SUPPLIES.
AND THEN LASTLY I WANTED TO JUST
HIGHLIGHT SEVERAL EFFORTS.
ACTIONS AND INITIATIVES FOR THE
STATE IS CURRENTLY UNDERTAKING.
AND THESE ARE MEANT TO ASSIST
COMMUNITIES LOCAL WATER
SUPPLIERS AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
ARE ROUGHLY THESE ACTIVITIES
FALL INTO THREE CATEGORIES
PROVIDING INFORMATION AND DATA.
PROVIDING FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE.
AND PROVIDING COMMUNICATION AND
COORDINATION SERVICE ARM AND
JUST BUILD A LITTLE BIT OF FUN
RITUALS. SOME OF THE INFORMATION
SHE PROVIDED. THESE INITIATIVES
AND EFFORTS. FALL INTO BOTH- A
PREVIOUS THE PREVIOUS
IMPLEMENTED. AND THOSE ACTIONS
THAT COME OUT OF THE LAST ROUTE
BUT WE'RE ALSO IN AND THAT IS
KIND OF A POSITIVE PART OF MY
PRESENTATION WERE ALSO-
CURRENTLY IMPLEMENTING.
ACTIVITIES THAT CAME OUT OF THE
RECENTLY PASSED STATE BUDGET-
SO- JUST KIND OF TOUCH UPON BOTH
OF THOSE TYPE OF AREA. HOME WHEN
WE MOVED INTO WATER CONDITIONS
SO- FOR CONTEXT AND AGAIN TO
MAYBE ECHO WHAT MY TROUBLE
PANELIST KEYED UP- WE ARE WE
HAVE STARTED THIS WATER YEAR
WITH HISTORIC LOW LEVELS OF
WATER STORED IN OUR RESERVOIRS
BUT ALSO OUR GROUNDWATER AND
BOXERS AND THIS IS IN LARGE PART
TO COMING OFF OF A TWO YEAR
PERIODS WILL LAST YOU
CONSECUTIVE YEARS COMBINED WHERE
THE SECOND DRIEST IN OVER A
HUNDRED YEARS SO WE HAVE ENTERED
THIS WATER YEAR WITH THE
DEFICIT- AND A LOT OF
UNCERTAINTY AS TO WHAT LIES
AHEAD. SO BASED ON THAT WE ARE
APPROACHING THE YEAR AND
MANAGING CURRENT OUR SUPPLIES IN
A VERY CONSTRUCTIVE MANNER AND
I'LL TALK A LITTLE BIT MORE
ABOUT THATJUST A SECOND- AS I
MENTIONED WE ARE. CAN OF
ENTERING THE CAP KELAPA WEATHER
MONTHS- SO WHAT HAPPEN BETWEEN
AND FEBRUARY. THANKS FOR THE
REST OF THE WATER HERE AND HOW
WE MANAGE SUPPLIES MOVING
THROUGH THE REST OF THE WORLD
TWENTY TWO. SO CURRENT
CONDITIONS THAT WAS STRAIGHT THE
VERY ABILITY OF CALIFORNIA'S
WATER CONDITIONS AT A LOCAL
LEVEL- AND THE GRAPHIC THAT I'M
SHOWING RIGHT NOW OUR THE SLIDE
THAT I'M SHOWING IS MEANT TO
ILLUSTRATE THAT VERY ABILITY. SO
ESSENTIALLY WHERE WE STAND RIGHT
NOW- IF YOU LOOK AT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS THAT IN THE
NORTHERN PART OF THE STATE OVER
THE LAST ROUGHLY TWO MONTHS. AND
IN TERMS OF PERCENT OF AVERAGE
PRECIPITATION WE ARE DOING WELL
WE ARE OVER A HUNDRED AND 50% OF
AVERAGE AGAIN THIS IS KIND OF A
SNAPSHOT IN TIME. IN TERMS OF
AVERAGE PRECIPITATION. BUT AS
YOU MOVE FURTHER SOUTH- DOWN THE
STATE WILL GET THE CENTRAL
PORTION OF THE STATE. THEY'RE AT
A LOWER AVERAGE PERCENTAGE OF
PRECIPITATION AND YOU MOVE INTO
THE SOUTHERN PORTION OF THE
STATE. SOME OF THOSE WATERSHEDS
OR ONLY AT ABOUT 4250% OF
AVERAGE FOR THIS TIME OF YEAR.
SO VERY ABILITY VERY KEY TO THE
TO THE STAGE AND THEN AGAIN THE
UNCERTAINTY OF THE CONDITIONS
THAT LIE AHEAD OF US- SORRY. ALL
BACK P FOR JUST A SECOND HERE-
I DID WANT TO MENTION THAT WE
ARE OBVIOUSLY VERY WELCOMING OF
THIS WEEK'S STORMS ARE MUCH
NEEDED SNOW IN THE MOUNTAINS
MUCH NEEDED PRECIPITATION IN
PARTS OF THE STATE INCLUDING THE
SOUTHERN PART OF THE STATE WHAT
WE SHOULD BE MINDFUL THAT THE
STORMS ARE BY NO MEANS A DROUGHT
BUSTER WE WILL NEED MANY MORE OF
THESE TYPES OF STORMS EVENTS
THROUGH THE SEASON TO REALLY
MOVE US PAST DIRE CONDITIONS
THAT WE TRIED- OURSELVES AND-
HAVE FOUND OURSELVES AND AS WE
ENTER THE LAST. LAST PART OF
THIS YEAR. OUR FORECASTS AND WE
TALKED A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE-
ABOUT THAT IN THE PREVIOUS
PRESENTATION ON THIS YEAR'S
WEATHER FORECASTS. DO YOU
SUGGEST TO THE NORTHERN PART OF
THE STATE. COULD RECEIVE ABOVE
AVERAGE PRECIPITATION FOR THE
MONTH OF DECEMBER. BUT THEY'RE
ALSO SHOWING THE POTENTIAL THAT
THIS PRECIPITATION DROPS OFF
OVER THE REST OF THAT SEASON SO
SOMETHING THAT WE WILL BE
MONITORING VERY CLOSELY. AND
OBVIOUSLY WILL BE FACTORING INTO
OUR DECISIONS AROUND WATER
ALLOCATION WATER STORAGE
PRESERVATION AS WE MOVE INTO THE
SPRING MONTHS. SEVERAL SWITCHING
GEARS I WANTED TO JUST TOUCH
UPON VERY BRIEFLY WATER STORAGE
I THINK THIS IS- AN ILLUSTRATION
THAT IS SIMILAR AND IN SOME WAYS
TO THE GRAPHIC THAT. RACHEL
SHOWED EARLIER- WHAT THIS
ILLUSTRATION IS MEANT TO SHOW
YOU IS THAT LOOKING AT ALL OF
THE MAJOR WATER STORAGE
RESERVOIRS WITHIN THE STATE WHAT
YOU QUICKLY NOTICE IS THAT THE
MAJORITY OF THEM ARE WELL BELOW
AVERAGE- WELL BELOW AVERAGE
HISTORICAL ALL CAPACITY. IN
THEIR CURRENT CAPACITIES ARE
VERY LOW OF THE TWO THAT I WOULD
DRAW YOUR ATTENTION TO JUST
BECAUSE THEY ARE CRITICAL TO THE
STATE WATER PROJECT. OR LAKE OR
A BILL WHICH IS IN THE MIDST OF
THE CRAFT IN THE UPPER RIGHT
HAND SIDE OF THE SLIDE YOU'LL
SEE AS OF DECEMBER FOURTEENTH SO
JUST A COUPLE DAYS AGO. MAKE
YOUR BILL WAS ABOUT. 31% OF ITS
CAPACITY. AND OTHER. AND DRAW
YOUR TO THE SAINT LOUIS
RESERVOIR MIDDLE OF THE STATE
THE CHART IS ON THE LEFT HAND
SIDE. AND AS OF A COUPLE DAYS
AGO THAT RESERVOIRS ABOUT 24% OF
CAPACITY SO. SO AS I THINK WE
BOTH HAVE A CODE- EACH OTHER WE
HAVE STARTED THIS YEAR WAS A
GREAT DEFICIT IN TERMS OF THE
WATER WE HAVE AVAILABLE. I WOULD
NOTE THAT THE COVER SLIDE TO MY
PRESENTATION IS SAM WAS
RESERVOIR I THINK A PICTURE IS
WORTH A THOUSAND WORDS AND JUST
LOOKING AT THAT YOU CAN. SEE
THAT INDEED 24% MAKES SENSE WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THE WATER LEVELS.
ALONG SURE. I WOULD ALSO JUST
KNOWN SUMMARY THAT STATEWIDE
RESERVOIR STORAGE AT THE END OF
NOVEMBER SO JUST LAST MONTH
WHAT'S THAT 66% OF AVERAGE. AND
THAT'S IN COMPARISON 287% OF
AVERAGE FOR THIS SAME TIME LAST
YEAR SO AGAIN THE TREND HAS BEEN
DOWNWARD AGAIN WE HAVE STARTED
THIS YEAR WITH MUCH LESS WATER.
AND I JUST WANTED TO TOUCH AT
THIS POINT ON GROUNDWATER LEVELS
I THINK WE HAVE MENTIONED THAT
THIS WAS ALSO ANOTHER PART OF
THE EQUATION COMING INTO THIS
WATER YEAR. OVER THE LAST BULLET
PAST SUMMER WE DID OBSERVE
DRAMATIC DROPS IN GROUNDWATER
LEVELS ESPECIALLY IN PARTS OF
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY. AND THIS
REFLECTS INCREASES IN PUMPING AS
WATER USERS IN THESE AREAS A
LITTLE OR NO SURFACE WATER
ALLOCATIONS LAST YEAR. SO FOR
THE STATE WATER PROJECT OVER
THIS LAST YEAR OR ALLOCATIONS
WILL ROLL AROUND FIVE PERCENT.
SIR WATER USERS NEEDED TO TURN
TO OTHER SOURCES- COUPLE MET IN
AND TO ADDRESS THE WATER DEMANDS
THAT THEY HAD. SO. SORRY I'M
GONNA BACK UP JUST A MINUTE HERE
I WANT TO TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT MANAGING WATER SUPPLY SO
AGAIN THIS IS FROM THE STATE
WATER PERSPECTIVE. AS WE BEGIN A
WET SEASON AS WE SAID WITH
EXTREMELY CHALLENGING WATER
SUPPLY CONDITIONS STATE WATER
PROJECT INITIALLY WILL REALLY
ONLY PLANNING TO DELIVER MINIMUM
RESIDENTIAL HEALTH AND SAFETY
WATER NEEDS SO I'M SURE MANY OF
YOU SAW IN THE MEDIA ON DECEMBER
FIRST WE DID OUR INITIAL STATE
WATER PROJECT ALLOCATION AND
THAT WHAT OUR ALLOCATION WAS 0%
WE ARE STILL PROVIDING WATER TO
SOME OF OUR STATE WATER
CONTRACTORS FOR HUMAN HEALTH
HOME GYM AND HEALTH AND SAFETY
NEEDS. BUT THE ALLOCATION IN THE
TRADITIONAL SENSE IS THE LOWEST
WE HAVE NOT HAD A 0% ALLOCATION.
BERRY BEGINNING IN NINETEEN
NINETY SO IT IS- AND DID A VERY
HISTORICAL MOMENT FOR OUR
PROCESS- AS WE- BEING INTO
FURTHER INTO THE WET SEASON WE
ARE CONTINUING TO WORK WITH OUR
WATER AGENCIES TO CONTINUE TO
IDENTIFY HEALTH AND SAFETY NEEDS
THAT THEY MAY HAVE IN THEIR
SERVICE AREAS CURRENTLY WE HAVE
EIGHT OF OUR STATE WATER
CONTRACTORS THAT WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING WITH SHOE PROVIDE. US
SOME WATER FOR THOSE TYPES OF
NEEDS- TO HELP THEM MEET THOSE
COMMITMENTS AND DELIVER WATER
FOR AGAIN HUMAN HEALTH AND
SAFETY NEEDS SERVICES DOMESTIC
USE USE FOR SANITATION AND FIRE
SUPPRESSION. WE ARE ALSO
COORDINATING WITH U. S. BUREAU
OF RECLAMATION WHO IS IN CHARGE
OF OPERATING THE CENTRAL VALLEY
PROJECT. H. YOU ARE WORKING WITH
THEIR MUNICIPAL WATER
CONTRACTORS IN THEIR SERVICE
AREAS TO IDENTIFY SIMILAR.
CRITICAL RESIDENTIAL. AND HEALTH
INSURANCE SAFETY NEEDS TOGETHER
WERE ARE LOOKING AT THE VARIOUS
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
WORKING WITH OUR WATER
CONTRACTORS TO IDENTIFY WHO'S
MOST AT NEED AT THIS POINT IN
TIME IT WILL CONTINUE TO DO THAT
. SO AS WE LOOK AT- AT OPERATING
THE STATE WATER PROJECT AS I
MENTIONED WERE WERE ERRING ON
THE SIDE OF BEING VERY
CONSERVATIVE THIS EARLY IN THE
WATER YEAR BASED ON STARTING
WITH SUCH A LIMITED AMOUNT OF
WATER IN STORAGE. THERE ARE
CERTAIN CRITICAL AREAS THAT WE
ARE REALLY FOCUSED ON
ADMISSIONS. HUMAN HEALTH AND
SAFETY NEEDS ONE THING I WOULD
HAVE A LINK TO THIS JUST MAYBE
FOR SOME CONTEXT TO SOME OF THE
INFORMATION AGAIN BUT YOU MIGHT
BE SEEN THROUGH THE MEDIA-
READING OR HEARING ABOUT NO
OTHER PLACES. IS THAT PART OF-
BEING ABLE TO PROVIDE WATER AND
WATER QUALITY THAT IS SAFE FOR
DRINKING WATER AND DOMESTIC USE-
WE NEED TO PROTECT WATER QUALITY
IN THE DELTA REGION. SO ONE OF
THE EFFORTS THAT WE'VE DONE IN
THE PAST AND THAT WE DID AGAIN
FOR THIS DROUGHT IS TO INSTALL.
A ROCKET TEMPORARY WALK. DELTA
BUT IT'S- IS USED REPEL- SALT
WATER WORKS SALTIER WATER COMING
IN FROM THE OCEAN AND THE BABY
INTO THE DELTA. AND PRESERVING
THE FRESH WATER THAT IS FLOWING.
THROUGH THE DELTA REGION SO
THAT'S OUR TEMPORARY BARRIER IT
IS STAYING IN PLACE FOR THE
MOMENT. BUT WE WILL OBVIOUSLY BE
EVALUATING THE NEED FOR THAT
YOUR POTENTIALLY OTHER BARRIERS
DEPENDING ON WHAT THE HYDROLOGY
GETS US AS WE MOVE INTO THE
SPRING. ANOTHER CATEGORY OF
CRITICAL NEED THAT WE ARE REALLY
FOCUSED ON IN TERMS OF HOW WE'RE
APPROACHING WHAT WATER
MANAGEMENT OPERATIONS OF STATE
WATER PROJECT. IS WATER NEEDED
FOR ENDANGERED SPECIES OUR I
KNOW THAT RACHEL TALKED ABOUT-
THAT NEED FOR FISHERIES- WE'VE
ALSO BEEN HELPING IN DIFFERENT
WAYS WITH SOME OF THE CITRIX Y.
WAY. EFFORTS TO PRESERVE
NATIONAL WET AREAS FOR BIRDS
THAT ARE MIGRATING THROUGH THE
STATE. SO THAT'S ANOTHER
CRITICAL AREA THAT WE'RE REALLY
FOCUSED ON AS WE'RE LOOKING AT
WATER OPERATIONS. OVERALL OUR-
ONE OF OUR PRIMARY GOALS IS TO
PRESERVE STORAGE IN OUR IN THE
RESERVOIRS ARE KEY RESERVOIRS
BECAUSE WE DON'T KNOW WHY BUT
SHE WILL BRING. AND SO YOU KNOW
LOOKING AT THE GRAPHIC I HAVE UP
NOW AND AGAIN THINKING ABOUT THE
FACT THAT WE'RE STARTING AT
LOWER LEVELS. REALLY TRYING TO
PRESERVE THOSE TO GET US THROUGH
THE YEAR- AND HOPING THAT WE
CONTINUE TO HAVE STORMS LIKE WE
DO THIS WEEK HOME I THINK REALLY
MAYBE GOING BACK TO THE OCTOBER
THE BIG ATMOSPHERIC RIVER AND
THEY CAME THROUGH THE STATE. ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT THAT DID THAT
WILL BE HELPFUL AS WE MOVE
FORWARD IS TO. TUNE HIDE-
ADDITIONAL MOISTURE INTO THE
SOIL SO TO BUILD THE SOIL
MOISTURE CONTENT. SO WE DON'T
HAVE THAT THAT SORT OF REALLY
FAST AND FURIOUS AND BAD EVENT
THAT WE HAD YOU KNOW THIS LAST
YEAR WHERE THE SOILS WERE BONE
DRY DRY AND THE WATER THAT WE
GOT WAS JUST IMMEDIATELY SUCKED
UP INTO ONE SO THAT. HELPS PUT
US ON A LITTLE BETTER FOOTING-
BUT AGAIN YOU KNOW WE'RE REALLY
MANAGING TO SHOOT THESE LOW
LEVELS. AND THEN LASTLY I WANTED
TO MENTION THAT I THINK I
PROBABLY SAID IT A COUPLE
DIFFERENT WAYS- IS THAT WHAT
YOU'RE LOOKING AT THE HYDROLOGY
WE'RE LOOKING AT POTENTIAL
CLIMATE INDUCED IMPACTS LIKE
WARMER TEMPERATURES. ANOTHER
ISSUE THAT REALLY EXASPERATED
THE DROUGHT CONDITIONS THIS LAST
YEAR SO WE'RE LOOKING AT YOU
KNOW OUR TEMPERATURES AIR
TEMPERATURES LOOKING NORMAL
QUOTE UNQUOTE FOR THIS MONTH FOR
JANUARY. FOR FEBRUARY- AND KIND
OF PUT ALL OF THIS AND- TO. AND
AS THE HYDRO. OF FOR IT AS WE
HAVE WE'RE NOT COMING IN. EACH
THE RESERVOIRS ARE WE SEE THE
TREND MAY BE MOVING UP IN TERMS
OF STORAGE WE WILL BE ADJUSTING
ALLOCATION. OF WATER TO OUR
CONTRACTORS- HOPING THAT YOU
KNOW WE CANNOT SUPPLY WATER FOR
PURPOSES. IN ADDITION TO JUST
THAT YOU WILL HELP HUMAN HEALTH
AND SAFETY MEETINGS- BUT IT WILL
BE A VERY DYNAMIC PROCESS AND
AGAIN WE WILL HAVE TO ADJUST YOU
KNOW WE'RE LOOKING AT THINGS ON
A DAILY WEEKLY MONTHLY BASIS.
I'M AN ADJUSTING OUR DECISIONS
AS WE GO THROUGH. THIS GO
THROUGH THE SEASON AND GO
THROUGH OUR PROCESS SEES. SO NOW
WITH. THE NEXT LIGHT ONLY HAVE
FIVE SLIDES ARE GOING TO MAKE A
LAST I GUESS- BUT JUST AS I
PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED
GROUNDWATER. VERY CRUCIAL
RESOURCE DURING DROUGHTS
CRITICAL RESOURCE DURING ALL
TIMES BUT ESPECIALLY DURING
DROUGHT CONDITIONS- AND WE
WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT SOME MOVING
SORRY MOVING KIND OF INSURE
AREAS OF ASSISTANCE THAT THE
STATE IS PROVIDING SEVERAL THIS
IS AN EXAMPLE OF. INFORMATION
AND DATA SYSTEMS- WE JUST
RECENTLY RELEASED OUR GROUND
STATEWIDE GROUNDWATER REPORT
THAT SUMMARIZES GROUNDWATER
CONDITIONS. ON THE GROUND WATER. RESOURCES ACROSS THE WHOLE
STATE. PART OF THIS. WE NEED
WATCHED THIS NEW TOOL HELLO THE
GROUNDWATER WHAT HAPPENED SORRY
CALIFORNIA GROUNDWATER LIKE TO-
WE ARE SUPER EXCITED ABOUT THIS
TOOL IT'S WEB BASED SO ANYBODY
CAN ACCESS IT IT'S VERY USER
FRIENDLY IT CONTAINS A LOT OF
CRITICAL BROWN WATER RELATED
DATA AND INFORMATION. THAT USERS
CAN CUSTOMIZE AND THEN VISUALIZE
THE EXAMPLES I HAVE HERE AND
USED TO HELP IN GROUNDWATER
MANAGEMENT TO HELP ANSWER
QUESTIONS THEY MAY HAVE SO WE
WANTED TO MAKE SURE TO SHARE
THIS WITH EVERYONE TODAY YOU CAN
ACCESS IT THROUGH OUR WEBSITE.
IF YOU GO TO DETER YOUR WEBSITE
TO THE SUSTAINABLE GROUNDWATER
MANAGEMENT PAGE YOU'LL BE ABLE
TO GET TO THIS TOOL- JUST WANTED
TO MENTION IN LOOKING AT THE
SLIDE THIS IS JUST ONE EXAMPLE
OF WHAT YOU CAN DO WITH THE
TOOL. AND I THINK IT IS NEAR
SOME OF THE INFORMATION WE'VE
ALREADY HEARD. ALL THE- GRAPHIC
ON THE LEFT HAND SIDE IS CURRENT
WATER LEVELS IN WELLS SO THIS
GIVES YOU A SNAPSHOT YOUR JOB
RIGHT NOW- FROM OUR MONITORING
WELLS WHAT A WHAT WHAT DO WATER
LEVELS LOOK LIKE. SO THAT YOU
CAN SEE 74% OF THE WALLS THAT WE
MONITOR THE LITTLE NORMAL SO THE
WATER LEVELS ARE LOW. ABOUT 17%
OR IN THE NORMAL RANGE AT 9% OR
ABOVE NORMAL. ON THE RIGHT HAND
SIDE OF THE SLIDE YOU CAN TAKE
THAT SAME INFORMATION AND LOOK
FOR TRENDS SO THIS IS ABOUT A
TWENTY YEAR. CYCLE THAT WE'VE
LOOKED AT THE SAME INFORMATION
JUST JUST A SEAT OVER TIME
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN TERMS OF
WATER LEVELS IN WELLS. AND YOU
CAN SEE IT FOLLOWS SOMEWHAT THE
SAME PATTERN I'M A LITTLE LESS
SEVERE OVER TIME WITH 58% OF
THOSE WALLS HAVING A DECREASE IN
WATER LEVEL. THIRTY SIX
REMAINING STABLE AT ABOUT 6%
SHOWING AN INCREASE IN WATER
LEVEL. SO JUST WANTED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT EVERYONE KNEW
ABOUT THIS TOOL AND AGAIN WERE
VERY EXCITED AND I THINK IT.
WILL BE VERY HELPFUL. IN TERMS
FOR COMMUNITIES FOR GSA'S FOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WATER
SUPPLIERS TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
THIS INFORMATION- JUST AT HAND.
AS THEY NEED TO LOOK AT AND
ADDRESS DIFFERENT. QUESTIONS AND
DIFFERENT SITUATIONS. SO NOW-
WANTED TO SWITCH GEARS AGAINST
YOU MORE OF THE CATEGORY OF
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE. AND THIS
IS ONE OF THOSE AREAS THAT I
MUST SAY WE ARE VERY PLEASED TO
BE A PART OF VERY HAPPY THAT WE
CAN PROVIDE THIS TYPE OF
ASSISTANCE. SO SINCE THE PASSAGE
OF THIS YEAR'S STATE BUDGET-
THERE. YOU HAVE YOU ARE WAS MADE
RESPONSIBLE FOR WAR- PROVIDING
SMALL COMMUNITY TRAVEL SH AND SO
WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO DO FIVE
ROUNDS OF FUNDING COMMITMENTS TO
THE TOTAL ABOUT NINETY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS. AND THIS IS FOR
FORTY EIGHT PROJECTS THAT
ADDRESS SMALL COMMUNITY DROUGHT
WEEKS- IN FACT ENOUGH PENDING
APPLICATIONS IN THIS PROGRAM TO
COMMIT THE REMAINING NINETY
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS THIS
FISCAL YEAR. AS WE MOVE FORWARD
WE WILL BE PRIORITIZING
EMERGENCY DROUGHT RESPONSE
PROJECTS IN TROUBLE PROJECTS. SO
THESE ARE PROJECTS THAT HELP
SMALL COMMUNITIES REPLACE THINGS
LIKE LEAKING- SHALE DISTRIBUTION
SYSTEMS STRUCTURE DRILLING NEW
WELLS IS NEEDED FOR PROVIDING
BULK AND BOTTLED WATER FOR THOSE
COMMUNITIES WHO ARE IN MOST NEED
OF BEING ABLE TO GET. DRINKING
WATER A DOMESTIC USE WATER AND
SO ON. SO LOOKING AT THE
GRAPHICS I WOULD JUST POINT OUT
THAT THE DIFFERENT COLORED
CIRCLES ARE THE FIVE PHASES OF
THE FUNDING THAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO MOVE. TO GET OUT THE DOOR IF
YOU WILL- THIS FISCAL YEAR. AND
YOU CAN SEE THAT THE DOLLAR
AMOUNTS THAT GO WITH THOSE- YOU
CAN SEE THE DISTRIBUTION
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WE HAVE A
WIDE DISTRIBUTION OF PROJECTS
THAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO FIND SO
FAR. I WOULD NOTE THERE ORANGE
ANY DOTS IN THE VERY SOUTHERN
PART OF THE STATE- AND THAT'S
LARGELY BECAUSE IN COORDINATION
WITH THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD. WHO ALSO RECEIVED
FUNDING FROM THIS LAST STATE
BUDGET ROUNDED WHO ARE ALSO AS
MANY OF YOU KNOW RESPONSIBLE FOR
A LOT OF. PROJECTS THAT WORK
WITH SMALL COMMUNITIES AND HELP
TO ADDRESS SOME OF THEIR THEIR
DRINKING WATER ISSUES WATER
QUALITY ISSUES THEY HAVE BEEN
FOCUSING A LOT OF THEIR EFFORTS
IN THE SOUTHERN PART OF THE
STATE SO IN ORDER TO NOT
DUPLICATE EFFORTS. BUT TO BE
COORDINATED IF YOU WERE TO PUT
THEIR PROJECTS INTO THIS GRAPHIC
YOU WOULD SEE MORE JOBS IN. IN
THE SOUTHERN PART OF STATE SO.
ONE AND THEN MY LAST SLIDE IS ON
THE- URBAN MALL BENEFIT DROP
GRANTS PROGRAM AGAIN THIS IS
FUNDING THAT IS. WAS MADE
AVAILABLE WITH THE PASSAGE OF
THIS YEAR'S STATE BUDGET- D. W.
R. IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
IMPLEMENTING THIS GRANT PROGRAMS
AND GETTING THESE AWARDS OUT. WE
HAVE SO FAR TO FUNDING PHASES
ONE THAT WERE JUST ABOUT TO WRAP
UP IN ANOTHER ONE THAT WE'RE IN
MID PROCESS WITH. THERE'S A
TOTAL OF TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
SIX MILLION DOLLARS AVAILABLE
FOR THESE GRANT AWARDS WE HAVE
DONE A SET ASIDE FOR UNDER
REPRESENTED COMMUNITIES AND
TRIBAL PROJECTS. TO THE TUNE OF
ABOUT FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS TO
OUR FIRST PHASE HI THESE GRANT
AWARDS WILL BE RELEASED IN LATE
DECEMBER SO JUST AROUND THE
CORNER- THESE WERE GRANTS THAT
IN APPLICATIONS RECEIVED IN MID
NOVEMBER WE REVIEWED THEM AND
WE'RE GETTING READY TO. MAKE
THOSE AWARDS THE SECOND PHASE WE
HAVE OPEN NOW- IT'S CURRENTLY
OPEN THROUGHOUT THE MIDDLE OF
JANUARY AND THEN WE'LL WE'LL
WE'LL REVIEW THOSE GRANT
APPLICATIONS AND ANTICIPATE
MAKING AWARDS- BY MARCH OF NEXT
YEAR SO FIRST QUARTER OF NEXT
YEAR. IN THE BOTTOM HALF OF THIS
FLIGHT JUST GIVES YOU THE
BREAKDOWN BETWEEN THE URBAN
COMMUNITY FUND AND THE MULTI
BENEFIT- PROJECT FUND. SO AGAIN
THESE ARE PROJECTS
INFRASTRUCTURE RELATED TO OTHER
PROJECTS BUT FOR THE URBAN
COMMUNITIES AND FOR MULTI
BENEFITS DROP PROJECTS THAT
HELP- ADDRESS MANY DIFFERENT
TYPES. OF DRUG RELATED IMPACTS.
SO TO LAST POINT AND THEN I WILL
BE I'M AND I WANT TO JUST TOUCH
BRIEFLY ON THE COMMUNICATION
COORDINATION ASSISTANCE THAT THE
DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN WORKING ON.
AGAIN NOT ALWAYS BY YOURSELF
DEFINITELY IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
OTHERS. FIRST ONE I WANTED TO
MENTION IS THAT WE WILL BE
SHORTLY VERY SHORTLY RELEASING A
SET OF DRINKING WATER WELL
CONSOLES AND STRATEGIES. RIGHT A
FRAMEWORK FOR GUIDING STATE
ACTIONS IN ADMINISTRATION
PROGRAM SUCH AS THE SUSTAINABLE
GROUNDWATER MANAGEMENT PROGRAM
FOR THE STATE BOARD'S SAVER
PROGRAM. THESE ARE THE
PRINCIPLES AND STRATEGIES
RECOGNIZE IMPORTANCE OF
GROUNDWATER AS A DRINKING WATER
SOURCE FOR PRIVATE WELLS AND
PUBLIC SMALL PUBLIC SYSTEMS SO
THIS IS A SET OF PRINCIPLES AND
STRATEGIES THAT HELP FURTHER
INTEGRATE THE STATE AND OUR
ACTIONS WERE ADMINISTRATION. OF
VARIOUS EFFORTS AND ACTIVITIES
WITH THE LOCALS NON NON
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS
TRIBAL ORGANIZATIONS GSK'S AND
OTHER LOCAL ENTITIES SO THESE
ARE MEANT TO PROVIDE A FRAMEWORK
IN WHICH WE CAN MOVE FORWARD. TO
BUILD MORE RESILIENCE- SPACE A
DRINK IT FOR SMALL WORLD PRIVATE
WELLS AND SMALL SYSTEMS THAT
PROVIDE DRINKING WATER. ARND ARM
THE LAST POINT I WANT TO MAKE IS
ON OUTREACH SO- AS YOU ALL MAY
REMEMBER WE UTILIZED SAVE OUR
WATER- OUTREACH CAMPAIGN WE
UTILIZE THIS DURING THE LAST
DROUGHT WE ARE UTILIZING IT
AGAIN WE HAVE GREAT SUCCESS WITH
IT LASKO AROUND. SO WE ARE ONCE
AGAIN- USING THE SAME OR WATER
AFTER PLATFORM. IF YOU WILL
RECALL IT'S MEANT TO REALLY-
IT'S TARGETED AT RESIDENTIAL
WATER USERS SO IT'S MENTOR
PROVIDES REALLY SIMPLE WAYS THAT
RESIDENTIAL RESIDENTS CAN.
REDUCE THEIR WATER USE WITHIN
OUR HOUSE AROUND THE HOUSE WAYS
TO KINDERGARTEN GOING- BUT WITH
LESS WATER. SO WE HAVEN'T DONE A
LOT OF ADVERTISEMENTS TODAY WE
WILL CONTINUE TO UTILIZE A LOT
OF SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS TO GET
MESSAGING OUT WE ARE DOING THIS
IN DIFFERENT LANGUAGES WE ARE
TARGETING DIFFERENT TYPES OF
MARKETS I'M IN COMMUNITIES
RECOGNIZING THAT PRIORITIES
MIGHT BE DIFFERENT INFORMATION
NEEDS MIGHT BE DIFFERENT. SO
WILL BE MORE TO COME ON THAT AS
WE MOVE INTO THE NEW YEAR BUT
THAT IS DEFINITELY ONE OF THOSE
AREAS THAT I WANTED TO MAKE
SURE- IN TERMS OF COMMUNICATION
THAT THE STATE IS APPROACHING
AGAIN. A STATEWIDE. USING THIS
TOOL TO ACHIEVE THAT. SO THINK
THAT I AM- MY PRESENT AND HAPPY
TO ADDRESS QUESTIONS WORLD THE
TIME IS RIGHT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU BOTH FOR YOUR PRESENTATIONS
AT THIS MOMENT I WILL OPEN UP-
THIS PART OF THE OF THE
COMMITTEE PROVIDE FOR QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND SO
WHEN IT JUST AFRAID OF
SUNDERLAND SEARCHES QUESTIONS
FOR THE- TWO SPEAKERS. YES THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR- SO I WANT TO
THANK THE PRESENTERS FOR THE
INFORMATION THERE SAID BREADTH
OF INFORMATION THAT YOU SHARED
SOME OF WHICH YOU KNOW WE ARE
ALL AWARE OF- BUT A LITTLE MORE
DETAIL- ON THOSE WHICH I
APPRECIATE BUT WE TALK A LOT.
ABOUT THE RAMIFICATIONS OF. NOT
HAVING ENOUGH WATER BUT I WONDER
IF SOMEONE CAN ANSWER THIS VERY
SIMPLE QUESTION WHICH IS. WHAT
WOULD THE COST BE. IF WE WERE
TO- BUILD THE. RESERVOIRS IN AND
EVERYTHING WE WOULD NEED TO
CONSERVE MORE WATER FOR
CALIFORNIANS WHAT WOULD THAT
COST BE IF WE WERE TO DO THAT SO
THAT WHEN WE WERE IN THE SEVERE
DROUGHT YEARS. CALIFORNIANS
WOULD BE ENSURED THAT THEY WOULD
HAVE THE WATER THAT THEY NEED
CAN ANYONE ANSWER THAT QUESTION
FOR ME BY ANY CHANCE. THIS IS
RACHEL EVANS WITH THE LA OUT- I
THINK THE INFORMATION AND I
DON'T HAVE IT ON HAND BUT I'M
HAPPY TO SEND IT THAT THAT WE
HAVE IS ESTIMATED COSTS OF THE
PROPOSED. KIND OF RESERVOIRS
AND- AND GROUNDWATER PROPOSALS
FOR THE PROPOSITION ONE WATER
STORAGE FUNDING. SO WE HAVE COST
ESTIMATES FOR THAT IN TERMS OF
HOW MUCH WOULD IT COST TO KIND
OF ADDRESS ALL CALIFORNIA'S
WATER NEEDS AND THAT IS NOT A
NUMBER I'VE SEEN IT NOW OR AN
ESTIMATE THAT I'VE SEEN- BUT WE
CERTAINLY DO HAVE ESTIMATES FOR.
PROPOSED THAT TOTAL COST OF SOME
OF THAT PROPOSED WATER STORAGE
PROJECTS OF THAT- AND THEN THAT
WOULD BE IN THAT KIND OF-
MULTIPLE BILLION DOLLAR. RANGE
BUT HAPPY HAPPY I THINK YOU KNOW
I WANT TO SAY FOURTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS OF OFF THE TOP OF MY
HEAD FOR THOSE PROP ONE THE
TOTAL COST OF THOSE PROPOSED
PROP ONE STORAGE PROJECTS BEAT
THEIR EIGHT OF THEM- BUT HAPPY
TO FOLLOW UP WITH YOUR OFFICE
WITH MORE SPECIFIC THAT THAT'S-
KIND OF THE- THE BEST ESTIMATE I
HAVE I DON'T KNOW IF MISS MESSER. HAS HAS MORE TO OFFER. I'M NOW
MUCH MORE IN I WOULD I THINK
THOSE ARE PROBABLY OUR BEST AND
GIVE THEY GIVE US THE BEST IDEA
OF WHAT THESE TYPES OF PROJECTS
COST AND- YOU KNOW THEY- WERE
LIMITED. IN THE AREAS IN WHICH
WE CAN INSTALL THESE KIND OF
PROJECTS SO THERE'S ALSO THAT
THE IDEA THAT WE YOU KNOW THAT
MIGHT BE IT. THE LEASE FOR NOW
ON SORT OF THE INFRASTRUCTURE
SIDE. I WOULD ALSO SAY TO
THERE'S THERE STORAGE THERE'S
INFRASTRUCTURE I THINK THERE'S
ALSO A LOT. TO BE GAINED ON THE
CONSERVATION SIDE AND I KNOW
THAT'S PROBABLY A LITTLE HARDER
TO PUT A PRICE TAG ON BUT I
THINK THAT'S- PART OF THE SUPER
WATER CAMPAIGN- WE HAVE VARIOUS
WATER MANAGEMENT PLANS- THAT.
YOU KNOW WE LOOK TO THE LOCAL
WATER SUPPLIERS TO IMPLEMENT
WATER CONSERVATION MEASURES. I
KNOW THE GOVERNOR BROWN HAD THE
25% REDUCTION GOVERNOR NEWSOM IS
ASKING FOR FIFTEEN PERCENT.
ABOVE THOSE LEVELS BUT I THINK
THERE ARE AREAS IN THE HOLE IN
MY MIND THE WHOLE THING IS AN
EQUATION SO YOU'VE GOT SUPPLY.
WE'VE GOT SOME DEMAND BUT
SOMEWHERE IN THERE THERE ARE
DIFFERENT MEASURES YOU CAN TAKE
TO REALLY KIND OF. IF YOU WILL.
IT. INCREASED WATER THAT WE HAVE
. AT OUR DISPOSAL SO I'M TO
FOLLOW UP ON SURE SOME OF OUR
FOLKS WILL HAVE TO MEDICINAL
PERMISSION YOU CAN PACKAGE FOR.
HOURS AND PERMISSION. THANK YOU
LADIES I APPRECIATE THAT IN THE
END IT'S A COMPLICATED ISSUE
CLEARLY- I JUST YOU KNOW I'M
LEFT TO WONDER. IF WE WOULD JUST
INVEST THE MONEY PARTICULARLY IN
YEARS LIKE THIS YEAR AND LAST
YEAR WHERE WE HAD- A BUDGET
SURPLUS AND IF WE COULD PERHAPS
INVEST THAT MONEY IN. SOME OF
THIS INFRASTRUCTURE SO THAT YOU
KNOW IT WE WOULD HAVE IT IN
PLACE BECAUSE AS WE KNOW. THE
LONGER YOU WAIT THE MORE
EXPENSIVE IT. BECOMES TO DO
PROJECTS LIKE THIS AND IT'S A
BIG TICKET ITEM FOR SURE AND I
THINK. YOU KNOW.
ADMINISTRATION'S OFTENTIMES ARE
HSITANT TO. KIND OF SPEND
EVERYTHING IN THE ACCOUNT BUT- I
THINK THERE'S A LOT MORE WORK
THAT WE COULD BE DOING THAT
WE'VE THAT WE'VE NOT YET DONE-
EVEN GIVEN THE FACT THAT MOST OF
OUR WATER USE IS NOT FROM
RESIDENTIAL CONSUMERS BUT REALLY
FROM THE AGRICULTURAL COMMUNITY.
HOWEVER WE- FEED THE COUNTRY YOU
KNOW WITH OUR FRUITS AND
VEGETABLES AND I THINK IT'S-
WHAT TWO THIRDS. COMES FROM
CALIFORNIA SO. WE CERTAINLY HAVE
A VESTED INTEREST NOT ONLY IN
THE HEALTH OF CALIFORNIANS BUT
IN THE REST OF THE COUNTRY WHO
DEPEND ON US. AND I THINK WE
HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO. INVEST IN
THE THINGS WE NEED TO INVEST IN
TO MAKE SURE THAT. NOT ONLY A
RESIDENTIAL USERS HAVE THE WATER
THAT THEY NEED BETTER
AGRICULTURAL USERS TO BECAUSE
THEY'RE DOING EVERYTHING THEY
CAN. YOU KNOW FOR SURE I MEAN
THERE'S- THERE'S A LOT OF
INNOVATION OUT THERE THERE'S-
CERTAINLY- SOME INNOVATION THAT
HAS COME FROM THE PAST AND
CONTINUES TO COME FROM ISRAEL
WITH RESPECT TO WATER
CONSERVATION MAKING BETTER USE
OF THE SUPPLY THAT WE HAVE BUT I
FIRMLY BELIEVE THAT. WE CAN DO
MORE WE JUST HAVEN'T DONE IT-
FOR A FOR A NUMBER O REASONS
BYE I THINK THE- THE CHAIRWOMAN
PROBABLY M. SHARES. SOME OF THAT
STUFF OPINION I WOULD IMAGINE-
PARTICULARLY FROM THE AREA THAT
SHE LIVES AND I KNOW MY SON
WHO'S IN THE NAVY STATION AND
LEARN MORE AND YOU KNOW I TALKED
HIM THE OTHER NIGHT AND FOUND
OUT THAT THEY HAVE TO BUY WATER
WHEN THEY CAN'T DRINK THE TAP
WATER WHICH IS. I MEAN THAT'S
IT'S FOREIGN TO MANY PEOPLE WHO
YOU KNOW I JUST DON'T UNDERSTAND
WHAT YOU MEAN YOU CAN'T TURN ON
YOUR TAP AND DRINK THE WATER BUT
THEY CANNOT AND THAT'S YOU KNOW
THAT'S ON SOME THIRD WORLD
COUNTRY THAT SIXTEEN CALIFORNIA
FOR GOODNESS SAKE- SO. I THANK
YOU FOR THE INFORMATION- THE
FOURTEEN BILLION OR YOU KNOW
IT'S PROBABLY MORE THAN THAT
THAT YOU ESTIMATED IT WOULD COST
TO PUT WHAT WE NEED TO PUT IN
PLACE TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE- NOW
I'M PRETTY SURE WE HAD THAT IN
THE BUDGET THIS YEAR ON THAT WE
COULD HAVE SPENT BUT AGAIN WE
HAVE TO FACTOR IN THE
ENVIRONMENTAL INTERESTS IN THE
REGULATORY INTERESTS THAT COME
INTO PLAY THAT OFTEN TIMES STOP
PROJECTS LIKE THIS FROM GOING
FORWARD BUT PERHAPS. THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD TAKE A LOOK
AT SOME OF THESE REGULATIONS AND
POLICIES AND DETERMINE WHETHER
OR NOT THEY CAN BE ADJUSTED SO
THAT WE CAN ADDRESS THE WATER-
ISSUE THAT WE HAVE IN CALIFORNIA
THINKING MANAGER. THANK YOU
CENTER MELINDA'S AND THANK YOU
FOR ON POINTING OUT THAT. THE
CHALLENGES THAT- THAT MANY
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA FIFTEEN AND LACK
OF ACCESS TO WATER VERTICAL
LAMAR PORCELAIN MARS AND MY
SENATE DISTRICT AND- IT'S LIKE
AS YOU SAID IT'S NOT SOME THIRD
WORLD COUNTRY WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT. CALIFORNIA THE- YEAH ONE
OF THE TOP FIVE LARGEST
ECONOMIES IN THE WORLD- THAT
SHOULDN'T BE HAPPENING AND THAT
THAT IS EXACTLY WHY WE ARE YOU
KNOW HERE TODAY AND- WORKING ON
HUMAN SECURITY ISSUES BECAUSE
IT'S- IT GOES BEYOND THAT TEND.
AND I HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS-
FOR OUR OUR TWO SPEAKERS- I HAVE
ONE FOR OUR FIRST SPEAKER AND A
COUPLE COUPLE OF OTHER.
QUESTIONS FOR ANYONE THEY CAN
ANSWER ON THE QUESTION THAT I
HAVE THE FIRST ONE IS- ANOTHER
WAS MENTION OF A LOT OF FUNDS
FROM PROP ONE FOR STORAGE THAT
WERE USED- AND IN PART AND YOU
KNOW PLEASE FEEL FREE TO-
CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG. KIND OF
ATTRIBUTE IT TO. THE REASON WHY
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND PART WAS
DOING WELL IN TERMS OF- NOT
REALLY TAPPING A HOLE LOT INTO
THE GROUND WATER. AND I GUESS MY
QUESTION TO THE ALLEY- IS THE
ALIENS OFFICES DO WE HAVE REALLY
AN EQUITABLE. A WATER WATER
STORAGE THROUGHOUT EVERY PART OF
CALIFORNIA WHERE COMMUNITIES.
ARE LIVE- IF YOU HAVE IT QUICKLY
FEEL FREE
YOU ARE STRONGER I'M- YEAH I
THINK ONE IMPORTANT POINT IS
THAT- DIFFERENT AREAS OF THE
STATE DEPEND ON DIFFERENT
SOURCES OF WATER SO THERE ARE
THERE IN THE TIME ALLOWED FOR
EXAMPLE THERE'S A GREAT
DEPENDENCE ON GROUNDWATER. I'M
IN PART BECAUSE THEY HAVE OUR
CULTURES THAT HAVE HSTORICALLY
BEEN ABLE TO STORM WATER AND BE
WITHDRAWN AND THEN RESELL THAT'S
NOT THE CASE EVERYWHERE IN THE
STATE THERE ARE CERTAIN AREAS
WHERE THERE ISN'T MUCH
DEPENDENCE ON GROUNDWATER AT ALL
IT'S ALMOST ALL IN SURFACE WATER
FOR EXAMPLE LIKE IN THE-
SANDIEGO THERE'S NOT MUCH
GROUNDWATER- PUMPING OR USAGE.
THERE ARE CERTAIN AREAS OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA THINKING IN
THE VENTURA AREA WHERE THERE IS
A QUITE A BIT OF A GROUNDWATER
USAGE BUT OTHER AREAS THAT
AREN'T SO AND THAT MAKES IT
COMPLICATED- AND THE NEED FOR
ABOVE GROUND STORAGE VERSES WITH
UNDERGROUND STORAGE VARIES
AROUND THE STATE- THERE ARE
PARTS OF THE STATE TO GET A LOT
OF PRECIPITATION THERE OTHER
BIRDS THAT DON'T GET A LOT OF
PRECIPITATION SO. WE DO NEED TO
PAY A VARIED APPROACH ACROSS THE
STATE ONE SIZE DOES NOT FIT ALL
I AM GIVING MONEY FOR
GROUNDWATER TO EVERY AREA OF THE
STATE WOULD MAKE SENSE BECAUSE
SOME AREAS OF THE STATE DON'T
HAVE GROUND WATER AND DON'T USE
IT SO. I THINK THAT DOES
HIGHLIGHT THE IMPORTANCE OF- A
REGIONAL APPROACH AND ENSURING
THAT EACH REGION GETS WHAT THEY
NEED I WILL SAY SOME OF THE
INVESTMENTS IN STORAGE ABOVE
GROUND STORAGE IN PARTICULAR IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA HAVE BEEN
FUNDED LOCALLY NOT BY THE STATE-
BY YOU KNOW FOR EXAMPLE
METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT HAS
HAS SOME ABOVE GROUND-
RESERVOIRS THAT THEY'RE THAT
THEY'RE REPAIRS TO PAY FOR NOT
NOT AND NOT PRIMARILY THROUGH
THE STATE- SO I THINK YOUR POINT
SENATOR ABOUT EQUITY IS AN
IMPORTANT ONE. I THINK THE POINT
THAT I WOULD HIGHLY IN RESPONSE
IS THAT WE CAN'T TAKE A ONE SIZE
FITS ALL BECAUSE THAT WILL
INHERENTLY BE AN EQUITABLE- WE
HAVE TO LOOK AT WHAT THE NEEDS
ARE OF EACH REGION WHERE THEIR
WATER SUPPLY COMES FROM WHAT THE
REPAIRS ARE ABLE TO SUSTAIN
VERSUS AREAS THAT DON'T HAVE A
RATE BASE THAT CAN'T SUSTAIN IT-
M. AND WHERE THEY MIGHT BE WORSE
THE STATE ASSISTANCE IN ORDER TO
MEET OUR HUMAN RIGHT TO WATER-
BECAUSE BECAUSE IT IS A REALLY
COMPLEX PICTURE ACROSS THE STATE
AS DIVERSE AS OURS. ABSOLUTELY
AND THANK YOU FOR THAT YES IT'S
IT IS COMPLICATED AND AT
DIFFERENT- IT'S NOT ONE SIZE
FITS ALL BUT SOMETHING I ALWAYS
SAY SO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THAT ANSWER AND. I HAVE A COUPLE
OTHER QUESTIONS- THERE ARE A
ALSO MENTION OF IRAQI HEALTH
YOUR WATER FOR HUMAN HEALTH. IT
REALLY INTERESTED AND KNOWING- A
LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT WHAT THAT
EXACTLY MEANS FOR THAT DAY
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES- I
ALSO ASIDE FROM. THE BUREAU OF
RECLAMATION WHAT OTHER AENCIES
IS AT D. W. ARE WORKING WITH TO
UNDERSTAND THE CHALLENGES THE
CHALLENGES FACING DELTAS- AND OR
SUBSIDENCE. ISSUES THE OTHER
QUESTION WHAT MACRO CHANGES
COULD BE MADE TO THE CALIFORNIA
WATER SYSTEM. AND THE REALITY OF
CLIMATE CHANGE AND ITS IMPACT ON
WHETHER WATER SUPPLY RELIABILITY
AND- HUMAN FOOD INSECURITY. AND
HOW DO WE DO WE NEED DO WE NEED
TO LOOK AT MAJORY OPERATION OF
THE SYSTEM OR CAN WE MAKE
ADJUSTMENTS TO CAPTURE MORE
WATER. MORE EFFICIENTLY FROM
LIKE ATMOSPHERIC RIVERS RIVERS.
R. L. SO WONDERING- HOW DO WE
MORE EFFECTIVELY MANAGE THE
WATER SYSTEM FOR PROTECTION
DURING THE WINTER MONTHS BUT
ALSO FOR WATER SUPPLY FOR FARMS
PEOPLE AND OF THE ENVIRONMENT IN
SUMMER MONTHS. AND IF THE OTHER
QUESTION ARE ALL TRIED TO STOP
THERE AFTER AND WHATEVER YOU DO
YOU CAN ANSWER CRATE AND
WHATEVER YOU CAN'T- UP AT ANY
ANY INFORMATION DUMPED ON THE
ROAD IT'S UP GREATLY APPRECIATED
AS WELL. BUT THE LAST QUESTION I
HAVE IS THE ERROR THERE WAS A
REPORT BACK IN TWENTY TWELVE ON
THE GLOBAL OUR WATER SECURITY
AND APPOINTED TO WATER AS- THE
POTENTIAL USE OF THE WEAPON AND
I'M I'M INTERESTED IN KNOWING
HOW TO WHAT EXTENT YOUR
DEPARTMENTS ARE. B. ALLELES
OFFICE IS DOING TO COMBAT
THINGS. THAT COULD BE USED AS
AS- YOU'LL LOVE OUR AS A WEAPON
OR AS LEVERAGE- ARE WE LOOKING
AT WHAT MORE WE DOING IN TERMS
OF WATER THEFT WHAT ARE WE DOING
IN TERMS OF CYBER THREATS TO
WATER INFRASTRUCTURE- AND OF
COURSE THERE FOR TWO ALSO OUR
FOOD SUPPLY CHAIN- AT THOSE ARE
A LOT OF QUESTIONS AND ALSO IF
YOU NEED ME TO REPEAT ANY OF
THEM. FEEL FREE. TO LET ME KNOW. ALL RIGHT. I'LL JUMP IN FIRST
AND I MAY NEED YOU TO REPEAT
SOME OF THOSE ARE TRYING TO JOT
DOWN AS MANY AS I COULD BUT-
THANK YOU FOR THOSE QUESTIONS-
HONESTLY THERE WAS SOMETHING
THAT I FORGOT TO MENTION MY LAST
RESPONSE BUT THIS KIND OF I
THINK I COULD PULL IT. INTO INTO
A DRESS BUT- SO I THINK MAYBE
THE KIND OF COVER THIS IDEA OF.
OPERATING THE SYSTEM HAVING SOME
FLEXIBILITY TO CAPTURE WATER
WHEN WE HAVE THOSE WET EVENTS.
THAT ALSO KIND OF FACTORS INTO
SOME OF THE FLOOD MANAGEMENT-
PIECES ONE THING I WANTED TO
MENTION THAT I DIDN'T WAS- AS
PART OF. THE STATE. BUDGET THAT
WAS RECENTLY PASSED. SLASH
BUDGET OF PASSED- THE- STATE WAS
AWARDED OVER THREE GW ARE WE
HAVE A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
THAT IS- SLATED FOR WHAT WE'RE
CALLING THE CONVEYANCE OF
SCIENCE PROGRAM. AND SO THIS IS
A PROGRAM THAT WE WERE LOOKING
AT THE- FLOOR OF THE MAJOR WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE SYSTEMS IN THE
STATES OF THE CALIFORNIA
AQUEDUCT THAT'S PART OF THE
STATE WATER PROJECT- THE- ST
LOUIS ADULT. SORRY ST LOUIS
CANAL DELTA MENDOTA CANAL IN THE
CURRENT TRYING CURRENT CANAL. SO
MAJOR WATER INFRASTRUCTURE THAT. HAS SUFFERED FROM SUBSIDES.
THE SO HE YOU CAN. AND SOME OF
THOSE AREAS THE CAPACITY TO MOVE
WATER HAS BEEN GREATLY
DIMINISHED OVER THE YEARS AND
SO- THE STATE HOUSE IS PROVIDING
FUNDING IT'S A CULTURE
MECHANISM- SO THE STATE IS
PUTTING A PORTION THE LOCALS AND
THE FEDS FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
ALSO PUTTING IN THEIR SHARE SHE-
WE BUILD THIS INFRASTRUCTURE SO
THAT. THERE'S A HUNDRED MILLION
FROM THIS BUDGET YEAR THEY'LL BE
A HUNDRED MILLION MORE IN THE
NEXT BUDGET YEAR THAT GO TOWARDS
THIS PARTICULAR EFFORTS- AND
WHAT THAT DOES OVER IN A COUPLE
COUPLE DIFFERENT WAYS IS. IT
WITHIN TEN YEARS WILL BE ABLE TO
INCREASE THE CAPACITY OF WATER
THAT MOVES IN SOME OF THOSE
AREAS IT'S BEEN DIMINISHED BY
50% OR MORE A LITTLE BIT MORE.
SO WE'LL BE ABLE TO TAKE WATER
BUT WE HAVE IT MOVE IT THROUGH
THE SYSTEM. WILL HAVE MORE
FLEXIBILITY AROUND THAT. WHAT
WE'RE ALSO WILL AT THAT I THINK
IS KIND OF IN CONJUNCTION TO
THIS IS GROUND WATER RECHARGE SO
WHAT ARE SOME OF THE
OPPORTUNITIES AND THIS IS A BIG
PART OF. FALLS UNDER THE CIGNA A
BRAWL IN SOME WAYS BUT IT'S ALSO
REALLY ITS OWN ENTITY I THINK
UNDER CLIMATE CHANGE RESILIENCY
DROUGHT RESILIENCY. ON FLOOD
MANAGEMENT IS FINDING WAYS TO
TAKE WATER TAKE THAT EXCESS
WATER GET IT BACK INTO
GROUNDWATER- AUTHOR YES
GROUNDWATER AQUIFERS SH SO THAT
WE ARE BUILDING BACK THAT
STORAGE SO WE HAVE RESILIENCY
WHEN AGAIN THE WEATHER TURNS TRY
INSTRUCTORS WATER IS. LIMITED SO
THAT THESE ARE EFFORTS THAT WE
ARE WORKING ON NEW CONSTRUCTION
WITH SEVERAL OF OUR STATE
PARTNERS THE STATE WATER BOARD.
HELLO FROM YOUR DEPARTMENT FISH
WILDLIFE JUST TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT THINGS LIKE
STREAMS AND- WILDLIFE HABITAT
AND MAKING SURE THAT'S PART OF
THE FACTOR IN ADDITION TO THE-
THE HUMAN NEED FOR WATER- WE ARE
ALSO WORKING WITH. A LOT OF THE
LOCAL ENTITIES SO THE
GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY
AGENCIES NGOS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TRIBES. WORKING WITH OUR FEDERAL
PARTNERS US BUREAU OF
RECLAMATION BEING ONE. OF THOSE
PARTNERS SO IT'S KIND OF A
NETWORK IF YOU WILL A BUS. OR
WALKED AS WATER AND GIGI'S IN
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE REALLY
TRYING TO COME TOGETHER. TO
CREATE SOME FLEXIBILITY AND
RESILIENCY I THINK THOSE ARE THE
KEY WORDS REALLY FOR ME AS I
LOOK AHEAD- IN TERMS OF HOW TO.
GET THE MOST BANG FOR OUR BUCK
DURING THE WET. FLOOD PERIOD
CERTAIN OPTION APPEARS BUT THE
WET. WEATHER YEARS AND THEN HOW
TO BE RESILIENT AND MAKE OUR WAY
THROUGH THOSE DRIER PERIODS. IN
TIME OUR OWN. OPEN FOR CASTING I
THINK THE OTHER PIECE OF IT I
DON'T TALKED A LOT BIT OF- VW
ARE YOU DON'T AS A- IN. OF
LOOKING AT RAINFALL AT SNOW
PACKED LOOKING AT TEMPERATURES
WERE RELEASED RECENTLY BECAUSE
OF LAST YEAR WERE REALLY
STARTING TO FIND WAYS TO LOOK AT
THINGS LIKE SOIL MOISTURE
CONTENT- SO WE ARE WORKING TO
ENHANCE OUR FORECASTING
ABILITIES. BUT I THINK ALLOW US
TO OPERATE THE SYSTEM IN A WAY
THAT MATCHES THE CONDITIONS. AND
WE KNOW THE CONDITIONS OF
EXTREME AND THEIR DYNAMIC BUT
THE- FORECASTING WILL BE A KEY
ELEMENT THAT I THINK HELPS US BE
ABLE TO OPERATE AND ADJUST THOSE
OPERATIONS AS NEEDED- GIVEN
WATER THE WATER YEAR BRINGS US.
SO I'M SURE I AM MISSING SOME
ELEMENTS BUT- WANTED TO SHARE
THOSE TOPPLING STRINGS AND WILL
GLADLY TURN IT OVER TO. THE
SELLERS FOR STOCKS. I DON'T HAVE
TOO MUCH TO ADD OTHER THAN-
SENATOR I'M REALLY GLAD THAT YOU
MENTIONED FLOOD IN A DROUGHT
HEARING. BECAUSE THEY DO GO
TOGETHER YEAH I. IN OCTOBER OF
THIS YEAR OCTOBER TWENTY TWENTY
ONE THE CTY OF SACRAMENTO HAD
SET THE RECORD FOR THE MOST
NUMBER OF DRY DAYS WITHOUT
PRECIPITATION. IN ON RECORD TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY FOUR DAYS AND
THEN A FEW DAYS LATER SET THE
RECORD FOR THE MOST RAINFALL
WITHIN A TWENTY FOUR HOUR
PERIOD. SO WE JUST A FEW DAYS
APART THOSE TWO DIFFERENT.
RECORDS SO I THINK THAT JUST
HIGHLIGHTS THE EXTREMES THAT WE
ARE FACING UNDER UNDER CLIMATE
CHANGE AND- IN ORDER TO PREPARE
AND SUSTAIN THROUGH DROUGHTS WE
HAVE TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THESE
REALLY FLASHY WENT STORMS THAT
WE'RE GOING TO SEE MORE AND MORE
OF SO- I. GO AWAY AND THIS
SEMESTER SAID ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF MANAGED AQUIFER
RECHARGE HOW DO WE GET THOSE
FLOOD WATERS NOT ONLY NOT
CLEANING PEOPLE'S HOMES BUT ALSO
IN THE PLACES WHERE WE CAN SLOW
THEM SPREAD THEM SYNC THEM TO
GET THAT WATER INTO THE GROUND.
AND THEN ALSO THE IMPORTANCE OF
FORECASTING SO THAT WE KNOW
WHAT'S COMING WHEN IT'S COMING
SO THAT WE'RE NOT DRAINING OUR
RESERVOIRS TO CREATE RANDOM. FOR
FLOOD CONTROL WHEN WE'RE NOT
GONNA GET STOPPED BECAUSE I MEAN
THAT WE DON'T NEED TO. CREATE
THAT EMPTY ROOM IN THE
RESERVOIRS WE CAN STORE THAT
WATER BECAUSE THERE'S NOT A
STORM COMING- AND THEN WHEN A
STORM IS COMING HOW CAN WE
PREPARE FOR AND HOW CAN WE BUILD
THE FACILITIES AND IT AND IT IS
GONNA TAKE CONSTRUCTION- AN
INFRASTRUCTURE. OF WEIGHT HOW DO
WE GET THE WATER WHERE IT CAN BE
SUNK AND THEN HOW DO WE GET THE
WATER FROM THERE TO WHERE IT IS
NEEDED SO- IN THINKING ABOUT
INFRASTRUCTURE WOULD SAY IT'S
NOT JUST A BIG ABOVE THE GROUND
DAMS AND RESERVOIRS ANYMORE I
THINK THAT THAT FUTURE IS REALLY
THINKING ABOUT- THIS CONJUNCTIVE
USE SPAN. AND IN PARTICULAR
FLOOD WATERS AND GROUNDWATER AND
HOW DO WE. CAPTURE THAT WATER
AND THEN YOU SAID. WELL I WILL.
LEAVE MY QUESTION IN THT THAT-
THANK YOU SO MUCH TO YOU BOTH- I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE TIME THAT
YOU'VE TAKEN- HERE. NEAR THE
HOLIDAYS- TO COME OUT AND TALK
ABOUT WATER AND THAT THE DROUGHT
OF COURSE AND- AND REALLY LIKE
INCENTIVE BUT THIS REALLY IS
ABOUT- THE HUMAN IMPACTS THAT-
THAT. THAT THE DROUGHT- AND THE
CHALLENGES THAT PEOPLE FACE SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH TO BOTH BUT
BUT ONE LAST THING THAT A LOSS
FROM THIS- PANEL IS IF I COULD
HAVE COPIES OF THE SLIDE DECK SO
WE CAN. REVIEW OUR- DOWN THE
DOWN THE ROAD. ABSOLUTELY THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU THANK YOU
OKAY OUR NEXT STOP ISN'T PANEL
OVER TO THE KID AND HUMAN
IMPACTS OF FOOD HEALTH AND LABOR
WE HAVE OUR FIRST STOP- LESLIE
LIPPER A NATURAL RESOURCE
ECONOMIST SENIOR ENVIRONMENTAL
COLUMNIST FOR FOOD FOR THE FOOD
AND AGRICULTURE ORGANIZATION THE
UNITED NATIONS THE RETIRED-
LOVELY WELCOME. AND FEEL FREE TO
BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY. CAN YOU
HEAR ME. WE CAN HEAR YOU NOW
OKAY GOOD. THANK YOU. I MUST SAY
I'VE HAD A COUPLE OF THE WIFI
HERE IS A LITTLE BIT UNSTABLE SO
I'M JUST CROSSING MY FINGERS
THAT IT'LL STAY FOR THIS PART OF
THE PRESENTATION- THIS WE'RE
GONNA HAVE A BIT OF A CHANGE IN
THIS IN MY PRESENTATION AWAY
FROM CALIFORNIA'S REALLY
INTERESTING. L. EXPLANATION OF
WHAT'S GOING ON WITH CALIFORNIA
WATER CALIFORNIA DROUGHT. AND TO
MOVE TO A LITTLE BIT OF A
DIFFERENT POINT OF PERSPECTIVE.
OKAY PUT THE SOCK. OKAY. S. S.
THAT OKAY GET READY SET. YES WE
CAN OKAY GOOD SO LIVING AWAY
FROM CALIFORNIA THIS IS THE SORT
OF TAKING A PERSPECTIVE OF FOOD
SECURITY AS USED BY THE FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE ORGANIZATION OF THE
UNITED NATIONS. LOOKING FOR USE
IN THAT PERSPECTIVE TO LOOK AT.
WHAT ARE DIFFERENT KINDS OF
DROUGHT IMPACTS AND WHAT WE SING
ALSO WHAT'S CHANGING ABOUT IT.
S. SOME OF WHICH WILL BE OF
COURSE NOT AS RELEVANT
CALIFORNIA SOME OF THAT WILL BE
VERY RELEVANT BUT IN BOTH CASES
I THINK WILL HELP. SORT OF
CLARIFY SOME OF THE ISSUES OF
HUMAN IMPACT SINK IN CALIFORNIA
. L- WILL ALSO BRING IN A LITTLE
BIT OF THE DISCUSSIONS THAT CAME
UP THIS YEAR IN THE FATHER WAS A
U. N. FOOD SYSTEM SUMMIT. WERE
ALSO SOME OF THE DROUGHT AND
WATER MANAGEMENT AGRICULTURE AND
HUMAN IMPACTS. GOT A LOT OF
DISCUSSIONS GOING TO BRING IN A
LITTLE BIT OF THAT. SO THIS
FRAMEWORK THE FOODSECURITY
FRAMEWORK IS ONE THAT'S VERY
WIDELY USED WITHIN THE UNITED
NATIONS CERTAINLY WITH A VERY
BIG INTO FOOD RAGER CULTURE
WORLD. IT STARTED IN- THE
SEVENTIES IN AN
INTERGOVERNMENTAL MEETING WHERE
THERE WAS A DISCUSSION ON WHAT
HOW SHOULD WE DEFINE. WHAT WE'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE FACT THAT
SOME PEOPLE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH TO
EAT. AT A DATE THERE WAS A GOOD
AGREEMENT ON A DEFINITION WHICH
IS NOT THE ONE THAT'S ON THE
SLIDE. THE ONE THAT'S ON THE
SLIDE IN GREEN IS WHAT THE
CURRENT DEFINITION. BUT THERE'S
STILL A LOT OF- EVOLUTION IN THE
THINKING. IN PARTICULAR AROUND
THE FOUR PILLARS THAT IT YOU CAN
SEE AT THE BOTTOM OF THE SLIDE.
AVAILABILITY ACCESS UTILIZATION
INSTABILITY. BECAUSE IN THE
FIRST PHASE OF THINKING ABOUT.
FOOD SECURITY IN GENERAL NOT
SPECIFIC TO DRUG TEST FOOD
SECURITY THE REAL EMPHASIS WAS
ON SUPPLY AVAILABILITY LIKE DO
CAN WE PRODUCE ENOUGH FOOD FOR
THIS GROWING POPULATION. AND
THEIR FOOD NEEDS. BUT BY THE
EIGHTIES IT BECAME PRETTY CLEAR
THAT. ACCESS WAS UNLESS IT WAS
ACTUALLY A VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE
AN ACCESS MEANS COULD YOU GET
THE FOOD IF IT'S EVEN IF IT'S
THERE EVEN IF IT'S IN YOUR LOCAL
SUPERMARKET CAN YOU AFFORD TO
BUY IT. BECAUSE THERE WAS MORE
MORE EVIDENCE OF. THERE IS
PLENTY OF FOOD AROUND BUT PEOPLE
ARE STILL GOING HUNGRY BECAUSE
THEY LACK ACCESS AND THE REASON
THEY LACKED ACCESS WAS BECAUSE
THEY DIDN'T HAVE ENOUGH INCOME.
OR BECAUSE FOOD PRICES. MORE
RISING UP TO EIGHT AND OF COURSE
IT'S RELATIVE FOOD PRICE TO
INCOME SO THEY COULDN'T AFFORD
IT. FILLED IN THE AXIS DIMENSION
IT WAS VERY MUCH A LOT OF
CONCERN AROUND THROUGH PRICES
AND ALSO. INCOME OF THE POOREST
PEOPLE. OF IRAN WHICH IN THE
WORLD IS OFTEN IN AGRICULTURE
AND I THINK ALSO IN CALIFORNIA.
NOT EVEN CALIFORNIA IS QUITE A
DIFFERENT SITUATION THAN MANY OF
THE YOU KNOW AGRICULTURAL
DOMINANT ECONOMIES AROUND THE
WORLD. BUT GLOBALLY THE ROOM
MATE IN MOST MOST POOR PEOPLE IN
THE WORLD ARE STILL LOCATED IN
RURAL AREAS AND HAVE SOME KIND
OF DEPENDENCE ON AGRICULTURE SO
THE AXIS DIMENSION IS REALLY KEY
IN LOOKING AT AGRICULTURE.
INCOME N. WORKERS THEN ALONG
CAME UTILIZATION WHICH IS IT
STILL YOU KNOW BEING DEVELOPED
THEY DISCUSSED A LOT NOW IN
CONTEXT OF NUTRITION UTILIZATION
REFERS TO CONSUMING FOOD
PREPARING IT CHILLED FOOD
STORAGE AND FOOD SAFETY. AND
MORE RECENTLY THIS BIG EMPHASIS
ON LOOKING ON IT IT'S THE
NUTRIENT CONTENT. BECAUSE WHEN
ED IT YET DID THE SAME THING SO
FROM THE NINETIES ON WHEN YOU
HAD ENOUGH CALORIES BEING
PRODUCED. IN FACT TOO MUCH SO
THAT YOU GOT PROBLEMS WITH
OBESITY BUT LACK OF
MICRONUTRIENTS PEOPLE WERE
UNHEALTHY THIS CAUSED REALLY
SERIOUS. THAT NON COMMUNICABLE
DISEASE PROBLEMS BIG HEALTH
COSTS AND MORTALITY SO
UTILIZATION IS SORT OF LOOKING
AT THAT THE NUTRITIONAL SIDE OF
FOOD SAFETY. AND THEN THE LAST
ONE IS STABILITY WHICH IS- GOT
MUCH MORE ATTENTION I WAS
FINALLY CHANGED AND THIS IS
WHERE YOU SEE A LOT ABOUT
DROUGHT TOO BECAUSE THEY
INCREASE INCIDENCE AND-
FREQUENCY AND THE DEPTHS OF
EXTREME EVENTS. SO THAT HE
WOULDN'T BE FOOD SECURE IF YOU
HAD TO. HEY YOU KNOW I AVAILABLE
SUPPLY AND YOU COULD AFFORD IT
BUT IT WAS UNCERTAIN IT WAS
UNRELIABLE SO THAT'S WHAT THIS
LAST MENTIONS ABOUT. SO IN THE
REST OF THE PRESENTATION I WANT
TO DO WITH FOR THE NEXT PART IS
JUST WALK A BIT THROUGH THESE-
MENTIONS AND HOW THEY RELATE TO
DATE IT TO DROUGHT IN IN
DIFFERENT CONTEXTS. BUT FIRST
ACTUALLY- FROM THIS SIDE. THIS
IS A STUDY THAT JUST CAME OUT OF
THE PHARAOH THE FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE ORGANIZATION THIS
YEAR LOOKING AT IMPACTS OF
DISASTERS AND CRISES ON
AGRICULTURE I THOUGHT IT WAS
REALLY INTERESTING THAT DROUGHT
STICKS OUT LIKE THIS IS THE ONE
THIS 34% IT HAS THE LARGEST
SHARE. I WISH. IS THE BIGGEST
CAUSE OF LOSS OF CROP AND
LIVESTOCK. COMPARED TO ALL THESE
OTHER KINDS OF DISASTER CROP
BRETT PESCE STORMS EARTHQUAKES
FLOODS EXTREME TEMPERATURES AND
WILDFIRES. HEY I WAS ACTUALLY
NOTICED PRESENCE OF FLOODS WOULD
HAVE BEEN EVEN BETTER THAN DRUGS
BUT- DROUGHT IS A REALLY BIG
PROBLEM FOR AGRICULTURE IS A
MAJOR SOURCE OF THE LOSS IN
AGRICULTURE IS THE S. SECTOR
GLOBALLY. AREAS BY DIFFERENT
PLACES BUT I WILL CHOOSE A
SECTOR THAT REALLY ABSORBS THE
COST OF DROUGHT MUCH MORE THAN
OTHER SECTORS SAY FLOODING OR
SOME OF THESE OTHER. EXTREME
EVENTS. THE DAMAGE THE COST OF
THE DAMAGE IS SPREAD ACROSS IN A
DIFFERENT SECTOR SAY INDUSTRY
URBAN. OR AS DROUGHT HAS A VERY
HIGH PERCENTAGE OF THE COST IS
IN AGRICULTURE. OKAY SO. JUST
GOING THROUGH THE FOUR
DIMENSIONS OF FOOD SECURITY FOR
STARTING WITH AVAILABILITY I PUT
THIS A SLIDE UP IT'S FROM
GUARDIAN ARTICLE FROM SEPTEMBER
IT'S KIND OF THE CLASSIC DROUGHT
SLIDE OF. THE DROUGHT KENYA. TWO
POINT ONE MILLION PEOPLE AT RISK
OF STARVATION BUT IMPORTANT TO
RECOGNIZE HERE THIS IS FROM
NORTHERN KENYA THIS IS THE PLACE
THAT IS TOTALLY RELIANT ON
RAINFALL IT'S VERY ISOLATED NOT
LINKED TO OTHER MARKETS. VERY
FEW OPTIONS IN TERMS OF GETTING
FOOD. ANDIT GROWING FOOD IN THE
PEOPLE'S LIVELIHOOD IS MOSTLY
PASTORALIST AND THERE'S VERY FEW
OPTIONS THERE SO. THIS IS WHERE
YOU HAD TO SORT OF LIKE OLD
SEVENTIES KIND OF REALLY BIG
CONCERN THAT WHEN YOU WERE IN
THESE KINDS OF VERY. LIMITED
COMMUNITIES LIMITED OPTION
COMMUNITIES. AT THE END OF THEIR
RAINFALL DEPENDENT AND THERE'S
STILL PLENTY OF- THAT- DROUGHT.
REDUCING THE FOOD PRODUCTION IN
THAT AREA IS A DISASTER. BUT
IT'S NOT THE ONLY ASPECT ON
AVAILABILITY IN DROUGHT IMPACTS
THEIR SPECIFICITIES DISS THE
SLIDE THAT COMES FROM A STUDY
THAT WAS DONE LOOKING AT
AUSTRALIA WHICH HAS. YOU KNOW A
DIFFERENT AND MUCH MORE
INDUSTRIALIST TYPE OF
AGRICULTURAL MODEL NOT. IS
SOMEWHAT SIMILAR I THINK IN SOME
WAYS CALIFORNIA BUT- THE POINT
OF THIS ANALYSIS WAS. THE AUTHOR
IS ESTIMATED TO WHAT YOU WOULD
EXPECT THE PRODUCTIVITY OF
AGRICULTURE TO BE THE
PRODUCTIVITY BEING THAT THAT
HERE YOU ARE USING A MEASURE
CALLED TOTAL FACTOR PRODUCTIVITY
SO- WHAT YOU WOULD GET. OUT IT
IS IT IS IT FORCES EVERYTHING
THAT YOU PUT IN SO FOR ALL THE
LABOR THE WATER THE TIME DELAY
AND HOW MUCH OUTPUT YOU GET IS.
IT SO ACCORDING TO THE MODEL OF
WHAT WAS BEING USED IN THE LAND
QUALITY ALL THESE KINDS OF
THINGS THE DOTTED LINE IS WHAT
YOU WOULD EXPECT TO HAVE SEEN
THE PRODUCTIVITY OF THE
AUSTRALIAN AGRICULTURE COURSE
PRODUCTIVITY IS REALLY RELATED
TO THE RETURNS. AND TODAY TODAY
PROFITABILITY OF AGRICULTURE.
INSTEAD IT DAVID THE SOLID LINE
IS WHAT THE ACTUAL PRODUCTIVITY
MEASURES WORK AND THIS WAS
DURING A PERIOD OF DROUGHT. BUT
ALSO AFTER. SO THAT THERE'S-
SOME SUGGESTION THAT THERE'S
LONGER TERM IMPACTS EVEN ON
PRODUCTIVITY AND THIS WOULD HAVE
BEEN IN IN IMPLICATIONS FOR.
OVERALL FOOD PRINT PRODUCTION IN
THE WHERE THE VEIL ABILITY
DIMENSION OF FOOD SECURITY. THE
TO- ACCESS OKAY SO AN ACCESS
YOUR MEMBER IS LIKE YOU CAN YOU
AFFORD TO GET THE STUDENTS AND-
THEY HAVE THINGS TO LOOK AT
THERE IS FOOD PRICE. WILL AFFECT
ALL CONSUMERS AND FOOD PRICES
ARE ON AN UPWARD TREND BUT
THERE'S A LOT O BIG DIFFERENCES
AND DEPENDING ON WHERE YOU ARE.
BUT THE OTHER BIG IMPACT OF
ACCESS BUT I THINK IT'S WORTH
LOOKING AT CLOSELY AS AG
AGRICULTURE EMPLOYMENT BECAUSE
REMEMBER THAT'S PART OF IT IF
YOU IF YOUR INCOME. IS REDUCED.
YOU WILL HAVE LESS ABILITY TO
BUY FOOD IMPORT PEOPLE. AND A
MUCH LARGER SHARE OF THEIR
INCOME ON FOOD SO IT'S A IT'S A
GOOD PRICE. N. EIGHT CAN
DECREASE IT WAS OBVIOUSLY A
MAJOR IMPACT ON POOR PEOPLE.
WHAT WE SEE HERE I WAS LOOKING
ACROSS A LOT OF DIFFERENT
STUDIES BUT- BECAUSE I JUST
EXPECTED THAT YOU WOULD NEVER
NORMALLY SEE THAT. DURING A
DROUGHT IN A PLACE THAT IS
EXPERIENCING DROUGHT IN
AGRICULTURAL LOCATION YOU WOULD
EXPECT TO SEE LESS EMPLOYMENT
PEOPLE LOSING JOBS ARE LOSING
OURS. IT WASN'T ALWAYS THE CASE
AND I THINK PART OF THE REASON
IS IN SOME CASESTHAT YOU SAW
THE RESPONSE TO DROUGHT WAS THAT
FARMERS WERE PUTTING IN MORE
LABOR INTENSIVE TYPES OF CROPS.
SO THAT ACTUALLY DREW IN MORE
LABOR. I THINK ANOTHER ISSUE
THOUGH IN LOOKING AT SOME OF
THOSE STUDIES THIS- IT TAKES
TIME TO FIGURE OUT THE IMPACTS
OF THE DROUGHT THAT DATE THEY
BUILD UP OVER TIME SO. FOR
EXAMPLE OF ONE OF THE STUDIES
FROM BRAZIL IS LOOKING OVER THE
PERIOD F NINETEEN SEVENTY
TWENTY TEN SO THEY HAD A REALLY
LONG PERIOD AND THEY REALLY
DETAILED LOOKING AT. THE DROUGHT
IN THESE LITTLE COMMUNITIES AND
WHAT HAPPENED AND THEY FOUND BIG
IMPACTS THEY FOUND BIG COMMUNITY
LEVEL IMPACTS. OF THAT FIRST ON
THE AGRICULTURAL LABOR. THIS IS
SOME OF THE BUSINESSES GO BROKE.
YOU SEE THIS KIND OF-
ABANDONMENT OF HOUSES AND TOWNS
. BASICALLY IT BIG OUT MIGRATION
ESPECIALLY AMONG YOUNG PEOPLE.
SO IT'S NOT A IT'S NOT YOU KNOW
AN UNAMBIGUOUS THING THAT
DROUGHT WILL ALWAYS GIVE YOU
LOWER- AGRICULTURE EMPLOYMENT
AND THEREFORE LOWER INCOME. BUT
IT IS SOMETHING THAT IS MAYBE IT
TAKES A LITTLE TIME TO FIGURE
OUT EXACTLY WHAT THE FULL
IMPACTS ARE AND THEY CAN BE
QUITE IMPORTANT IN LOOKING AT
THE OVERALL FOOD SECURITY
IMPACTS. ANOTHER STUDY FROM
AUSTRALIA WAS LOOKING AT.
SEVERAL INDICATORS. OF INCOME
AND THEY ALSO WERE LOOKING AT
MENTAL HEALTH AND MEDICATION AND
DRINKING WHICH I'M NOT GONNA GET
INTO I THINK OTHERS WILL BE
DISCUSSING THAT BUT- THE THING
THAT WAS INTERESTING HERE IS
THAT. THIS SITE HAS THREE
COLUMNS SO THIS IS THE ONE TO
FOR THIS TO THE LEFT HERE IS.
LOOKING AT THE HIGHEST THE MOST
SEVERE DROUGHT THIS IS KIND OF
PRETTY BAD DROUGHT IN THIS IS
BAD BUT BUT THE LEAST BAD. SO
WHAT YOU SEE IS THAT IN TERMS OF
INCOME AFFECTS IT'S ONLY IN THE
REALLY REALLY BAD DROUGHT. YOU
GET A HUGE NEGATIVE HIT ON
INCOME AND THERE'S ASTERIX KENO
INDICATING THAT IT'S
STATISTICALLY SIGNIFICANT WHAT
IS ITS NEGATIVE HERE IN THE BAT
PRETTY BAD. BUT IT'S NOT IT'S
NOT SIGNIFICANT SO THE RIGHT THE
RESULT ON INCOME IS REALLY LIKE
OKAY. IT MAKES YOU THINK. YES
DRUGS SEEMS TO BE HAVING. IT
IMPACTS ON INCOME THEY WERE
LOOKING AT REAL INCOMES AS WELL
AS NON RURAL- THEY THEY FIND
FURTHER IMPACTS ON FINANCIAL
STRESS ACROSS THIS PRETTY BAD
PLACE. BUT THE IN THE ACTUAL
IMPACTS AN INCOME DIDN'T SHOW
THROUGH HERE AND THAT COULD ALSO
BE BECAUSE PEOPLE HAVE SAVINGS
IN THAT IT'S AGAIN A TIME THING
LIKE I'VE BEEN LOOKING AT IT
OVER TIME. BUT AGAIN ON THAT YOU
WOULD EXPECT. CERTAINLY I THINK
IF YOU TALK TO CALIFORNIA FOR
RESEARCH THAT DROUGHT WILL HAVE
SOME IMPACT ON FARMING. A MOVE
INTO THE FOURTH THE FIFTH THIRD
DIMENSIONAL STABILITY. AT THE
END I JUST PUT THE SLIDE HERE
SHOWING THAT THE INCREASING
NUMBER OF EXTREME EVENTS
STABILITY ISN'T A BIG CONCERN
BECAUSE THERE'S JUST BEEN SO
MANY HITS TO AGRICULTURAL
PRODUCTION. L. AND S. TROOPS
EXTREME EVENTS AND THAT'S IT
IT'S BECOMING MUCH FOR- MUCH
MORE PRIORITY INSISTED SECURITY
PROGRAMS. AND THE LAST ONES ON
UTILIZATION AND A LOT OF STUDIES
AND DROUGHT IN DROUGHT AREAS
WITH AGRICULTURAL POPULATION
WHICH SHOW THAT PEOPLE START TO
SHIFT TOWARDS LESS NUTRIENT
DENSE DIETS AS THEY BECAUSE
THEY'RE LOSING INCOME OR THEY'RE
LOSING PRODUCTION. SO THEY TEND
TO EAT WORSE NUTRITIONALLY AND
THEN THIS HAS LONG TERM HEALTH
IMPACTS. THERE'S ALSO INCREASE
OF FOOD SAFETY PROBLEMS DUE TO
LACK OF GOOD WATER DRINKING
WATER WAS INTERESTING TO HEAR
THAT THAT'S THAT'S SUCH AN ISSUE
IN CALIFORNIA. AT INCREASED RISK
OF WATER CONTAMINATION AND ALSO
CONCERNS ABOUT INCREASED
INCIDENCE OF PARASITES BACTERIA
VIRUSES. AT A. POSSIBILITY IN
NIGHT THIS IS NOT A DISEASE
TRANSMISSION SO FOOD SAFETY IS
THE REAL CONCERN AROUND. THE S.
SCARCITY OF WATER. SO WHAT ARE
PEOPLE DOING IN THIS IS REALLY A
QUICK IN AND OUT A QUICK AND
DIRTY ANALYSIS BUT JUST LOOKING
THROUGH THOSE FOR- DIMENSIONS ON
THE AVAILABILITY WHAT I THINK I
HEAR A LOT OF. CALIFORNIA IT'S
ON THE PRODUCTION SIDE IT'S
BUILDING STORAGE IS FILLING IN
FOR IRRIGATION- THERE'S ALSO A
LOT OF WORK ON BUILDING AT YOU
KNOW GETTING FARMERS TO USE
DROUGHT TOLERANT VARIETIES. AND
THEN. IN SOME CASES
PARTICULARLY. IN SAY LIKE AFRICA
RIGHT NOW THEY'RE JUST LOOKING
FOR NEW MARKET SOURCE TO GET
FOOD. AS AS THE DAY TRADITIONAL
ONES BECOME LESS RELIABLE I MEAN
IN THE CASE OF THE KENYA'S
LETTER SHOWED EARLIER THIS
SOURCE OF TRUTH EMERGENCY FOOD
RELIEF FROM. WORLD FOOD PROGRAM-
THE NEW MARKET SOURCES CAN BE
KIND OF PROBLEMATIC BECAUSE TO
ACTUALLY IMPORT FOOD FIRST OF
ALL BUT MANY COUNTRIES HAVE A
HIGH DEBT. OF FOOD IMPORTS
ALREADY AND IT'S IN THERE PAYING
INTEREST ON IT SECONDLY YOU NEED
A PRETTY ADVANCED INFRASTRUCTURE
TO GET. FOD OUT TO PEOPLE LIKE
IN THAT THAT PASTORAL AREA. BUT
NONE THE LESS THE- THE OF
INVISIBILITY THERE'S A FOCUS ON-
IMPROVING. THE RESILIENCE OF
PRODUCTION SYSTEMS. AT THE END
OF CLIMATE OUT OF. THERE'S A
DISCUSSION OF INCREMENTAL
ADAPTATIONS FOR THAT YOU'RE
DOING KIND OF. WHAT WE'VE ALWAYS
BEEN DOING THAT BETTER SELECT
SAY A GROWING- YOU RICE THAT
DROUGHT TOLERANT RICE ARE YOU
USING A DIFFERENT KIND OF
IRRIGATION METHOD THAT'S FOR. IT
YOU KNOW WATER. EGG EFFICIENT.
L. BUT THERE'S THE INCREASING
CALLS FOR MORE TRANSFORMATIVE
FORMS TO REALLY RECOGNIZE THE
MAJOR SHIFTS THAT ARE BEING
IMPOSED BY CLIMATE CHANGE AND
DROUGHT IS ONE OF THEM. AND THE
ACCESS SIDE WHAT'S BEEN REALLY
SUCCESSFUL IS SOME SAFETY NET
PROGRAMS THEN THERE'S A LOT OF
TIMES IS FOOD FOOD TRANSFERS BUT
ALSO CASH TRANSFER PROGRAMS HAVE
BECOME VERY POPULAR. I MEAN THIS
ISN'T THAT'S A LITTLE BIT TRICKY
WHEN IT DEPENDING ON LOCAL FOOD
SUPPLIES. AND SO THEIR THEIR THE
DESIGN OF THE PROGRAM HAS. IT IS
VERY IMPORTANT IN TERMS OF HOW
SUCCESSFUL THEY ARE. BUT OVERALL
THERE'S BEEN A HUGE EXPANSION IN
SAFETY NET PROGRAMS IN IN
AFRICA. AND SOUTH ASIA ALSO IN
LATIN AMERICA WAS STILL ONE OF
THE PIONEERS AND BRAZIL. AND
IT'S BEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL IN
MAINTAINING CERTAIN LEVELS OF
FOOD SECURITY- BUT NOW LOOKING
AT THE AG EMPLOYMENT ISSUE LIKE
SO. BUT AND THIS IS ONE OF THE
BIGGEST ISSUES I THINK COME AND
THAT WAS DISCUSSED IN THE FOOD
SYSTEM SUMMIT. THEY'RE STILL HIT
A BILLION WHERE. HUGE NUMBER OF
VERY POOR PEOPLE EMPLOYED IN
AGRICULTURE AND AGRICULTURE
RELATED AND- ACTIVITIES IN THIS
IS ALSO WHERE THERE'S STILL
REALLY HIGH LEVELS OF POPULATION
GROWTH. THE AG PRODUCTIVITY ON
THOSE FARMS FARMS VERY SMALL
FIVE FARM SIZES ARE GETTING
UNDER ONE ACTOR. IT'S NOT REALLY
CLEAR THAT YOU CAN DO ANY KIND
OF AGRICULTURAL TECHNOLOGY OR
MARKETING SCHEME THAT WOULD
REALLY LIFT PEOPLE OUT OF
POVERTY AND SO THERE'S A LOT
MORE FOCUS ON TRAINING AND
LOOKING FOR ALTERNATIVE
EMPLOYMENT BUT PARTICULARLY IN
AGRICULTURAL VALUE CHAINS. WHICH
UP TO IN THE PAST IT HAS BEEN
MUCH MORE OF A FOCUS ON SAY
LABOR SUBSTITUTION AS YOU. MOVE
INTO FOOD PROCESSING YOU LOOK
FOR EQUIPMENT THAT WOULD BE
PLACED LABORS INSTEAD OF LIKE
SAY EQUIPMENT THAT WOULD LABORS
WOULD USE TO INCREASE THEIR
PRODUCTIVITY SO THERE'S A LOT OF
DISCUSSION THERE ABOUT- SAFETY
NET PROGRAMS CAN ONLY TAKE YOU
SO FAR IN SO LONG. WE NEED TO
LOOK FOR OTHER ALTERNATIVES BUT-
NOT MAYBE ON THE FARM MAYBE NEAR
THE FARM. ON STABILITY ALSO
QUITE A LOT OF STUFF GOING ON
REGIS MANAGEMENT THINGS
STABILIZING FOOD PRICE PROGRAM
STATE STORAGE BUFFER STOCKS ALSO
AGREEMENTS TO AVOID SAY EXPORT
BANS WHICH WAS ONE OF THE
PROBLEMS OF THE FOOD PRICE BY.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT EXPERIMENTAL
INSURANCE LIKE THE INDEX
INSURANCE PROGRAM SET FOR. FULL
SCALE FARMERS THAT'S HAD KIND OF
MIXED. RESULTS THAT DIDN'T COME
IN A COUPLE OF CASES HAS WORKED
A LOT OF CASES AND PROBLEMATIC.
TRADE TRADE HAS BEEN INCREASING
TRADE NETWORKS HAS BEEN A REALLY
SUCCESSFUL WAY OF STABILIZING
FOOD SUPPLIES AND FOOD PRICES.
FINALLY ON UTILIZATION THERE'S-
YOU KNOW USING SUBSIDIES ON
VOUCHERS TO GO TO MAKES THIS
COULD INCENTIVIZE PEOPLE
INCENTIVIZE PEOPLE TO YOU.
CONSUME NUTRIENT DENSE FOODS OF
LAKE CALIFORNIA AND SAM THAT'S
NOT SO FOR IT'S JUST. THAT KIND
OF THING WHICH IS MY OFFICE-
MORE EXPENSIVE RELATIVE TO THE
SORT OF BASIC GRAINS- THEN IN
TERMS OF LIKE THE FOOD SAFETY
ISSUES THAT'S A LOT OF THE FOOD
PREPARATION. IN DEVELOPING
COUNTRIES IS IN THE INFORMAL
SECTOR IT'S NOT LICENSED IT'S
NOT. YET IT'S NOT UNDER THE
GOVERNMENT CONTROL. IT'S IN THE
INFORMAL SECTOR AND THERE'S A
LOT OF THE FOCUS LOT MORE FOCUS
TO WORKING IN THAT SECTOR T.
EDUCATE PEOPLE ON THE DANGERS OF
FOOD. CONTAMINATION AND TO
IMPROVE IT. OKAY LET AT THESE
TWO KINDS OF. AND ALSO JUST
LISTENING TO SOME OF THE
PREVIOUS PRESENTATIONS. I THINK
THE- IN LOOKING AT DROUGHT IN
THE IMPACTS ON HUMANS IT'S
IMPORTANT TO KIND OF LOOK AT
WHICH HUMANS ARE WE TALKING
ABOUT. ARE WE TALKING ABOUT
PEOPLE THAT ARE WORKING IN
AGRICULTURE BECAUSE THAT'S
THAT'S A VERY CLEARED DEFINED
GROUP THAT HAS A SET OF. FAIRLY
CARD THE NEGATIVE IMPACTS
THERE'S ALSO FARMERS BUT IT
WOULD BE DIFFERENT A SMALL
FARMER RECEIVES A LARGE FARMER
AND OF COURSE IN ANY FOOD
CONSUMER. ANY CONSUMER SAY
CALIFORNIA FRUITS AND VEGETABLES
WOULD HAVE BEEN IMPACTED IN SOME
WAY BY CALIFORNIA DROUGHT. AND
THEN I THINK ALSO- AND THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT'S BEEN DISCUSSED
QUITE A LOT IS THE DIFFERENCE IN
THE SHORT RUN SOLUTIONS AND WHAT
ARE THE LONG TERM ONES. AND SO
IN THE SHORT RUN AS THEY
DISCUSSED IN THE PREVIOUS SIDE
THAT YOU KNOW THE SAFETY NETS
LIKE A CASH PAYMENTS FROM
PAYMENTS. BUT THE LONG TERM ONE
IS. WHAT IS A VIABLE. AND STABLE
ALTERNATIVE FOR DECENT
LIVELIHOODS FOR PEOPLE. AND HOW
AT N. ALSO SORT OF RECOGNIZING
TO WHAT EXTENT IS THE CURRENT
LIVELIHOOD YOU JUST NEED A TIDE
OVER SO THE NEXT TIME IS TO GET
TO THE NEXT TIME OR YOU SHOULD
YOU REALLY BE LOOKING FOR CHANGE
A REALLY BIG CHANGE. AND THAT'S
GOES FOR THE FARMERS AS WELL
LIKE ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT-
BUILDING NEW TECHNOLOGY IS THE
IMPROVING STORAGE IMPROVING
IRRIGATION EFFICIENCY ARE WE
TALKING ABOUT SOME FARMERS NEED
GOING OUT OF PRODUCTION. AND SO
. THESE QUESTIONS- YOU HAVE BEEN
RAISED IN VARIOUS CONTEXTS IN
AUGUST AND THE ANSWERS ARE
DIFFERENT DEPENDING WHERE YOU
WORK- AND SAME THING ALSO ON THE
CONSUMERS THE SHORT TERM IS THIS
KIND OF SUBSIDY OR EDUCATION
PROGRAM SO THAT THE LONG TERM
MAY BE MORE IT. MAJOR CHANGES IN
FOOD SUPPLY SOURCES IN WHAT THEY
CALL FOOD ENVIRONMENTS LIKE
WHERE YOU GET YOUR FOOD
SUPERMARKETS BUT ALSO
RESTAURANTS AND FOOD STANDS. SO
THERE'S NO NEED TO CONSIDER
WHICH GROUP. OF IMPACT OF PEOPLE
ARE WE TALKING ABOUT IN TERMS OF
IMPACTS. AND OVER WHAT TIME
FRAME. THE LAST SLIDE- AND JUST
TO SUMMARIZE SOME OF THE STUFF-
SOMEONE'S MOTIVE IS TALKING
ABOUT AND ALSO WHAT'S COMING
OUT. OF MORE RECENT DISCUSSIONS
RELATED TO THAT FOOD SYSTEM SOME
. THE ONE THING THAT'S PRETTY
CLEAR ACROSS ALL THOSE STUDIES
IS EVIDENCE CERTAINLY WAS NOT
GONNA SURPRISE ANYBODY. THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE HARDEST HIT ARE
THE MOST VULNERABLE THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE ALREADY IN DEFICIT AS
THE HECK. IT ACT LIKE THEY'RE
LIKE CALIFORNIA AND GROUNDWATER
GUARDIAN DEFICIT THAT'S WHERE
THEY TAKE IT EVEN HARDER. SO IN
A LOT OF THOSE PEOPLE ARE IN
AGRICULTURE IN THIS IS GLOBALLY
I MEAN. L. UNDER LOW INCOME
PEOPLE THEY CAN BE MINORITY
PEOPLES AND A LOT OF THEM ARE.
AGRICULTURAL WORKERS THEY'RE NOT
USUALLY LANDOWNERS BUT LET THEIR
LABORS- ONE ANOTHER COME WITH
CONCERT CLICK CONSISTENTLY IN
THIS CONTEXT IS. THERE'S A LOT
OF FOCUS ON THE EXPOSED TO LIKE
THE EMERGENCY RELIEF BRINGING IN
FOOD. AND I THINK THIS WAS ALSO
RAISED AT THE BY THE SENATOR AT
THE BEGINNING OF LIKE WE REALLY
NEED TO BE THINKING ABOUT. DOING
MORE OF THE EX ANTE. THE
INVESTMENTS IN ADVANCE AND LESS
OF THE EMERGENCY IS CERTAINLY A
LOT CHEAPER. TO PREPARE WELLS
COURSE IS FLOODED IT'S KIND OF
TRICKY TO DO THAT BECAUSE WE'RE
FACING A LOT OF UNCERTAINTY BUT-
THIS IS A- PRETTY CLEAR. THING
THAT IS THE WORST SPENDING WAY
TOO MUCH ON THAT THE EMERGENCY
EXPOSED ENOUGH. IN ADVANCE- AND
THERE'S NOT A LOT OF EXPERIENCE
WITH TRANSFORMATIONAL ADAPTATION
THOSE LONG TERM CHANGES WHERE
THERE'S RECOGNITION THAT SOME OF
THE CHANGES THAT WE'RE SEEING.
GOING ON A LEASH DAVE ARM IT WAS
CLIMATE CHANGE WITH POPULATION
PATTERNS IT REALLY IMPLIES. A
MAJOR MAJOR CHANGE. IS SO FAR
WHAT YOU'RE SEEING IS MOSTLY
INCREMENTAL CHANGE PEOPLE SORT
OF STAYING IN THE SAME. OVERALL
PICTURE ABOUT AGRICULTURE I
MEAN- BUT NOT A MAJOR SHIFT AND
SO THERE'S A LOT OF PUSHING TO
DO THAT BECAUSE- THERE'S A LOT
OF FEAR THAT IF WE DON'T DO THAT
IN THE NEXT TEN YEARS IS GONNA
BE A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT ARE
GONNA BE. IN VERY BAD SHAPE.
THAT PARTICULAR SUBSAHARAN
AFRICA AND SOUTH ASIA. BUT I
THINK THAT'S RELEVANT IN OTHER
PLACES AS WELL. I DID ALREADY
MENTIONED THIS THING ABOUT THE
DECENT JOBS THAT THERE'S MUCH
MORE FOCUSED ON LOOK IN THE OLD
AGRICULTURAL MODEL AND STILL
THERE'S LIKE THE VIEW OF
TECHNOLOGY A LOT OF TIMES IS
THAT IT SUBSTITUTES FOR LABOR IT
REDUCES. THE OVERALL PRODUCTION
COSTS THAT'S GREAT. BUT IT'S NOT
GREAT IF YOU YOU END UP.
GENERATING HUGE BODY OF
UNEMPLOYED PEOPLE PARTICULARLY
WHEN THEY'RE THE DAY SORT OF
LOVE MOST VULNERABLE PEOPLE IN
SOCIETY. AND THAT THEREFORE
THINKING OF DIFFERENT KINDS OF-
TECHNOLOGY DEVELOPMENT IN
PARTICULAR THE ONES THAT.
ENHANCE LABOR PRODUCTIVITY. AND
THAT COULD. GENERATE DECENT
EMPLOYMENT OVER A LONG TERM. IS
SOMETHING THAT REALLY NEEDS IT'S
A CHANGE FROM HOW THINGS WERE.
VIEWED IN THE PAST. AND THERE'S
A LOT OF WORK GOING IN SOME
MONEY GOING INTO INVESTING IN
THAT. AND THEN A LOT OF FUN IS
THIS GREAT RETHINKING AND
REDEFINING SUCCESSFUL OR
SUSTAINABLE AGRICULTURE NOTHING
GOING ON FOREVER. WELL SIMPLY
RESET YOUR REFINING AND
RETHINKING. BUT ONE THING I
THINK IS PROBABLY MOST RELEVANT
IN THE CALIFORNIA CONTEXT IS.
THERE'S REALLY BIG PROBLEMS WHEN
YOU'RE SHORT TERM. SOLUTION
BLOCKS THE LONG TERM ONE THE
LONG TERM SUSTAINABLE ONE. AND I
THINK THAT'S COMING UP LIKE YOU
KNOW SUPPORT FOR UNSUSTAINABLE
PRODUCTION METHODS. FOR IS A
PROBLEM IT KEEPS YOU FROM MOVING
TO WHERE YOU NEED TO GO I MEAN
OBVIOUSLY THERE'S TRANSITION
PERIODS AND THINGS LIKE THAT
BUT- THIS IS SOMETHING THAT'S
COME UP A LITTLE AND- THAT WAS A
BIG. ISSUE IN THE DISCUSSIONS
AROUND THAT. ALTHOUGH NOT A LOT
OF SOLUTIONS I WAS STILL IN WHAT
DO YOU DO BECAUSE. THE SHORT
TERM SOLUTIONS- I SOMETIME IN
THEY ARE. TO IN THEY DO. TO
THERE IS A VERY STRONG URGENCY
TO THOSE KINDS OF. MEASURES SO.
I THINK PART OF THE DISCUSSION
THERE THOUGH IT IS LIKE THIS
LONG TERM IT GET THE LONG TERM.
INVESTMENTS IN PLACE FASTER THAN
WE'RE DOING SO FAR. OKAY AND
THAT'S PRETTY MUCH EVERYTHING I
HAVE TO SAY ABOUT THAT AND THANK
YOU VERY MUCH TO BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AS THEY
COME UP. THANK YOU LOVELY PLEASE
STAND BY WHAT WILL I BE HEARING
FROM OUR NEXT PANELIST FOR THE
SECTION AND THAT'S DR JASMEET
BAYNES. SHE'S A MEDICAL DOCTOR
AND DOCTOR BAINES FEEL FREE TO
BEGIN WHEN YOU ARE READY.GOOD
AFTERNOON- THANK YOU FOR HAVING
ME HERE TERROR ON MADAM CHAIR
CENTER TOWN CENTER MELINDA'S- I
THINK THIS IS. A VERY VERY
IMPORTANT AREA DISCUSSION SO I
APPRECIATE YOU PUTTING AN
ORGANIZING THIS PANEL TOGETHER-
I AM A BOARD OF FAMILY MEDICINE
PHYSICIAN- IN ADDITION TO WORK
IN ADDICTION MEDICINE- IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY I CURRENTLY
PRACTICE IN BAKERSFIELD
CALIFORNIA. THE HEALTH
IMPLICATIONS OF THE DROUGHT ARE
VERY REAL- THEY ARE VERY
APPARENT TO THOSE OF US IN THE
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM. AS WE
WITNESS IT EVERY SINGLE DAY IN
OUR PRACTICES AS THE FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE WORLD WE
NEED TO WAKE UP WE NEED TO WAKE
UP TO THE REALITY OF THE BIGGEST
LACKS OF AXIS OUR PEOPLE SUFFER-
AS A PHYSICIAN I HAVE SPENT MANY
YEARS WORKING ABROAD. INCREASING
HEALTH CARE ACCESS TO QUOTE ON
QUOTE THIRD WORLD COUNTRIES AND
I HAVE TO SAY. I'VE SEEN VERY
MANY SIMILARITIES OF MY OWN
COMMUNITY HERE TEN VITAMINS I
HAVE SEEN ABROAD. AND IN MANY
SITUATIONS MY COMMUNITY
CONTINUES TO SUFFER THE MOST
DEVASTATING RESULTS OF CHANGES
THAT ARE. HAPPENING IN MANY MANY
WAYS. THE CDC OR- THAT. THE
DROUGHT IS INCREASING READ. DRAW
IS CAUSING REDUCED STREAM AND
RIVER FLOWS THAT CAN INCREASE
THE CONCENTRATION OF POLITICS
AND WATER- AND THEN THE FURTHER
STAGNATION OF WATER AS WELL
HIGHER WATER TEMPERATURES IN
LAKES AND RESERVOIRS LEADING TO
REDUCED OXYGEN LEVELS THAT CAN
IMPACT FISH AND OTHER AQUATIC
LIFE IN WATER QUALITY. A RUNOFF
FROM DROUGHT RELATED WILDFIRES
CAN CARRY EXTRICITY MEN ASKED
HER GOAL AND WE NEED TO BREED TO
SURFACE WATERS KILLING FISH
OTHER QUANTIC LIFE BY DECREASING
THE OXYGEN LEVELS IN THE WATER.
MANY PARTS OF THE UNITED STATES
DEPEND ON THE GROUND WATER AS
THEIR PRIMARY SOURCE. OF THE-
WATER AS WELL. SO LET'S GO AHEAD
AND TALK ABOUT FOOD I THINK
LESLIE DID A GREAT JOB TALKING
ABOUT THAT AS WELL- AND THE- LOT
OF THE PANELS FOR TALKING ABOUT
THAT AS WELL THE DRUG COULD
LIMIT GROWTH OF FOOD RESULTING
IN INCREASED COSTS OF FOOD. AND
SHORTAGES WHICH WE ARE ALREADY
EXPERIENCING THE HEALTH
IMPLICATION OF MALNUTRITION
WHICH WAS ALSO DISCUSSED EARLIER
IS ALREADY BEING WITNESSED IN
CLINICS ACROSS THE CENTRAL
VALLEY I'M IN ACROSS THE COUNTRY
AS WELL- AND IT'S FURTHER BE
EXACERBATED BY DISTRAUGHT WE CAN
SEE IT IN OUR PATIENTS- IN
ADDITION TO INCREASING ON
HEALTHY EATING AS WELL. I'LL
LET'S GO AHEAD TALK ABOUT AIR
QUALITY DURING THE DROUGHT THERE
IS AN INCREASED RISK FOR
WILDFIRES WHICH WE ALL KNOW AND
DUST STORMS AS WELL I'M LIVING
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY VALLEY
FEVER IT'S A BIG CONCERN THERE-
PARTICULATE MATTER SUSPENDED IN
THE AIR FROM THESE EVENTS CAN
IRRITATE THE BRONCHIAL PASSAGES
OF. AND ONES AND THIS IS LEADING
TO INCREASED CASES OF CHRONIC
RESPIRATORY ILLNESSES WHICH WE
ARE EXPERIENCING AND SEEING AND
WORSENING DAY BY DAY- THE
INCREASED RISK FOR RESPIRATORY
INFECTIONS LIKE BRONCHITIS AND
PNEUMONIA AND OF COURSE CODE
NINETEEN. IS INCREASING AND
BEING EXACERBATED BY OUR DROUGHT
AS WELL- WITH INCREASED DUST AND
DRY CONDITIONS CREATED OTHERS-
JUST CREATING IT'S CREATING A
EIGHTY ATMOSPHERE FOR MORE
WILDFIRES AND THE SOMEWHAT KEENE
VALLEY AIR DISTRICT- OUR
RESEARCH TEAMREPORTS THAT AIR
QUALITY IS BEING MAJORLY
AFFECTED BY WILDFIRES- WHICH IS
FURTHER EXACERBATING CHRONIC.
OBSTRUCTIVE PULMONARY DISEASES
IN OUR PATIENTS ESPECIALLY IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY WHICH IS
WHERE I PRACTICE- AND ESPECIALLY
SOMEONE- AS ME I PERSONALLY
SUFFER FROM ASTHMA MYSELF- SO I
EXPERIENCE A DAY TO DAY IN
ADDITION TO SEEKING THE
INCREASES IN MY PATIENTS AS-
WELL. DROUGHT BECAUSE THE
INCREASED. OF- PER. AND AIRBORNE
TALK AS WELL WHICH IS STUDY WELL
AS WELL- THROUGHOUT HISTORY WE
HAVE SEEN WHENEVER THERE IS A
WATER SHORTAGE- SANITATION AND
HYGIENE OR CHALLENGE CREATING
MORE DISEASE AND INFECTIONS
SPREAD. INCLUDING HAND WASHING
SO HANDWASHING IS ACTS ACTUALLY
THE MOST EFFECTIVE DETERRENT FOR
KOBE NINETEEN ASCO NINETEEN IT'S
AN ENVELOPED VIRUS- COMPROMISING
HANDWASHING SPELLS NIGHTMARES
FOR KOBE NINETEEN ECONOLINE
SALMONELLA SPREAD AS FAR. THE
SPREAD OF THE DISEASES RAINFALL
DECREASES VERY WELL STUDIED AS
BACTERIA AND VIRUSES CAN POLLUTE
BOTH- SURFACE OF SURFACE WATER
AND GROUNDWATER FROM STAGNATION
I THINK SOMEBODY ELSE HAD ALSO
GONE OVER THIS AS WELL-
STAGNATION OF WATER CAN ALSO
INCREASE MOSQUITO BREEDING
GROUNDS- WHICH CARRY DISEASES
LIKE WEST NILE. WHICH IS
SOMETHING THAT IS HUGE IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY CASES ARE ALSO
RISING. TO STOCK UP ON VALLEY
FEVER- THE DROUGHT INCREASES
FUNGAL INFECTION SPREAD
INCLUDING- IT SPREADS THE
COXETER MY NKOSI'S FUNGUS
RESPONSIBLE FOR VALLEY FEVER ON
TOP. OF THE ALREADY RISING CASES
OF VALLEY FEVER IN OUR VALLEY-
WE HAD A BLAST I JUST WANTED TO
TOUCH UPON MENTAL HEALTH- THE
PANDEMIC HAS PROVEN- THE IMPACT
AND THE MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS-
THAT WE ARE IN IS MORE SECURE
THAN WE THOUGHT- THE FINANCIAL
RELATED STRESS THE WORRIES- JUST
WORSENS DEPRESSION AND ANXIETY
WE SEE IT. EVERY DAY AND ALL DAY
IN CLINICS- IN ADDITION TO
INCREASING ALCOHOL AND SUBSTANCE
ABUSE AND SADLY INCREASE IN THE
SUICIDE RATE- I AM IN THE
MEDICAL DIRECTOR BUT YOU'RE
STILL RECOVERY SERVICES AND WE
ARE SEEING IN VERY ALARMING
INCREASE IN SUBSTANCE AND
ALCOHOL ABUSE. IN ADDITION TO
SUICIDE RATE AS WELL HERE IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY- MENTAL HEALTH IS
BEING IMPACTED FROM VERY MANY
ASPECTS- AND THE DROP IS
DEFINITELY NOT HELPING- AREAS OF
FOCUS THAT WE NEED TO FOCUS ON-
INCLUDING RESEARCH IS. YOU KNOW
THE DIRECT EFFECT OF THE DROUGHT
ON OUR WORKERS OUT IN THE FARMS
ON OUR OUTDOOR WORKERS AND THEN
OF COURSE OUR CHILDREN AS WELL
AS WE HAVEN'T- AS MANY PEOPLE.
HAVE- DESCRIBED BEFORE
INADEQUATE TO WATER. INTO OF THE
HEALTH OF KIDS- ARMOR AND
LASTING I ALSO WANTED TO MENTION
IS A LOT OF THIS ALSO AFFECTS
OUR WILDLIFE OF WILDLIFE AND OUR
DEAR USER AND TO OUR LIVESTOCK
THAT WE HAVE- WHAT'S NOT VALLEY
FEVER ALSO AFFECTS ANIMALS AS IT
DOES AFFECT. HUMANS AS WELL SO
WITH THAT THAT WAS ALL I WANTED
TO ADD- AND- ALL CUSTOMERS NEXT
WEEK OR- THANK YOU DR BRAINS AND
OUR NEXT SPEAKER IS- CHRISTINA
GREENE ASSISTANT RESEARCH
SCIENTIST A CLIMATE ASSESSMENT
FOR THE SOUTHWEST. A UNIVERSITY
OF ARIZONA THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
JOINING US AND FEEL FREE TO
BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY WITH
YOUR PRESENTATION. I'M GOOD
AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR. THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE
TODAY. I AM A HUMAN GEOGRAPHER
AND I STUDY THE HUMAN DIMENSION
OF DROUGHT AND HOW IT'S
IMPACTING PEOPLE'S ON A DAY TO
DAY BASIS. AND TODAY I WANT TO
PRESENT ON RESEARCH THAT I
CONDUCTED IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY DURING THE. 200-012-2000
SIXTEEN DROUGHT. AND AS WELL AS
OTHER SPEAKERS HAVE ADDRESSED
DROUGHTS ARE REALLY DIFFERENT
THAN OTHER NATURAL HAZARDS.
DESCRIBED AS SLOW MOVING
HAZARDS. AND SO- SOCIAL ECONOMIC
IMPACTS THAT WE SEE FROM
DROUGHTS HAVE A LONG LAG TIME.
AND THEY OFTEN PRESENT LONG
AFTER THE DROUGHT IS OVER. WE
HAVE. A HUGE SUITE OF TOOLS AND
INDICATORS THAT MONITOR THE
PHYSICAL IMPACTS OF DROUGHT SO
HOW MUCH WATER THERE IS HOW MUCH
PRECIPITATION BUT WE REALLY HAVE
A WAYS TO GO AND IDENTIFYING AND
TRACKING THE SOCIAL AND ECONOMIC
IMPACTS OF DROUGHT AND PART OF
THAT IS BECAUSE IT'S REALLY
DIFFICULT TO SEPARATE. ONGOING
SOCIAL ENVIRONMENTAL AND
ECONOMIC PROCESS SEES THAT-
IMPACT LIVELIHOODS AND WELL
BEING. AND- FORMER KURDISH HAVE
REMAINED LARGELY INVISIBLE
DURING DROUGHT A LOT OF
ATTENTION IT'S PAIN TO THE
FARMERS THEMSELVES BUT THE
EXPERIENCE OF OUR WORKERS ARE
VERY DIFFERENT. A LOT OF THIS.
HAS TO DO WITH THE UNDOCUMENTED
STATUS OF MANY FARM WORKERS AND
THEY ARE RELUCTANT TO REPORT ON
THEIR EXPERIENCES. AND SO TODAY
I AM PRESENTING ON THE RESEARCH
THAT I CONDUCTED IN THE SN
JOAQUIN VALLEY OVER SEVERAL
YEARS. AND I INTERVIEWED A LOT
OF FARM WORKERS FARMERS SOCIAL
WORKERS. COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES WHO ARE WITNESSING THE
IMPACTS OF THE DROUGHT- I ALSO
CONDUCTED HOUSEHOLD SURVEYS.
INVOLUNTARILY DISTRIBUTION AND
FARMWORKER COMMUNITIES. AND I
CONDUCTED QUALITATIVE RESEARCH
TO LEARN ABOUT THE IMPACTS OF
DROUGHT UNEMPLOYMENT AND WILL BE
THAT IS HOW IS IT IMPACTING FOOD
SECURITY HOW IS IT IMPACTING
WATER SECURITY AND HEALTH. IN
SOME CONTEXT SOME OF THIS HERE'S
A QUOTE FROM A NONPROFIT
DIRECTOR WHO SPENT DECADES IN
THE REGION. STROUT IS A CANCER I
HAVE BEEN INVOLVED IN SEVEN
MAJOR DISASTER RESPONSES WILL
FREEZE WE HAVE AN IMMEDIATE
IMPACT. WE LOSE THE ORANGES AND
THOUSANDS OUT OF WORK. RIGHT
WITH AN IMMEDIATE IMPACT. WE
HAVE A DROUGHT IT IS A SLOW KILL
EACH YEAR IT IS LIKE A CANCER
RATHER THAN HEART ATTACK. WE
HAVE A HEART ATTACK IT IS
IMMEDIATELY DIAGNOSED WITH
CANCER IT GOES ON KILLING YOU
UNDETECTED. AND ONE OF THE MAJOR
AREAS THAT. DROUGHT IMPACTS FARM
WORKERS IN RURAL COMMUNITIES IN
GENERAL HAS TO DO WITH LABOR AND
EMPLOYMENT. AND A COMMUNITY
WORKER THEY INTERVIEWED SHE
DESCRIBED IT AS A CONDITION OF
UNDER EMPLOYMENT. SO FARMERS
DON'T HAVE ONE JOB THROUGHOUT
THE YEAR THEY'RE OFTEN TAKING
VERY SHORT. JOBS ONE AFTER
ANOTHER SO I AM SO I SPOKE WITH
ONE FARMER CRAIG SHE DESCRIBED
HER HERE TO ME AND SHE SAYS. IT
ALL IN A COUPLE WEEKS PICKING
GRAPES AND THEN I'LL GO AND
SPEND ANOTHER WEEK COUPLE WEEKS
FIGHTING TO MALES AND IT'S
CONTINUOUS SO WHILE THEY STILL
HAD SOME LEVEL OF EMPLOYMENT
DURING THE DROUGHT. OVERALL
THERE WAS LESS WORK. I AM I
CONDUCTED A SURVEY IN TWO
DIFFERENT COUNTIES IN TULARE AND
FRESNO COUNTY AND 76% OF THE
PEOPLE SURVEYED SAID THERE WAS
LESS WORK AVAILABLE IN 65%
DECREASED AND THE REPORTED. A
DECREASE IN INCOME DURING THE
DROUGHT. A LOT OF FARMWORKERS
EXPLAINED IF THEY HAD A TROUBLE
A LOT FARTHER DID YOU FIND WORK
SO. OF PEOPLE WHO ARE LIVING IN
COMMUNITIES IN MENDOTA. HEIGHTS
NEAR FRESNO WERE TURNED IN
DURING THIS TIME WERE TRAVELING
TWO TO THREE HOURS EACH WAY TO
FIND WORK IN REGIONS LIKE
SALINAS VALLEY. A LOT OF THE
FARM WORKERS ALSO COMPLAINED
ABOUT THE CLOSURE FOR PACKING
PLANTS IS NOT ONLY NECESSARILY.
WORK BUT ON THE ON THE FARM
ITSELF ALONG THE- PRODUCTION
PROCESS. IT INTO THE REGION ALSO
WITNESSED A DECREASE AND
MIGRATORY WORKERS ARE KIND OF
TWO CATEGORIES THE FARMWORKERS
THEIR FARM WORKERS WHO LIVE IN
THE REGION YEAR ROUND. AND THERE
ARE FORMER BECAUSE YOU SPEND A
LOT OF TIME TRAVELING BETWEEN
WASHINGTON STATE OREGON AND
ARIZONA AND SO DURING THIS TIME
PERIOD THEY JUST SKIPS SEVENTEEN
VALLEY BECAUSE THERE WAS NOT
ENOUGH WORK AVAILABLE. AND THIS
HAD IMPACTS ON LOCAL BUSINESSES
THAT WERE SET UP TO SUPPORT THEM
DURING THIS TIME PEOPLE TALK TO
ME- ABOUT NORMALLY IT DURING A
CITY LIKE WINDOW THAT. WOULD
SWELL BY EMAILING NUMBERS BY
THOUSANDS WHEN THESE MIGRATORY
WORKERS COMMAND A LOT OF PEOPLE
HAVE HOUSING AND- BUSINESSES
THAT ARE USED TO SUPPORT THEM
AND SO THEY HAVE AS BIG IMPACTS
DURING THIS TIME. AND THIS WAS
ADDRESSED EARLIER AND DOCTOR
LIPPER'S PRESENTATION. BEING
DETERMINANT OF THE IMPACT OF
DROUGHT ON FARM WORKERS HAS TO
DO WITH THE- LABOR DEMANDS OF
EACH CROP. AND HERE IN THIS
GRAPH WE CAN SEE HOW MANY JOBS
EACH ACRE OF CROPS PROVIDES FOR
FARM WORKERS AND THIS IS THIS IS
THIS IS THIS NUMBER COMES FROM A
STUDY DONE IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY. AND SO IT REALLY DEPENDS
WHAT. FARMERS ARE DECIDING TO
NOT PLAN DURING YOUR DURING A
ROUTE THAT IMPACTS FARM WORKERS
SO IF YOU'RE IN A PASTURE WHICH
IS ONLY PROVIDED ONE OR TWO JOBS
ON AVERAGE. ARE FOLLOWED IT
DOESN'T HAVE A BIG IMPACT ON
FARM WORKERS BUT- WHAT WE SEE IS
THAT DURING THE DROUGHT OFTEN
THE FRUITS AND VEGETABLES THAT
HAVE A HIGH LABOR DEMAND ARE
FOLLOWED. SO THIS WOULD BE THE
SITE MELONS AND SQUASH AND
CUCUMBERS AND MELONS PROVIDE ON
AVERAGE IS A HUNDRED AND SIXTY
TWO JOBS PER ACRE FOR FARM
WORKERS- AND- DURING THIS TIME
WE ALSO SAW THAT FARMERS WERE
BEING ACTUALLY INCREASING. THE
NUMBER OF ALMONDS PISTACHIOS AND
TREATMENTS AND THAT'S BECAUSE
THEY AREN'T VEN THOUGH THEY DO
REQUIRE MORE WATER. THEY WERE
HAVING HIGHER RETURNS IN THE
INTERNATIONAL MARKETS SO I'M A
RESERVIST TIMER KIND OF DOUBLE
HIT ONE BECAUSE THERE WAS LESS-
THE DROUGHT LEADING FARMERS TO
NOT PLANT TOMATOES AND STUFF BUT
ALSO BECAUSE THE INCREASE IN
ALMONDS AND PISTACHIOS THERE IS
A DECREASE IN JOBS AVAILABLE FOR
ALL. AND SO HERE'S WELL FROM A-
STAFF MEMBER FROM NONPROFIT YOU
SPENT A LOT OF TIME WORKING WITH
FARMERS. AND SHE TOLD ME MORE
INFORMATION IS GETTING BACK TO
US FOR A FARMER WHO COMMUNITIES
IMPACTS SUCH AS LOWER HOURS AND
SHIELDS WORK CHANGING
SPORADICALLY ACTUALLY GETTING
THREATS FROM FARMERS SAYING IF
IT DOESN'T RAIN. THEY'RE GOING
TO LAY OFF OVER THREE HUNDRED
PEOPLE. THE SECOND I MENTIONED
THAT I STUDY DURING THE DROUGHT
HAD TO DO WITH THE IMPACT OF THE
DROUGHT ON. FARMWORKER ENROLL
RESIDENTS OVERALL WELL BEING.
THE COMBINATION OF UNDER
EMPLOYMENT AND INCREASED
GROUNDWATER PUMPING DURING THE
DROUGHT HAS SERIOUS CONSEQUENCES
ON THE WELL BEING. OF PEOPLE
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT CAME TO FOOD
AND SECURITY WATER AND SECURITY
AND HEALTH. PEOPLE INTERVIEWED
REPORTED INCREASED DIFFICULTY IN
BEING ABLE TO PAY FOR FOOD PAY
FOR UTILITIES AND PAY FOR RENT.
AND THEY ALSO REPORTED. I'M
HAVING JUST LESS FOOD IN THE
HOUSE OVERALL. THE BIGGEST AND
MOST DRAMATIC IMPACT WAS ON
WATER AND SECURITY. IN RURAL
HOUSEHOLDS IN THE REGION ARE
DEPENDENT ON DOMESTIC WATER
WELLS BETWEEN DRY DURING THE
DROUGHT. AND IN THE MEDIA THIS
IS- THERE ARE A LOT OF REPORTS
OF A COMMUNITY SUPPORTER BELT
WHERE MANY OF THE HOUSES WENT
FOR YEARS WITHOUT ANY RUNNING
WATER. AT FRESNO COUNTY THERE
WERE OVER TWO HUNDRED THIRTY.
WELLS REPORTED DRY INTO LARRY
COUNTY IT'S JUST OVER TWO
THOUSAND. BUT AS THIS IS VASTLY
UNDER REPORTED. BECAUSE MANY
RURAL RESIDENTS ARE HESITANT TO
REPORT FOR FEAR OF BEING
DEPORTED. FOR BEING EVICTED BY
THEIR LANDLORDS OR FOR HAVING
THEIR TAKEN CHILDREN TAKEN AWAY
BY CHILD PROTECTIVE SERVICES FOR
LIVING IN A HOUSE WITHOUT
RUNNING WATER. PEOPLE ALSO
TALKED ABOUT THEIR CONCERNS ON
WATER QUALITY. SOME OF THE
FAMILIES I SPOKE WITH HAD
STOPPED DRINKING THEIR WATER
BECAUSE OF THE WAY IT SMELLED
AND TASTED. AND A LOT OF REPORTS
AND STUDIES THAT ANALYZE THE WAY
THE DROUGHT IMPACTS WATER
QUALITY OVERALL. AND MANY OF THE
FARM WORKERS AND RURAL RESIDENTS
ALSO SPOKE TO ME ABOUT THE WAYS
CHALLENGE AND RESPECTED HEALTH.
PEOPLE COMPLAIN THAT THEY COULD
NO LONGER AFFORD HEALTH CARE AND
THAT WILL BE ABLE TO PAY BY
CRITICAL MEDICINES. IN COPING
WITH DRY WELLS WAS INCREDIBLY
DIFFICULT FOR ELDERLY PEOPLE AND
PEOPLE WITH CHRONIC HEALTH
PROBLEMS. I SPOKE WITH ONE WOMAN
WHO IS PART OF L. WHO HAD BEEN
UNDERGOING TREATMENT FOR BREAST
CANCER. AND SHE'S GOING TO
CHEMOTHERAPY. INCREDIBLY
DIFFICULT BECAUSE SHE DIDN'T
HAVE RUNNING WATER AT HOME IT'S
JUST SO YOU KNOW ABOUT GROWING
UP IN MEXICO WHERE SHE DIDN'T
HAVE RUNNING WATER BUT SHE MOVED
TO THE U. S. AND THOUGHT THIS
WAS SOMETHING SHE HAD. SHE WOULD
HAVE TO EXPERIENCE AGAIN. SORRY
THIS IS ANOTHER WOMAN WHO LIVED
IN PORTERVILLE AND WENT THREE
YEARS WITHOUT WATER. AND SHE
SAYS FOR THIS TRIAL I HAD TO
HUMBLE MYSELF MY HUSBAND HAD A
STROKE AND IT WAS VERY DIFFICULT
FOR US TO LIFT THE WATER JUGS.
WE CANNOT USE OUR LAUNDRY
MACHINE AND HAD TO GO TO A
LAUNDROMAT. I LOST A LOT OF
WEIGHT FROM THE STRESS OF THE
STRAP I WOULD FLUSH THE TOILETS
WITH RAIN WATER. I READ IT IS
LEGAL TO CATCH THAT RAIN WATER
BUT I WOULD SECRETLY DO IT THIS
TRIAL HAS BROUGHT ME TO MY NEEDS
. AND HERE IS THE SOME PICTURES
OF THE WATER DISTRIBUTION
POINTS- HERE THE WATER JUGS ARE
BEING DISTRIBUTED TO COMMUNITY
MEMBERS AND THE WIDER CARDS SO
PEOPLE WOULD HAVE THESE PUNCH
CARDS. AND ONCE A WEEK YOU WILL
BE ABLE TO COME IN AND PICK UP
BOTTLED WATER. THE PICTURE IN
THE MIDDLE OF THIS. THANKS
ANOTHER WATERSHED. AND THIS IS
THE ONLY SOURCE OF WATER IN THE
KITCHEN THE WOMAN'S HOUSE. AND
IT WAS JST INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT
TIME FOR PEOPLE AND A VERY
EMOTIONAL TIME FOR THEM AS WELL. FINALLY A MESSAGE I HEARD
SEVERAL TIMES FROM FARM WORKERS
AND RURAL RESIDENTS WITH THE
NEED FOR MORE ECONOMIC
INVESTMENT. AND MORE ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES BEYOND FOREIGN
JOBS. I MENDOTA FARM WORKER THAT
I MET DURING THE DISTRIBUTION
EXPLAINED. WE ARE GRATEFUL THAT
THEY BRING THIS FOOD BUT WE WANT
MORE WORK TO GET MORE FIT TO GET
MORE RESOURCES TO GET MORE FOR
THE FAMILY I NEED TO PAY RENT I
NEED TO GET MY KIDS CLOTHES I
NEED TO GET SOMETHING BETTER TO
MY KIDS AND WE DON'T HAVE IT IN
JUST BRING FOOD. AND SHOPS. AND
SO THESE ARE SOME
RECOMMENDATIONS AND CONCLUSIONS
FROM MY RESEARCH. DROUGHT RELIEF
REQUIRES CLEAR COORDINATION
GUARD WORKING RELATIONSHIP
pACROSS DIVERSE AREAS OF
EXPERTISE. IT'S NOT. DROUGHT
WASN'T JUST ABOUT LABOR AND IT
WASN'T JUST ABOUT WATER AND IT
WASN'T JUST ABOUT HELP. IT IS
ALL THOSE THINGS COMBINED. AT A
LAPTOP TONIGHT SPOKE WITH SOCIAL
WORKERS IN GOVERNMENT AGENCIES.
AND THEY WERE OVERWHELMED DURING
THE TWO THOUSAND TWELVE THOUSAND
EXTREME DROUGHT. THEN THEY JUST
STATEMENT. PREPARATION
COORDINATION AMONG PEOPLE.
THERE'S ALSO NEED TO INCLUDE
MORE DIVERSE VOICES IN WATER
MANAGEMENT DROUGHT PLANNING NOT
JUST A FARM WORKERS BUT ALSO THE
FARM WORKERS. FINALLY THERE'S
DEFINITELY A NEED FOR MORE
ECONOMIC INVESTMENT IN BOTH
COMMUNITIES IN ORDER TO HAVE
MORE DROUGHT RESILIENT
COMMUNITIES AND NOT JUST
DEPENDENCY ON JOBS THAT COME IN
GOD'S WHICH IS WHAT. YOU GET IN
THE FIELD. I'M SO THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
HERE A LOT OF THIS WORK HAS BEEN
PUBLISHED IN SEVERAL DIFFERENT
PLACES BUT- THE STATE WIDE. THE
CALIFORNIA'S FOR CLIMATE CHANGE
ASSESSMENT IS THE SOURCE OF ALL
THAT. AND- THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU TO OUR PANEL I HAVE A
COUPLE QUESTIONS AND FEEL FREE
TO SPEAK UP IF YOU HAVE THE
ANSWERS TO ANY OF THE- I'M- VERY
THANKFUL TO YOU ALL- TO YOU EACH
FOR THE PRESENTATION AND- YEAH
YOU'RE FOR DOCTOR LIPPER I. YOU
KNOW ACCORDING TO SOME SOURCES
ABILITY TO GROW FOOD WILL BE
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCED DUE TO
CLIMATE CHANGE- WHAT IS A DROP
IN CALIFORNIA MEAN FOR A FOOD
SECURITY GLOBALLY. WELL THAT'S
NOT IT THAT'S NOT A QUESTION TO
ANSWER. BUT THE- CALIFORNIA IS A
MAJOR SUPPLIER I HAVE IT PRETTY
GOOD THESE NUTRIENT DENSE FOODS
THAT ARE NOW BEING REALLY
HIGHLIGHTED AS IMPORTANT FOR
FOOD SECURITY. SO IT THE
IMPLICATIONS AND IT DEPENDS A
LOT ON WHAT HAPPENS WITH OTHER
PRODUCERS AT FIRST WELL DEPENDS
A LOT ON WHAT CALIFORNIA DOES
BUT ITS OWN PRODUCTION HOUSE HOW
IS CALIFORNIA PRODUCTION GET IT
CHANGED. IN THIS CONTEXT THIS.
AT THE END OF THE CONTEXT OF
CLIMATE CHANGE AND ALSO OTHER
GLOBAL PATTERNS OF CHANGE. AND
IF THERE IS A SIGNIFICANT
REDUCTION FROM CALIFORNIA
SOURCES ARE THERE ALTERNATIVE
SOURCES OF SUPPLY. AS THAT
THERE'S SOME ANALYSIS LOOKING AT
YES THERE ARE POSSIBILITIES BUT-
I'VE NOT SPECIFIC TO CALIFORNIA
BUT JUST POSSIBILITIES OF NEW
AREAS COMING INTO PRODUCTION
WITH DIFFERENT KINDS O CROPS.
BUT ALSO SOME OF THE CONDITIONS
OF CLIMATE CHANGE BUT I THINK
SOME OF THE OTHER EXPERTS LATER
ON MIGHT HAVE MORE TO SAY ABOUT
IT. YEAH THESE ARE BIG BIG
CHANGES SO LIKE THE INCREASED
INCIDENCE OF EXTREME EVENTS IS
CHANGING IT FOR EVERYBODY EVEN
IF YOUR CONDITIONS. OF PERHAPS A
LITTLE BIT BETTER THAN
CALIFORNIA. BILL THE IT'S- IT'S
NOT TOTALLY CLEAR THAT YOU WHAT
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN ABLE TO DO
AND IT'S STILL ABLE TO DO. IS
GOING TO BE ABLE TO BE
SUBSTITUTED IF IT. TURNS OUT
THAT THAT CALIFORNIA WILL HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT REDUCTION. I I'M NOT
AN EXPERT IN THE NET AND AREA TO
TELL YOU LIKE WHAT I WHAT ARE
THE MODELS TELLING US ABOUT HOW
HOW FEASIBLE IS IT TO MAINTAIN
CALIFORNIA'S. CURRENT STATE OF
PRODUCTION. BUT I DO THINK A LOT
OF THE DISCUSSION AROUND THAT IS
WHAT IT IS SUBSTITUTION
POSSIBILITIES YES THERE MAY BE
BUT EVEN THESE ARE GOING TO BE
HIT BY SOME OF THE SAME I DO IS
MAYBE NOT THE SAME BUT IT'S
GOING TO BE HIT BY PROBLEMS AND
IT WON'T BE THE SAME LEVEL. AS
WE SAY IN THE PAST AND SO
THEREFORE THERE'S A LOT OF
DISCUSSION ALSO AND ARE WE
LOOKING AT A LONG TERM INCREASE
IN FOOD PRICES AND WHAT DOES
THAT MEAN. OVERALL AND THAT'S
THAT'S GOT A LOT OF IMPLICATIONS
FOR POOR PEOPLE AROUND THE WORLD
. AND MY NEXT QUESTION HAS TO DO
ABOUT- ACTUALLY FOOD PRICES AND-
OBVIOUSLY IT'S- PAYING A LIVING
WAGE AND BEYOND FOR EMPLOYEES
ARE AGRICULTURE EMPLOYEES FOR
FARM WORKERS- IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT BUT- HOW HOW. DO YOU
HAVE ANY SUGGESTIONS OR THOUGHTS
OR IDEAS ON HOW WE CAN. WITH ALL
THE CHALLENGES THAT CLIMATE
CHANGE IS PRESENTING ON US- ON
IT HOW DO HOW DO WE BALANCE AT
ALL IN TERMS OF KEEPING FOOD
PRICES DOWN BUT- CONTINUING OR
IF NOT IMPROVING ACTUALLY THINK
WE NEED TO IMPROVE WE NEED TO
IMPROVE ON. PAIN BEYOND THE
EIGHTY EIGHT- LIVING WAGE TO TWO
FARM WORKERS AND AGRICULTURAL
EMPLOYEES ARE DO YOU HAVE ANY
THOUGHTS OR IDEAS AND- IN THAT
REGARD. I CAN JUST TELL YOU SOME
OF THE DISCUSSIONS AS **** CLICK
IN THE- FOOD SYSTEM SOME OF BUT
ALSO TO SENIORS WORKING OUT FILE
. AND IT MORE RECENT WORK ALSO
JUST LOOKING ON. THE RETURNS TO
CAPITAL VERSUS RETURNS TO LABOR
SO THAT INVESTMENTS CAPITAL IT
IT IT DID THERE'S DISCUSSION
AROUND MAYBE THERE NEEDS TO BE A
OF MORE. EQUAL SHARING OF THE
BENEFITS BETWEEN THE INVESTMENT
CAPITAL AND SAVE X. WHAT EQUITY
CAPITAL PEOPLE THAT ARE WORKING
IN INDUSTRIES IN PARTICULAR
AGRICULTURE THIS IS BIG
DISCUSSION. SO HOW TO DO THAT
AND IS ANYBODY DOING IT AND I
DON'T KNOW THAT I DON'T THINK
ANYBODY'S ACTUALLY HAD A
SUCCESSFUL. BUT AT THE HAVE SAID
DON'T KNOW BUT- IT'S- ONE OF THE
SORT OF IT VERY BASIC THING THAT
THERE'S BEEN THIS HIGHER RETURN
TO PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
INVEST. FINANCIAL CAPITAL WHERE
IS THE PEOPLE THAT ACTUALLY DOES
SAY HAVE THE LABORS ARE GETTING
A LOWER SHARE OF THE BENEFITS
AND THAT'S CHANGED OVER TIME IT
USED TO BE HIGHER. THAT THE
THERE WAS A MORE EQUAL SPLIT
BETWEEN LABOR AND CAPITAL. IN
TERMS OF GETTING THE RETURNS AND
SO THEREFORE WE DO ACTUALLY HAVE
SOME EXPERIENCE WITH HOW THAT
WORKED IN THE PAST YOU COULD
LOOK AT THOSE MODELS AND TRY TO.
GO BACK USE SOME OF THOSE
TECHNIQUES TO. TO GET A MORE
EQUITABLE. DIVISION OF THE
RETURNS FROM THINGS LIKE YOU
KNOW THAT CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE. THANK YOU AND THE OTHER
QUESTION- EITHER PRODUCTIVE
INTERACTIVE PREEN- AND IN TERMS
OF WORKING WITH THE GET YOUR
DOES THAT HAVE BEEN IMPACTED BY
THE DROUGHT. ANOTHER'S DOCTRINE
PROVIDED A LOT OF EXAMPLES ARE I
MEAN IT WHAT ELSE WHAT ELSE HAVE
YOU HEARD OR HAVE YOU SEEN IN
TERMS OF. IT'S NOT JUST THE DROP
IN EXTREME HEAT BECAUSE AS WE
MENTIONED HE HAS MENTIONED
EARLIER AT. THE DROP THIS DOES
IT'S NOT IT DOESN'T COME ALONG
YOU ALSO SEE EXTREME HEAT
EXTREME. TEMPERATURES AND- WHAT
WHAT WHAT ARE YOU SEEING IN
TERMS OF- THE IMPACTS TO HEALTH
OR THE WELL BEING OF INDIVIDUALS
THAT. ARE MOST IMPACTED BY THESE
TWO. HE DEFINITELY DID COME UP
IN MY DISCUSSIONS WITH FARM
WORKERS. AND THEY'RE ACTUALLY A
A FARM WORKER CAN STAY IN THE
FIELD DEPENDING ON- THE
TEMPERATURE AND THEY DID SAY
THEY WOULD GET A CERTAIN NUMBER
OF BREAKS IF TEMPERATURES FOR.
OVER A HUNDRED AND- THEY'RE
ALLOWED TO WATER BREAKS I THINK
. THERE IS. A LOT OF WORK BEING
DONE ON THAT BUT IT'S DEFINITELY
RANGE FOR IMPROVEMENT BECAUSE
YOU KNOW CLIMATE PROJECTIONS ARE
. W. PROJECTING THAT WE'RE GOING
TO GET HIGHER TEMPERATURES FOR
LONG PERIODS OF TIME. ENSURING
THAT A LOT OF FARM WORKERS KNOW
ABOUT THEIR RIGHTS- DURING THIS
TIME I THINK IS REALLY IMPORTANT. YEAH I JUST I WANT TO TACKLE-
THOSE COMMENTS AS WELL AS A FEW
OTHERS- YES SO IN IN THE
PSYCHIATRIC WORLD WE KNOW VERY
WELL THAT ON CERTAIN MEDICATIONS
CAN MESS WITH THE AUTO
REGULATION WE HAVE TO EXPERIENCE
HOW OUR BODY REGULATES THAT
TEMPERATURE. SO YEAH I KNOW IT'S
A BIG CONCERN BECAUSE WINTER'S
EXTREME HEAT PEOPLE ON CERTAIN
MEDICATIONS WILL RESPOND TO IT
DIFFERENTLY THEY MIGHT- ACTUALLY
IT MIGHT BE A HUNDRED YEARS FOR
US BUT IT MIGHT BE A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY DEGREES FOR THAT SO-
THAT'S A REAL IMPLICATION FIRM
ON THE PSYCHIATRIC ASPECT OF
PATIENTS AND OF COURSE MENTAL
HEALTH- BUT YEAH NO IT'S OF
EXTREME CONCERN HEAT STROKES-
ARE REAL THEY'RE ON THE RISE. I
AM AND I REALLY REALLY WORRY
ABOUT OUR ELDERLY POPULATION
BECAUSE A LOT OF THEM- AS YOU
GROW OLDER YOU DON'T YOU CANNOT
RETAIN YOUR BODY HEAT AS WELL
ESPECIALLY WITH YOUNG BABIES
SPECIALLY AT AT YOUR EXTREME AT
YOUR EXTREME AGES SO YEAH- IT'S
GONNA DEFINITELY A FACTOR
ELDERLY POPULATION AS WELL AND
IT HAPPENS- IN IN VERY MANY WAYS
AND WE SEE THAT. IN OUR
HOSPITALS AND CLINICS AS WELL SO
THERE'S A VERY. EXTREME- THE
EMPLOYEE. OF THE DRAW AND THE
EXTREME WEATHER AS WELL. THANK
YOU SO MUCH TO OUR SECOND SECOND
PANEL I APPRECIATE YOUR TIME AND
ALL OF THE WORK THAT YOU FIND
OUT THAT YOU'VE DONE AND YOU
CONTINUE TO DO AND THE SPACE. R.
AND- WE WILL BE MOVING ON TO OUR
THIRD PANEL OUR THIRD AND FINAL
PANEL. AND IT'S HARD TO MOVE
FORWARD. TO IT AND THE FIRST
SPEAKER THAT WE HAVE IS LOUDER
ROMMEL'S ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR OF
RESEARCH AND EDUCATION.
CALIFORNIA WATER INSTITUTE AT
FRESNO STATE AND MODEL WALK
COMPLETES UP FEEL FREE TO BEGIN
WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU AND
IT IS MY PLEASURE TO BE HERE
TODAY AND I'M GONNA SHARE. ONE
OF OUR CURRENT EFFORTS AS WELL
AS A RECENT STUDY THAT. FOCUSES
ON HOW WE CAN MOVE FORWARD SO
LET ME SHARE MY SCREEN. ERIC I'M
SORRY ABOUT THAT. I'M SO WE BUT
WE'VE HEARD TODAY FROM- THE
PREVIOUS SPEAKERS IS THAT WATER
SHORTAGE IS GOING TO CAUSE A LOT
OF CHANGES AND PROBLEMS MOVING
FORWARD AND SOME OF THOSE ARE
BECAUSE OF THE POPULATION GROWTH
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT. CHANGES IN
CLIMATIC AGING OR DETERIORATING
INFRASTRUCTURE GROUNDWATER
OVERDRAFT ENDANGERED SPECIES
DECLINES AS WELL AS- FRAGMENTED
. WATER MANAGEMENT. AND SO THE
CALIFORNIA WATER INSTITUTE AT
FRESNO STATE BEGAN AND THIS
EFFORT IN TWENTY NINETEEN AND IT
WAS ACTUALLY IN RESPONSE TO THE
CALIFORNIA WATER RESILIENT
PORTFOLIO INITIATIVES ARE CENTER
HAD TO STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT
SESSIONS ON TWO SATURDAYS THAT
INCLUDED URBAN AGRICULTURE
ENVIRONMENTAL AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITY ADVOCATES FROM THOSE
SESSIONS THEY MADE. FIVE
RECOMMENDATIONS THE FIRST
RECOMMENDATION WAS THAT WE
SHOULD CREATE A SHARED VISION
FOR WATER IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY. PREPARE A CONCEPTUAL
LEVEL WATER INVESTMENT PLAN.
THAT INCLUDED THAT SHARED VISION
CREATED AN ORGANIZATIONAL AND
GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE STRUCTURE
FOR IMPLEMENTING THAT VISION.
DEVELOPING AND FINANCIAL
STRATEGY TO FUND THE SHARED
VISION AS WELL AS DEVELOP A
PROJECT DELIVERY PLAN. AS LESLIE
MENTIONED EARLIER- DURING HER
PRESENTATION ABOUT THE
AUSTRALIAN DROUGHT STUDY. THERE
WILL BE A DRAMATIC IMPACT ON
INCOME DUE TO WATER SHORTAGES
AND AS- CHRISTINA MENTIONED
THERE WILL ALSO BE IMPACTS TO
EMPLOYMENT IN THE SANFORD CAME
VALLEY. FROM OUR STUDY WE
CONCLUDED THAT THERE WILL BE AN
ESTIMATED FARM RECEIPTS DECLINE
OF ABOUT SEVEN POINT TWO BILLION
DUE TO THE ECONOMIC IMPACT THAT
WATER SHORTAGES WE HAVE WE WILL
HAVE IF WE DO NOTHING- THE OTHER
IMPACTS THAT IT WILL HAVE
INCLUDE STATE WATER OPERATING
INCOME LOSSES. AS WELL AS STATE
WIDE EMPLOYEE INCOME LOSSES AND
STATEWIDE EMPLOYEE INCOME LOSSES
AND THIS IS MAINLY DUE TO AS AS
CHRISTINA MENTIONED EARLIER IT
IS NOT JUST THE AG JOBS THAT ARE
AFFECTED BY ALL OF THIS BECAUSE
THERE ARE SUPPORTING INDUSTRIES
AS WELL AS OTHERS THAT DEPEND ON
THOSE WORKERS SUCH AS STORES
GROCERY STORES AND OTHERS. AND
SO WE ESTIMATE OUR STUDY
ESTIMATED THAT THERE WILL BE A
TOTAL OF STATEWIDE TOTAL LOSSES
OF ABOUT EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND-
JOBS AGAIN IF WE DO NOTHING TO
CORRECT OR TO IMPROVE THE WATER
SHORTAGE CONDITIONS. AND THIS
WILL HAVE AN ESTIMATED ANNUAL
TAX LOSSES OF ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
AND NINETY THREE BECAUSE ALL OF
THESE EMPLOYEES WILL NOT- WILL
NOT BE. WORKING AND SO- IN
RESPONSE TO SENATOR MILAN DAYS-
QUESTION EARLIER ABOUT HOW MUCH
WILL IT COST TO DO SOMETHING.
RACHEL MENTIONED THAT IT WAS AN
ESTIMATE OF FOURTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS FOR CALIFORNIA SO WE
CONDUCTED A STUDY AND OUR
ESTIMATE IN TWENTY NINETEEN WAS
THAT IT WOULD COST AN ESTIMATED
SEVEN BILLION FOR A ONE TIME
WATER INVESTMENT PROGRAM- AS
RACHEL ALSO MENTIONED EARLIER.
WE'VE BEEN REALLY GOOD LATELY
DURING THIS DROUGHT AT EMERGENCY
RESPONSE BUT WE NEED TO STOP
THINKING OF EMERGENCY HOW TO
RESPOND IN CASE OF AN EMERGENCY
WE NEED TO START PLANNING NOW TO
PREPARE FOR THE FUTURE. AND SO
OUR STUDY INCLUDED A PLAN FOR.
FUNDING OF THIS INFRASTRUCTURE
IN THE NEXT FORTY YEARS AND
CREATED THESE CHANGES AS WAS
MENTIONED I BELIEVE FROM SEVERAL
EARLIER THAT ONE SIZE DOES NOT
FIT ALL IT IS NOT JUST NEW
SURFACE WATER TREATMENT PLANTS
IT IS NOT JUST- ONE OR ANOTHER
IT IS A BUFFET OF ITEMS THAT ARE
NEEDED. AND IT ALL STARTS FROM
WATERSHED MANAGEMENT WE CA'T
THINK OF IT AS MANAGING THE
WATER FROM THE RIVER OR FROM THE
COMMUNITIES WE NEED TO THINK OF
IT. AS THE ENTIRE WATERSHED
STARTING FROM THE HEADWATERS
FIRES IS CAUSING HIM. PROBLEMS
WHEN IT RAINS WITH WATER QUALITY
AND JUST DEBRIS THAT IS GOING
AND THAT IT'S NOT ABOUT HAVING
TO BE TREATED SO IT COSTS MORE
MONEY TO TREAT THE WATER SO IT
IS- MAKING CHANGES THAT COME ALL
THE WAY FROM THE HEADWATERS ALL
THE WAY TO THE TOP. AND SO- THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENTS NEED
TO BE AGAIN- WATERSHED AS A
WHOLE THEY NEED TO INCLUDE
ENVIRONMENTAL AND ECOSYSTEM
RIGHT- RESOURCES AS YOU SEE
FROM. THE GRAPHIC IT INCLUDES-
READ. SOME RECHARGE BASINS AND
MULTIPLE AREAS OF THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY IT INCLUDES
SURFACE AND GROUND STORAGE. IT
INCLUDES NEW AND REFURBISHED
CONVEYANCE WE- THE FIRST PANEL
DISCUSSED. POTENTIAL NEW SURFACE
STORAGE. PERSONALITIES AND SO
WE'RE SAYING THAT IT IS BOTH NEW
AND EGGS- REPAIRING EXISTING OR
EXPANDING THEM AND STILL FOR
EXAMPLE EXPANDING THAT SELLERS
RESERVOIR AND THEN POTENTIALLY A
NEW- RESERVOIR SET INCLUDES BOTH
ALSO WE WILL NEED NEW SURFACE
SURFACE WATER TREATMENT PLANT
FACILITIES AS WELL AS WASTEWATER
TREATMENT FACILITIES IN MULTIPLE
AREAS SO AGAIN IT IS NOT A ONE
SIZE FITS ALL. AND IT IS NOT
JUST NEW INFRASTRUCTURE BUT IT
IS IMPROVING AND OUR EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE AS YOU SEE FROM
THE GRAPHIC ALSO THERE ARE- THE
EXCLAMATION MARKS ARE WHERE
THERE IS DAMAGE TO OUR CANALS
DUE TO SUBSIDENCE SO OUR PLAN
AND OUR ESTIMATE ALSO INCLUDES.
MAKING THE NECESSARY CHANGES SO
THAT THOSE CANALS CAN TRANSPORT
THE WATER THAT THEY WERE
INTENDED TO. AND SO YOU MIGHT
ASK WHAT DOES THAT FIVE BILLION
DOLLAR INCLUDES SO IT INCLUDES
THAT THAT SORRY THE SEVEN
BILLION OUT OF THAT SEVEN
BILLION FIVE BILLION WOULD GO TO
A LOT OF DEBT. INFRASTRUCTURE
ELEMENTS GROUNDWATER FACILITIES
RECOVERY FACILITIES SURFACE
DRINKING WATER FACILITIES CANALS
AND THEN THE REST WOULD INCLUDE
THE TRADITIONAL EXPENSES THAT GO
WITH CONSTRUCTION SUCH AS LAND
ACQUISITION FACILITY PLANNING
DESIGNING SEEKER AND SO ON. AND
ALSO AS I MENTIONED EARLIER
THESE ARE TWO THOUSAND NINE
NUMBERS AND- I'VE BEEN HEARING
THAT THIS IS MORE EQUIVALENT TO
ABOUT NINE AT THE MOMENT. AND
SO- WE UNDERSTAND THAT THE SEVEN
BILLION IS A PRETTY BIG. PRICE
TAG EVEN IF IT IS A ONE TIME
OVER THE NEXT FORTY YEARS AND SO
WHAT OUR STUDY CONCLUDED IS THAT
THE STATE FEDERAL OR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS CANNOT DO IT ALONE
AND SO WE BELIEVE THAT IT WOULD
TAKE ALL. OF US WORKING TOGETHER
TO BE ABLE TO FINANCE THIS AND
MAKE A AN EFFORT TO DESIGN AND A
PLANET TOGETHER AND COMMUNICATE
WITH EACH OTHER SO WE BELIEVE
THAT. SOME OF THE MONEY SHOULD
COME FROM THE STATES SOME FROM
THE FEDERAL SOME FROM GREENHOUSE
REDUCTION FUND- POTENTIAL WATER
SURCHARGES AS WELL AS- A SPECIAL
TAX ADD TO THE- TO CALIFORNIA
AND SO THAT WOULD. MAKE SURE
THAT LOCAL FEDERAL AND STATE ARE
ALL INVOLVED IN IN THIS EFFORT
BUT WE ALSO MUST MAKE SURE THAT
IT. TO USE AN ANALOGY OF
BUILDING A HOME- SO WHEN YOU'RE
BUILDING A HOME YOU PUT UP A
WALL AND YOU LEAVE THE SPACE FOR
IT BUT WHERE YOU KNOW A DOOR
MIGHT BE EVEN IF YOU DON'T HAVE
THE FUNDING FOR THAT DOOR AT THE
MOMENT. YOU'RE PREPARING
EVERYTHING AROUND ITFOR WHEN
THAT DOOR IS GOING TO BE BUILT
SO IF WE'RE GOING TO BUILD NEW
INFRASTRUCTURE REFURBISHED WE
NEED TO COORDINATE SO WE KNOW
THAT. IN THIS WALL THERE WILL BE
A DOOR SO THAT WE DON'T BUILD A
WALL AND THEN WE HAVE TO GO BACK
AND MAKE CHANGES TO THE WALL TO
FIT THE DOOR INSTEAD WE'RE
COORDINATING ALL OF OUR EFFORTS
TO MAKE SURE THAT IT IS. A HEY
CORD A ONE BIG. EFFORT THAT
WORKS TOGETHER FOR THE BENEFIT
OF THE ENTIRE WATERSHED. AND SO
HOW DOES THIS HAPPEN OR WHAT IS
THE NEXT STEP- SO THE NEXT STEPS
ARE PHASE ONE WHICH WOULD JUST
INCLUDE PLANNING ORGANIZING AND
GOVERNANCE AND IT WOULD BEGIN
WITH CREATING A SHARED VISION
FOR ST HIKING VALLEY WATER
MANAGEMENT. FOLLOWED BY. A
PROJECT FINANCING WHICH COULD
INCLUDE A BALLOT MEASURE AND
THEN THE PHASE THREE WOULD BE
THE PROJECT DELIVERY WHICH WOULD
INCLUDE- INITIATING FACILITY
PLANNING AND PRELIMINARY
ENGINEERING EFFORTS. AND SO-
SENSE OUR- INITIAL STUDY WE'VE
THEN. FORMED A GROUP THAT IS
HELPING TO MOVE SOME OF THESE
ITEMS FORWARD THERE ARE SOME-
EMERGING COLLABORATIONS IN THE
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY AND SPECIFIC
I'LL TELL YOU ABOUT- THIS ONE
AND SO IT CAME FROM AN EFFORT OR
A PAPER WRITTEN BY TIM CLAN. AT
ABOUT WHAT HE LEARNED IN THE
LAST FORTY YEARS OF WORKING IN
THE WATER INDUSTRY AND WATER
POLICY INSTITUTE CONSISTS OF
SOME OF THE HIS CONCLUSIONS WERE
THAT IT NEEDS TO BE AND
FACILITATED LEADERSHIP THAT
NEEDS TO HAVE FACILITATED
LEADERSHIP AS WELL AS BE A
COLLABORATION. AND SO- THERE'S
AN EMERGING COLLABORATION GOING
ON AT THE MOMENT AND IT BEGAN
WITH REPRESENTATIVES FROM FRESNO
STATE STANFORD AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS. IT IS CURRENTLY CO
CHAIRED BY BUZZ THOMPSON AND
ASHLEY SORENSEN AND THE FIRST
SESSION INCLUDED OVER FIFTY
PARTICIPANTS TODAY THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY WATER
COLLABORATIVE ACTION PROGRAM
WHICH I WILL CALL CAP FOR SHORT
DURING THIS PRESENTATION. IS
MADE UP OF OVER SEVENTY MEMBERS
OF WHICH WE ASKED FOR VOLUNTEERS
TO BE- AND THE PLANNING GROUP
WHICH TODAY INCLUDES OVER TWENTY
MEMBERS AND THAT PLANNING GROUP
IS THE ONES THAT DO A LOT OF THE
INITIAL WRITING REVIEWING.
PARTICIPATE IN WORK GROUPS- TO
MOVE SOME OF THIS EFFORT FORWARD
AND THE PLANETARY GROUP WHICH
IS- OVER SEVENTY MEMBERS IS THE
FINAL DECISION BODY AND THEN WE
HAVE A STEERING GROUP OF NINE
MEMBERS WHO JUST MAKE SURE THAT
THE EFFORT IS MOVING FORWARD FOR
PRESIDENT AS SCHEDULED MEETINGS.
AND WE HOPE THAT EVERYBODY THAT
IS PARTICIPATING IS ABLE TO COME
TO A UNANIMOUS CONSENSUS. OF
WHAT THE VISION SHOULD BE FOR
THE VALLEY AND THE NEXT STEPS-
THE CAP STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDE
SAFE DRINKING WATER ADVOCATES
ENVIRONMENTAL NGOS LOCAL
GOVERNMENT FODDER FARMERS AND
THE AG INDUSTRY. AS WELL AS
WATER AGENCIES. I'M SENSE. OF
CAP WE'VE CREATED A VISION
STATEMENT WHICH STATES THAT WE
WILL ENSURE A SUSTAINABLE AND
RESILIENT WATER SUPPLY FOR THE
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY FOR MULTIPLE
BENEFITS BY SECURING A SAFE
RELIABLE AFFORDABLE AND
AFFORDABLE ACCESS TO WATER FOR
DRINKING. SUSTAINABLE AND
PRODUCTIVE FARMS AND RANCHES
HEALTHY COMMUNITIES AND THRIVING
TERRITORIAL TERRA. KERIS DRILL
AND FRESHWATER ECOSYSTEMS. WE
BEGAN THAT AND ARE CLOSE TO
BEING DONE WITH THE PHASE ONE
ACTION PLAN WHICH INCLUDES A
COMMON PROBLEM STATEMENT A
COMMON SOLUTION SET AND IT
FOCUSED ON A COMPREHENSIVE
INTEGRATED SET OF SOLUTIONS TO
TRANSFORM THE BLACK VALLEY TO
THE SUSTAINABLE WATER RESOURCES
MANAGEMENT. AND SO MMHM THE CAP
HAS COMPLETED AND THE PROBLEM
STATEMENT AND THE PROBLEM
STATEMENT IS- HAS FIVE MAIN
CATEGORIES WHICH ARE THE
PROBLEMS ARE THAT IT. SOME LACK
OF ACCESS TO SAFE RELIABLE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER
THERE'S A DEMAND GAP. THERE'S A
GAP BETWEEN DEMAND AND SUPPLY.
THERE HAS BEEN LOST TO
HISTORICAL ECOSYSTEMS HABITATS.
THERE IS INADEQUATE PHYSICAL AND
NATE NATURAL INFRASTRUCTURE. AND
THERE'S SOME INCONSISTENT LOCAL
STATE AND FEDERAL POLICIES ALL
OF THE CAUCUSES WHICH ARE THE
STAKEHOLDERS AGREE WITH THE
LEGITIMACY OF THE PROBLEMS FACED
BY THE OTHERS. FROM THE
DEVELOPING OF THE PROBLEM
STATEMENT THE FIVE CATEGORIES WE
CAME UP WITH FIVE. THE DESIRED
OUTCOMES SO WE WOULD LOVE A SAFE
DRINKING WATER FOR ALL VALLEY
RESIDENTS IN A TIMELY MANNER A
SUSTAINABLE WATER SUPPLIES FOR
FARMS COMMUNITIES ECO AND ECO
SYSTEMS INCREASED FLOOD PLAIN
ECOSYSTEM HABITATS A SIGNIFICANT
CHANGE IN THE LOOP THE USE OF
LAND IN THE VALLEY. AND THEN THE
MORE CONSISTENT LOCAL STATE AND
FEDERAL POLICIES AND TO DEVELOP
A LIST OF SOLUTIONS WE CREATED
FIVE WORKING GROUPS THAT WERE TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THESE AND
PROVIDE FEEDBACK AND WE MADE
SURE THAT EVERY ONE OF THESE
GROUPS INCLUDED AT LEAST ONE
FROM ALL OF THE STAKEHOLDER
GROUPS. THE M. THE WORK GROUPS
ARE VERY SUCCESSFUL AND ACTUALLY
CAME UP WITH MORE THAN NINETY
ACTIONS THAT CAN BE TAKEN TO
TRANSFORM THE VALLEY FROM
UNSUSTAINABLE TO SUSTAINABLE
WATER RESOURCES MANAGEMENT AND-
SO WHAT IS NEXT FOR CAP OR WHAT
WILL YOU SEE IN THE FUTURE FOR
HIM CAT IS THAT IN MID JANUARY
WE'RE GOING TO FINALIZE THE CAP
STAYS ONE ACTION REPORT AND HOT
HOUSE AND A LOT MORE DETAILED IN
MY PRESENTATION TODAY. WHAT THE
PROBLEM STATEMENT IS AS WELL AS
THE LIST OF NINETY SOLUTION
SEPARATED INTO EACH OF THE
CATEGORIES N. FEB JANUARY OR
FEBRUARY WE WILL CONDUCT MORE
OUTREACH EFFORT TO EDUCATE
EVERYONE ABOUT THIS EFFORT AND
HOW THEY CAN PARTICIPATE IN WHAT
IS THE PLAN FOR PHASE. TWO IN
MARCH WILL LAND SPACE TO WHICH
INCLUDES SOME IMPLEMENTATIONS OF
SOME PROJECTS AND THEN IN
SEPTEMBER COMPLETING A DETAILED
PROGRAM. FOR DEMAND REDUCTION
AND ADDITIONAL- SURFACE WATER
SUPPLY AND HOPEFULLY BY
SEPTEMBER OF TWENTY THREE
COMPLETE A COMPREHENSIVE
DETAILED SUSTAINABLE ACTION PLAN. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND I
HOPE IT WAS INFORMATIVE ANSWERED
SOME OF YOUR QUESTIONS AND I
WILL PASS IT ON TO THE NEXT
SPEAKER AND WE'LL TAKE YOUR
QUESTIONS- LATER ON IN THE
SESSION. THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH FLORA AND UP
NEXT WE HAVE TO WAIT A WHILE SIR
A DOCTOR DOING ALL SIR I
APOLOGIZE CHIEF SCIENTIST OF THE
EARTH SCIENCE AND TECHNOLOGY AS
A DIRECTOR AT NASA'S JET
PROPULSION LABORATORY. PLEASE R.
AND I'M SORRY IF I MISPRONOUNCE
YOUR LAST NAME BUT PLEASE FEEL
FREE TO BEGIN WHEN YOU ARE READY. AS I LOOK. IT LOOKS GREAT OKAY
. SO IT'S A PLEASURE THANK YOU
MADAM CO CHAIR AND SENATOR
BLENDERS FOR POSTING THIS
SESSION AND INVITING A GPO
PARTICIPATION BETWEEN MYSELF AND
MARC SIMARD WILL GO NEXT. WE'RE
GONNA TRYING CONVEY THE SORTS OF
THINGS THE GPL DOES ON BEHALF OF
THE NATION AND THE CALIFORNIAN
THE- YOUNGER DUTERTE'S THAT
WE'VE TAKEN ON RELATIVE TO
TRYING TO DO MORE ON BEHALF OF
THE STATE AND THAT KIND OF
CONCERNS HAVE BEEN EXPRESSED SO
NICELY BY OUR PREVIOUS SPEAKERS.
THIS COVER SLIDE SHOWS ACTUALLY
A PIECE OF ART MUSEUM THAT
HIGHLIGHTS ON THE RIGHT YOU KNOW
MUCH OF WHAT YOU'VE HEARD JPL
DOES GOES TO MARS AND OTHER
PLANETS IN THE SOLAR SYSTEM.
WITH GREAT SUCCESS- BUT WE ALSO
SPEND A LOT OF TIME AND EFFORT
TO DETAIL ON- CENTER SCIENCE
CENTERS APPLICATIONS AND WE
WOULD LOVE TO HOST ANY AND ALL
OF YOU AT JPL SOMETIME- WHEN
THINGS GET BACK TO NORMAL AND I
HOPE YOU'LL TAKE. TAKE ME UP ON
THAT OFFER IN THE MEANTIME OUR
PUBLIC. RELATIONS. FOLKS HAVE
CREATED A REALLY NICE. VIRTUAL
TOUR AND THE THAT RITUAL TO.
THERE IN THAT YELLOW. AND
ENCOURAGE YOU TO TAKE A LOOK AT
YOUR HOUSE. SO FOR THOSE OF YOU
THAT AREN'T NECESSARILY FAMILIAR
WITH JPL JPL AS ONE OF TEN NASA
CENTERS. IT'S OWNED BY NASA AND
MANAGED BY CAL TECH. IT'S KNOWN
AS A FEDERALLY FUNDED RESEARCH
AND DEVELOPMENT CENTER SO- MMHM
OUR MAIN MANDATE IS A ROBOTIC
EXPLORATION SPACE AND THAT ALSO
APPLIES TO- EARTH OBSERVATIONS
AND TRYING TO HELP. WITH THE
NATION'S CHALLENGES RISK
RESPECT- SCIENCE AND
APPLICATIONS RESEARCHERS THINGS
HAVE BEEN DISCUSSED TODAY. THERE
ARE ABOUT SIX THOUSAND EMPLOYEES
OBJECT ON ANY GIVEN TIME AND ARE
THE BUSINESS SPACE IS ABOUT TWO
AND A HALF. BILLION DOLLARS AND
THAT'S A LABORATORY SITTING
THERE- THANKS TO THE SAN GABRIEL
MOUNTAINS. IN THE NORTHEAST PART
OF PASADENA. SO AS I SAID WE DO
A LOT ON BEHALF OF LOOKING A
THE EARTH- WE ACTUALLY.
SUPPLYING MASTER WITH ABOUT HALF
OF THE SATELLITES THAT ARE USED
TO OBSERVE THE PLANET- THE OTHER
HALF. MOSTLY PROVIDED BY GODDARD
SPACE FLIGHT INSTITUTE IN
MARYLAND. AND THIS IS JUST A FEW
OF THE SNAPSHOTS OF OUR FIRST
DOING SATELLITES AND QUANTITIES
THAT ARE RELEVANT TO THE
DISCUSSION TODAY. I'M GONNA JUST
START IN THE UPPER LEFT AND GO
TO THE RIGHT- THERE ARE A FEW
REALLY RELEVANT TO THE DROP
CONSIDERATIONS AND OUR CLIMATE
CHANGE THAT'S JUST SOME OF THE-
YOU KNOW FORCING. FUNCTION THAT
THAT IS IN. ADDING TO THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
UNDERTAKE SO IN THE UPPER LEFT
IS A GLOBAL PICTURE OF. SURFACE
AIR TEMPERATURE. WHICH WE KNOW
HAS BEEN RISING OVER TIME-
CARBON DIOXIDE IS ONE. THAT WE
NOW HAVE A VERY NICE
OBSERVATIONS OF THE GLOBAL
BURDEN OF CARBON DIOXIDE IN THEATMOSPHERE AND HOW IT CHANGES.
HOW IT'S CHANGING WITH TIME. AND
WE ALL KNOW IS INCREASING WITH
TIME BUT WE'RE ACTUALLY GETTING
TO THE POINT WHERE FROM SPACE.
WE CAN START TO SEEM FAIRLY
SMALL EMISSION SOURCES. WITHIN
THE STATE WITHIN A CITY. WELL
ALMOST NARROWING DOWN TO LARGE
FARMS AND FACTORIES TO TRY AND
UNDERSTAND THAT'S A MISSION
THAT'S- WE ACTUALLY. PROTOTYPE
THROUGH AIRCRAFT- THROUGH
METHANE SURVEYS AND SO FORTH
WITHIN THE STATE THAT WAS VERY
SUCCESSFUL. AND THAT ACTUALLY
HELPED DEVELOP INTO A PUBLIC
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP TO PUT.
SIMILAR INSTRUMENTS LIKE THAT
INTO SPACE IN ABOUT A YEAR OR
TWO AND TO HELP MONITOR THE
EMISSION SOURCES OUT. OF METHANE
IN THAT CASE. CARBON MONOXIDE IS
ANOTHER POLLUTANT THAT WE KEEP
TRACK OF SOME SPACE- THE ONE IN
THE UPPER RIGHT THERE IS THE
GRAVITY FIELD AND THAT'S GOING
TO COME UP IN A NUMBER OF TIMES
BECAUSE- IT'S A REALLY USEFUL
MEASURE TO TRACK WATER. AS IT
MOVES ACROSS THE PLANET- FROM
MELTING ICE SHEETS TO. GROUND
WATER AND SO FORTH AND YOU'RE
GOING TO SEE MORE OF THAT IN IN
IN THE COMING SLIDES AND THEN
MARCH PRESENTATION AS WELL. NOW
MOVING DOWN TO THE LOWER LEFT WE
KNOW ONE OF THE OUTCOMES OF
CLIMATE CHANGE'S RISING SEA
LEVELS. NASA WITH ITS
INTERNATIONAL PARTNERS FROM
FRANCE AND THE EUROPEAN. SPACE
AGENCY HAS DEVELOPED A LONG
RECORD OF SPACE BASED SEA LEVEL
MEASUREMENTS THAT HELP US TRACK
LOCAL. SEA LEVEL RISE. ANOTHER
CALL REALLY RELEVANT TO THE DISK
. TODAY AS STORM. WITH BURTON
SUGGESTS. INSTRUMENTS IN SPACE
MONITOR SOIL MOISTURE AND HOW IT
CHANGES IN RESPONSE TO RAINFALL
OR DROUGHT CONDITIONS. OZONE IS
INTERESTING IN THE SENSE THAT-
FOR. DECADES AGO WE HELP.
INSTRUMENTS IN SPACE THAT HELPED
US UNDERSTAND WHY THE OZONE
HOLE. WAS CREATED. AND THE
REASON I BRING IT UP HERE IS
BECAUSE YOU KNOW THERE WAS A
MONTREAL PROTOCOL SOMETHING PUT
IN PLACE AND THAT'S
INTERNATIONAL SETTING. TO TRY
AND REDUCE THE CHEMICALS THAT
WERE BEING AMENDED TO. TO
PRODUCE AT ALL AND NOW THESE
INSTRUMENTS ARE BEING USED TO
MONITOR THE RECOVERY. AND SO IN
THE SAME WAY AT SOME POINT WE'LL
WE'LL KEEP TRACKING. WILL KEEP
TRACK. OF CARBON WILL PLAY IN
THE SAME WAY TO HOPEFULLY. YOU
DON'T FOLLOW THE SORT OF
MITIGATION- AND REGULATION
THINGS THAT CALIFORNIA EXACTLY
LEADING THE WAY IN- AND THEN
FINALLY THERE'S A- WATER RATE
REMAINS THERE ON THE RIGHT WHICH
IS. IMPORTANT BECAUSE THIS WAS A
GREENHOUSE GAS ACTUALLY ALONG
WITH CARBON DIOXIDE. BUT AS YOU
KNOW IT'S ALSO THE FUEL FOR MANY
OF THE STORMS AND RAINFALL. THAT
WE SEE SO WELL. AND BUSTER WERE
POURED INTO. OUR ECONOMY AND SO
FORTH. AND SO I'M I'M ALSO HIT
ON THAT FACT THAT ALL OF NASA'S
. IS OF TO THE- THE BROADEST
PART PUBLIC INTERNATIONAL- FOR
MORE AND IT IS AVAILABLE YOU
KNOW ALL OF THAT FOR SCIENTIFIC
PURPOSES AND APPLIED SCIENCES
PURPOSES. BUT THERE ARE MANY
WAYS OF GETTING AT IT FROM A
MORE LATE PERSPECTIVE. I
HIGHLIGHT THE WEBSITE UP THERE
AT THE TOP CLIMATE DOT NASA DOT
GO WHICH IS A NICE. ENTRY POINTS
TO BOTH LEARNED ABOUT CLIMATE
CHANGE ALSO GET. CERTAIN KINDS
OF DATA THAT I JUST SHOWED YOU
IN A FORMAT THAT'S RELEVANT TO
LOOKING. AT FROM A CLIMATE
PERSPECTIVE. ON THAT LAST FIGURE
IS THAT WEBSITE IS SEXY ON AWARD
WINNING. AWARD WINNING WEBSITE
FOR MANY MANY YEARS. ARE YOU
MIGHT HAVE HEARD OF THE WEBBY
AWARDS IT'S ACTUALLY GARNERED
THREE OR FOUR WHEN THE AWARDS-
THAT'S A THAT'S A FANTASTIC
SITE. AND AT THE BOTTOM WITH
THOSE RED ARROWS YOU CAN SEE
THAT IT IT HAS. A SET OF CLIMATE
VITAL SIGNS FIRST FIND OUT VITAL
SIGNS FROM. WHAT'S WHAT'S
HAPPENING WITH THE GLOBAL CARBON
DIOXIDE BURDEN. THE GLOBAL
SURFACE TEMPERATURE. HOW WAS THE
SEA ICE EXTENT CHANGING IN HIGH
LATITUDES. WHAT'S HAPPENING THE
ICE SHEETS IN THERE MOSTLY
BENCH. MELTING AND IN PREVIOUS
DECADE OR SO AND THEN SO MUCH
THE C. LEVEL RISE. AND THEN THE
FIGURE ON THE RIGHT IS TO
HIGHLIGHT. THAT I DIDN'T GIVEN
TIME YOU CAN SEE ACTUAL. THE
LAST COUPLE DAYS OF ALMOST ANY
OF THOSE PARAMETERS I JUST
SHOWED YOU ON THAT PREVIOUS
PAGE. IT'S A- IT'S AN
APPLICATION CALLED EYES ON EARTH
YOU CAN LOOK AT IT FROM YOUR-
COMPUTER LAPTOP OR YOU CAN GET
IT ON YOUR PHONE. AND YOU COULD
LOOK ATFOR EXAMPLE THAT ONE
IMAGE THERE SHOWS ALL THOSE
DIFFERENT SATELLITES ORBITING
THE EARTH. YOU CAN PICK ONE N.
OR OR PARAMETERS LIKE
TEMPERATURE SEA LEVEL. CARBON
DIOXIDE AND THEN SEE IT
DISPLAYED AS YOU SEE THERE ON
THAT COLORFUL IMAGE TO THE
RIGHT. AND THAT COULD BE VERY
RECENT RIGHT UP TO A GIVEN DATE
LIKE AS OF YESTERDAY OR THIS
WEEK. SO THERE'S THAT'S THE
ENTRY POINT OF MAYBE FINDING.
MORE DATA. IF YOU WANT TO SEE
GLOBAL GLOBAL VIEWS- EARTH DAY
FROM NASA. AND THIS IS JUST IN
THE OF WALK THROUGH IT A LITTLE
BIT SO BUT WERE WE'RE ALL WE
BUSY WORKING ON THE NEXT
MEASUREMENTS THAT MIGHT GIVE US
GUIDANCE ON BOTH THE SCIENCE AND
WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH THIS
RESPECT THE EARTH WHICH HAS SOME
FIDELITY AND SING DOWN AT A
LEVEL OF CALIFORNIA AND REGIONS
WITHIN CALIFORNIA EVEN CITIES-
STARTING ON THE LOWER MIDDLE.
THAT'S OKAY OUR NEXT LINE SHE'S
GONNA LUNCHEON IN TWO WEEKS-
FROM KENNEDY SPACE CENTER IS
ACTUALLY UP A SET OF SENSORS
THAT HAVE BEEN SUPPORTED BY THE
AIR FORCE IN THIS CASE IT'S
GOING TO GO UP TO THE
INTERNATIONAL SPACE STATION AND
IT WILL HELP US UNDERSTAND AND
DO BETTER WITH MARINE WEATHER
AND EXTREME EXTREME WEATHER
THERE- MOVING TO THE LEFT IS A
SMALL INSTRUMENT THAT'S ALSO
GOING TO BE PLACED ON THE SPACE
STATION. AND IT'S DESIGNED TO
UNDERSTAND DUST SOURCES AROUND
THE PLANET- MAINLY DUST CAN
INFLUENCE ACTUALLY THE
DEVELOPMENTS LAOS AND IT CAN
ALSO REFLECT SUNLIGHT BACK TO
SPACE IT CAN ALSO BE AN ON AIR
QUALITY SOURCE AMERICAN WALLY
HAZARDS. SO THAT'S WHAT THAT
MACHINE JUST FOR. THAT WAS NEXT
BE ABLE ON THE OR WHAT WE REFER
TO AS FLAGSHIP MISSIONS THEY'RE
VERY BIG MISSIONS THEY HAVE
INTERNATIONAL PARTNERS I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THAT. MUCH OF WHAT WE
DO AND THE SUCCESS OF NASA. IN
SOMEBODY'S MISSIONS MANAGERS ON
REALLY SUCCESSFUL RELATIONSHIPS
WITH INTERNATIONAL PARTNERS IN
THE CASE OF THAT- ITEM CALLED
SUAT WHICH STANDS FOR SURFACE
WATER AND OCEAN TOPOGRAPHY. IT'S
A LONG STANDING PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE FRENCH SPACE AGENCY AND IT'S
DESIGNED. TO ACTUALLY MEASURE
FINE SCALE FEATURES OF THE OCEAN
SURFACE SITES. BUT MORE
PARTICULARLY IT MAKES A HUGE
ADVANCE RELATIVE TO PAST
MISSIONS LIKE THIS. BECAUSE IT'S
GOT FINE ENOUGH SKILLS TO
MONITOR LAKE LEVELS AND RIVER
LEVELS AND SO AROUND THE GLOBE
WE CAN WE CAN GET REALLY S.
FIRST MAJOR OF THE GLOBAL AMOUNT
OF. WATER AND MEASURE RIVER.
RIVER BOUND ELEVATIONS AND
MONITOR SLIDES- IT STARTING IN
TWENTY TWENTY TWO WHEN IT'S
SLATED TO LAUNCH IT SO WE'RE
REALLY LOOKING FORWARD TO THAT
SPOT MISSION. CRITICAL BECAUSE
IT'S GOING TO GET INSIGHTS INTO. LAKES AND RIVERS THAT WE JUST
HAVEN'T HAD BEFORE. THAT NICER
MISSION WITH THAT BIG AND- IS
GOING TO BE LAUNCHED IN TWENTY
TWENTY THREE IT'S VIBRATION WITH
THE INDIAN SPACE AGENCY- IT HAS
A LOT OF APPLICABILITY AND
MARK'S GONNA TALK. QUITE A BIT
ABOUT WHAT A MISSION LIKE THIS
CAN DO IN TERMS OF- I THINK FROM
WHAT. I MEAN THIS NATIONAL HELP
WITH ALL KINDS OF HAZARDS AND
THAT'S WHAT'S MARKED AND TALK
ABOUT IT ALSO HELP US MONITOR
THE ICE SHEETS AND KEEP TRACK OF
THE AMOUNT OF BIOMASS- WHICH IS
RELEVANT TO YOU KNOW.
UNDERSTANDING THE CARBON EMITTED
AND THE SINK. OF CARBON IN IN
THE LAND SURFACE SO MARKLE HIT
ON THAT MORE WHEN IT COMES TO
THE HAZARDS LIKE SUBSTANCE AND
THOSE CONDITIONS RELATED TO
GREAT DROUGHT AND GROUNDWATER
EXTRACTION. MAYA THE MISSION
THERE IS RELATED IS. IS A REALLY
UNIQUE MISSION CALIFORNIA PLAYS
A REALLY CRITICAL ROLE IN THIS-
MY AS A MISSION TO STUDY. ERA
SOULS IN THE ATMOSPHERE AND
THEIR IMPACT ON AIR QUALITY AND
THE AND THEN TURN ON PUBLIC
HEALTH. THE MISSION TEAM IS
COMPOSED OF BOTH. AIR QUALITY
SCIENCES AND PUBLIC HEALTH.
SCIENCES AND IT'S GOING TO. IT'S
DESIGNED TO STUDY THE AIR
QUALITY ON BIRTH OUTCOMES. AND
CALIFORNIA ACTUALLY HAS A NUMBER
OF STATIONS THAT WILL PLAY A
ROLE IN HELPING HELPING THOSE
TEAMS TAKE TAKE ON THAT SEVEN.
OTHERS ANOTHER MISSION THAT'S A
VERY KIND OF HIGH AND VERY
DETAILED SCIENCE QUESTION
RELATED TO HIGH LATITUDES OF
NIGHT SHOOTS AND CLIMATE CHANGE
AND THEN THAT LAST ONE. CURRENT
CONCERNING SEA LEVEL IS JUST THE
LAST OR THE MOST RECENT ADDITION
TO THAT LONG STANDING LINE AT
SEA LEVEL MISSIONS TO HELP US
MONITOR HOUSE THE LEVEL IS
CHANGING AROUND THE GLOBE AND
THAT'S- AGAIN THAT IT'S PART OF
A VERY IMPORTANT PARTNERSHIP
WITH. FRIGID SPACE AGENCY AND
THE EUROPEAN SPACE AGENCY'S
THAT'S WHAT'S KEEPING. US BUSY A
LOT AT JPL- IN COULD JUST ON
THIS IS A DIAGRAM THAT SHOWS. A
SATELLITE OBSERVATION I MENTION
THAT GRAVITY MISSION- WE REFER
TO IT AS GRACE AND THEN THE
FOLLOWING GRACE FOLLOW ON. AND
IT HELPS US MEASURE AND KEEP
TRACK OF THE AMOUNT OF WATER ON
WHITE. AND SO IT IT ADDS UP. IT
IS ABLE TO ADD TOGETHER ALL THE
GRAMMAR GROUNDWATER SURFACE
WATER AND SNOW PACK AND JUST
GIVE HIM AN OVERALL ASSESSMENT-
WHAT THE LANDSCAPE HAS IN TERMS
OF. WATER STORAGE AND THIS IS
THE TIME SERIES SINCE THE FIRST.
LAUNCH OF THE FIRST RACE MISSION
STARTING IN TWO THOUSAND TWO AND
BLUE COLORS ARE SHOWING PERIODS
WHERE THE WATER. THE WATER IS
SORT OF EXTRA ABOVE NORMAL
RELATIVE TO THAT TIME PERIOD.
AND THE RED IS SHOWING SORT OF
OUR DROUGHT TEN FOLLOWING WHAT-
NICELY AS CINDY AND RACHEL
PROVIDED SOME BACKGROUND YOU CAN
SEE WE JUST WENT THROUGH THE
TWENTY FIFTEEN TWENTY SIXTEEN
GROUND EVERYTHING TURNED RED.
AND NOW WE'RE GOING TO LAND ON A
PRETTY. SIGNIFICANT READ PERIOD
WHICH IS A YOU KNOW A VERY
STRONG DROP AND THE NUMBERS
THERE IT'S FAIR IN TERMS OF
MILLIMETERS SO OVER THIS LARGE
LANDSCAPE. YOU KNOW THESE
REGIONS ARE JUST DEFICIENT IN
THE AMOUNT OF WATER THROUGH
THOSE LAYERS UP GROUNDWATER
SURFACE WATER AND STILL BACKED
BY THE AMOUNT OF ABOUT A- THIRD
OF A METER. AND SO MOVING ON ON
THE NEXT SLIDE THIS IS A MORE OF
A CLOSED DOOR GETTING MORE
FOCUSED ON WHAT WE DO RELATIVES
ARE WATER RELATED RESOURCES
OBSERVATIONS THAT MAY THE BULLS
HELP US CARRY OUT SCIENCE AND
UNDERSTAND CLIMATE CHANGE AND
OTHER THINGS THAT AFFECT
CALIFORNIA IN TERMS OF WEATHER
AND OTHER HAZARDS BUT IT ALSO
PROVIDES IN MANY CASES
INFORMATION TO HELP US START TO
PROVIDE DECISION SUPPORT FOR
FOLKS LIKE YOU IN THIS ROOM-
JUST AND A LOT OF NEPHEW WITH
THESE. ARE PART AND PARCEL OF
OPPORTUNITIES THAT WE'VE HAD
WITH CALIFORNIA TO ACTUALLY
PROVIDE COLLABORATION AND
PROVIDE DATA FOR SOME CASES OF
SERVING UP TO NEW YORK YOUR
DECISION MAKING AGENCIES
STARTING AT THE UPPER LEFT. WE
ACTUALLY STUDY- EXTREME STORMS
AND RAIN FALLING ANOTHER
ATMOSPHERIC RIVERS ARE A BIG
PART OF THAT THAT IMPACT THE
WEST COAST. AND WE- STUDY THOSE
RIVERS AND HOW THEY'D CHANGE
WITH TIME CLIMATE CHANGE RELATED
THINGS AND ALSO YOU MENTIONED
BEFORE DELIVERY ARE AND THEIR
FOCUS ON. FORECASTING AND TRYING
TO DO THE MOST ACTUALLY I'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH JEAN JONES FOR
ABOUT FIVE YEARS AND TRYING TO
IMPROVE. SUB SEASONAL AND
SEASONAL FORECASTING EFFORTS ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA DECISION
MAKING IT SIR REALLY OUR
PROBLEM- THERE IN THE MIDDLE IS
SIERRA SNOWPACK AND WE HAVE
MEASURES OF- BILLY BEANE. YES HI
FIDELITY MEASURES OF SNOW BACK
YOU KNOW THEY GO OUT BUT HOLD.
ON A FEW PLACES AND TRYING TO
ASCERTAIN WHAT THE TOTAL SNOW
PACK IS OVER A PLACE LIKE THIS-
TRYING TO REMEMBER THE NAMES
FOLLOWING BASIN- AND WITH SO
THEY WOULD NORMALLY DO THAT WE
ARE WE NORMALLY ASSESS THE
AMOUNT OF SNOW IN A REGION LIKE
THAT THIS BIG WATERSHED BASIN.
USING UP ALL AND YOU KNOW DOZENS
OF POINTS THROUGH. REMOTE
SENSING- BASED ON A ON AN ON AN
AIRCRAFT WE CAN GET IN THE
SYSTEM AND OF THE ENTIRE
WATERSHED AND THE AMOUNT OF SNOW
IN THAT WATER SHOULD PRETTY
PRETTY EFFECTIVELY AND- NASA IS
WORKING HARD ON THE NEXT
SOLICITATION TO TRY AND DEVELOP
A SPACEBORNE MEASUREMENTS. THAT
WOULD WORK AS EFFECTIVELY
INSTANCE. I'M ON THE RIGHT IS
THIS CENTRAL GROUND. SHE'S FINE
I SHOWED YOU THAT IN THE LAST
ANIMATION SO I WILL GO OVER THAT
DETAIL. THAT BIG RADAR MISSION
THAT I MENTIONED- NICE EITHER
WHICH IS THE CALIBRATION WITH
THE INDIANS THERE ARE A FEW-
MEASUREMENTS LIKE THAT IN SPACE
AND THAT ARE ALSO FLOWN ON
AIRCRAFT. THE MAP ON THE LOWER
LEFT IS USING DATA LIKE THAT FOR
HAZARD RESPONSE IN THIS CASE
IT'S DETECTING WHERE THE SERVICE
IS FLOODED IN THOSE REGIONS- AND
THERE'S A RESPONSE PRODUCTS.
PRODUCED BY SOMETHING WE CALL
ARIA BUT USED BY CALIFORNIA AND
OTHER NASH STATE AGENCIES IN THE
COUNTRY IN THE NATION TO HELP-
INFORMS LIKE RESPONSE ALL THE
WAY FROM NOT ONLY FLIGHTS THAT
FLOODS EARTHQUAKES. FIRES. AND
SO FORTUNATELY IS IN OTHER PARTS
OF THE WORLD. IN THE BOTTOM WE
HAVE A SATELLITE- A SENSOR ON
THE INTERNATIONAL SPACE STATION
THAT IS USED TO MEASURE- PLANT
WATER USE IT. IN SS IS BASED ON
HOW WARM AND HOT WITH THE PLANTS
ARE JUST JUST HOW MUCH WATER IT
NEEDS AND HOW MUCH STRESS IS
UNDERTAKING AND YOU CAN SEE.
THAT IT HAS A FIDELITY TO ALMOST
SEE FARM LEVEL FARM SIZE LAW.
AND UNDERSTAND HOW MUCH WATER IS
BEING USED FROM A FARMING
PERSPECTIVE WE REFER TO THAT AS
A BACKWARD TRANSPIRATION IF
YOU'VE HEARD THAT TERM. FINALLY
ON THE RIGHT. IS SOMETHING
REFERRED TO AS BROWN SUBSTANCE
YOU MIGHT KNOW THAT WHEN YOU
EXTRACT GROUNDWATER AND YOU
EXTRACT ENOUGH OF IT THE GROUND
CAN ACTUALLY SING. AND THAT'S A
MEASURE OF SOMEONE THAT SINKING
IN MARK'S GONNA TALK ABOUT. THAT
MUCH MORE DETAIL IN THE STOCK.
SO THIS LAST TIME IT IS JUST A
HIGHLIGHT THAT- FROM SERVING
NASCENT AND THAT'S- DETAILS
PRIMARY MISSION ABOUT 90% OF OUR
WORK IS DIRECTLY TO DO THAT
NASSAR RELATED WORK WHETHER IT'S
PLANETARY OR SCIENCE THE SORT OF
THING I'M SHOWING YOU HERE WITH
THE SATELLITES- ABOUT 10% OF OUR
WORK IS WITH NON ASSET AGENCIES
INCLUDING. CALIFORNIA WE'VE HAD
SOME VERY EFFECTIVE
COLLABORATIONS WITH CALIFORNIA.
ON THE LEFT THERE IN THE PAST
AND CURRENT. ACTIVITIES THAT
HAVE BEEN. REALLY SUCCESSFUL I
THINK TO A GREAT DEGREE WITH
CALIFORNIA AGENCIES YOU SEE
THERE ON THE RIGHT THERE'S THAT
REGIONAL METHANE SURVEY THAT I
MENTIONED EARLIER- THE
FORECASTING THAT I ALSO MENTION
IN RELATION TO ATMOSPHERIC
RIVERS IN SEASONAL DROUGHTS.
CENTRAL VALLEY SUBSTANCES ON AS
A PROJECT THAT WAS CONNECTED
WITH. WHEN THE WATER RESOURCES
THE AIR QUALITY MONITORING AND
THAT MY AMBITION I TALKED ABOUT
THAT'S RELATED TO PUBLIC HEALTH
OUTCOMES ZERO WATER SNOW PACK
AND RELATED TO THAT- SUBSTANCES
LEVY INTEGRITY MONITORING WHICH
MARK IS GOING TO COVER IN MORE
DETAIL AND THAT'S THAT THINKS
THAT THIS IS SUCH AN IMPORTANT
TOPIC THAT SORT OF THING THAT WE
TALKED ABOUT TODAY THAN ABOUT
FIVE YEARS AGO THEY STIRRED UP
BY. NASA WESTERN WATER
APPLICATIONS OFFICE. TO TRY AND
INFUSE NASA DATING CAPABILITIES
MORSE MORE- CHANCE OF LATE INTO
INTO WESTERN WATER STAKEHOLDERS
AND DECISION MAKERS HANSON SO
THAT'S HOW'S THE GPL AND THERE'S
ALWAYS ACTIVITY IN RELATION TO
THAT KIND OF A AN APPLIED
SCIENCE BASIS AND TRYING TO
BRING DATA. TO DECISION MAKING
SO WE HAVE THESE LONG STANDING
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THESE
AGENCIES ON THE RIGHT AND I JUST
ALSO WANT TO MENTION THAT SOME
OF THIS IS SUCCESSFUL ENOUGH AND
PEOPLE ARE OPTIMISTIC ABOUT IT
GOING FORWARD AT JPL AND
CALIFORNIA SIGNED A MEMO YOU
ABOUT A YEAR AND A HALF AGO-
SPECIFICALLY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY. CAL
EPA AND CALIFORNIA FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE AND SO WE'RE TRYING
TO BUILD ON THE SUCCESSES AND
MOVED IN THE FUTURE AND HELP
WITH THE KIND OF PROBLEMS WITH
FOR TODAY AND WITH THAT I'M.
GONNA MOVE. ON MARK DO YOU WANT
TO SHOW YOU SLIDES ARE YOU WANT
ME TO- I WILL DO IT. OKAY ALL
AND ALL AT THIS POINT I'LL GO
AHEADAND INTRODUCE- MARK
SIMMERED DUCK DOCTOR MARK
SIMMERED PRINCIPAL SCIENTIST
ALSO FROM THE NASA JET
PROPULSION LABORATORY. WELCOME
MARK. THANK YOU MY FIRST SLIDE
HERE- WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
WITH YOU- AND- SO I WILL MAYBE
GO INTO A LITTLE BIT MORE
DETAILS ON OUR WAY TO DOING WHAT
IS FOR MY COLLEAGUE JUST THE- I
WENT TO- SOAK. IN IN ADDITION TO
ALL THAT NOW THEY CAN DO FROM
SPACE WE CAN ALSO DO THINGS-
FROM THE AIR MOST OF THE
SATELLITES AND INSTRUMENTS THAT
YOU SEE. THAT WILL BE LAUNCHED
TO SPACE IN THE NEXT FEW YEARS
HAVE BEEN DEVELOPED ON THE
AIRCRAFT AS WELL AS FOR TESTING
AND ARE ALSO AVAILABLE FOR
STUDYING THE LANDSCAPES AND THE
WATER. SO SO THE TITLE YOU'RE
TALK IS THE FOLLOWING TO WATER
SO I'M GOING TO TALK TO YOU
ABOUT THE RESERVATIONS OF. THE
MISSISSIPPI RIVER DELTA AND-
CENTRAL BODY SO I'M A PRINCIPAL
SCIENTIST ALSO LEAD DOES NOT
EXIST DELTA X. THE MISSION WHICH
IS ACTUALLY IN. A CAMPAIGN WITH
AIRCRAFTS. IN THE MISSISSIPPI
RIVER DELTA. SO A HERE I'M
SHOWING YO THE PART OF THE
MISSISSIPPI RIVER DELTA-
WEEKENDS FOLLOW. THE LAND LOST
USING TIME SERIES OF SATELLITES.
THE NEW LET ME MENTION HERE
SHOWS LOSS OF LAND IN RED SINCE
NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT. SO YOU
CAN SEE THAT SOME PARTS OF THE
DELTA OR LOSING LAND WHILE
OTHERS ARE GAINING LAND THAT SO
THOSE ARE THE ONES IN THE WEST
THE GREEN PARK. SO IF YOU LOOK
AT THE LOSS OF LAND IN THIS
AREA. NO COASTAL LOUISIANA. IT'S
A QUIVER LAND TO LOSING THAT.
ONE FOOTBALL FIELD EVERY SINGLE
HOUR SO THERE'S A LOT OF LAND
THAT IS BEING LOST IN THAT
REGION AND THIS IS CERTAINLY
SOMETHING YOU DON'T WANT TO
HAPPEN IN THE SACRAMENTO SAN
JOAQUIN. DELTA BUT- IN THE
INTEREST OF- NOW UNDERSTANDING
THE HOLLIES DEALT US CAN'T KEEP
UP WITH SEA LEVEL RISE- I'M
GOING TO JUST SHOW YOU THIS
LITTLE ANIMATION HERE SO THERE
ARE TWO PERSON SEES BY WHICH
DEALT US CAN KEEP UP WITH THE
SEA LEVEL RISE SO WE'RE TALKING
HERE ABOUT WHAT WE NEED TO
DELTAS RIGHT THAT NOT TALKING
ABOUT THE BAD THAT. SOMEONE CAME
BY THE END OF CENTRAL CALIFORNIA
SO THERE ARE TWO PROCESSES BY
WHICH THE KEEP UP WITH C. LEVEL
RISE THE FIRST ONE IS THROUGH A
SENTIMENT THAT THE POSITION SO
THE REVERSE COME DOWN FROM THE
WATERSHED. AND THE DEPOSIT
SENTIMENTS AT ITS MACH THIS
BUILDS SOIL AND THAT WE CAN KEEP
UP WITH SEA LEVEL RISE BUT ON
THIS MOST OF THE TIME IS NOT
SUFFICIENT. SOME OF THE OTHER A
PROCESS BY WHICH YOU CAN GAIN
LAND ELEVATION TO KEEP UP WITH
SEA LEVEL RISE IS THROUGH THE
PLANT AND PRODUCTION SO THE
PLANTS OF COURSE. GREW THESE
ROOTS IN THE GROUND- THE- THE
SENATE SIDE THERE IN THE FALL
THEY DIE AND ALL THIS MATERIAL
ACCUMULATES ON THE GROUND AND
ALSO CONTRIBUTES TO ELEVATING
THE SOUL AND KEEP UP WITH SEA
LEVEL RISE SO THESE ARE THE TWO
PROCESSES BY WHICH A NATURAL.
ADULT BAG SYSTEM. CAN SURVIVE TO
ARISE. SO OKAY THE MISSISSIPPI
RIVER DELTA OF COURSE HAS A LOT
OF WATER- SO THIS MAP HERE-
WEST'S- NOW GENERATED USING THE
GRACE THAT A SYSTEM WHICH IS THE
ONE THAT THE- DOING IT
INTRODUCED EARLIER SO. IT
BASICALLY MEASURES. THE MASS THE
WEIGHT OF THE WATER AROUND THE
PLANET AND YOU CAN SEE HERE IN
BLUE THE MISSISSIPPI RIVER DELTA
AND ITS WATERSHED IS FULL OF
WATER WHICH IS KIND OF.
CONTRASTING TO WHAT WE FIND OF
COURSE IN CALIFORNIA WHERE WE
ARE LOSING WATER RIGHT BUT THE
SIMILARITY IN THESE TWO SYSTEMS
IS THE NEED. FOR THE MANAGEMENT
OF THE WATER RESOURCES RIGHT SO
WE CAN OBSERVE ALL OF THIS STUFF
FROM SPACE AND HEAR WHAT I'M
DISCUSSING OR INTRODUCING TO YOU
ARE WAYS. TO MAKE INFORMED
DECISIONS THAT. WITH THE USE OF
SATELLITE AS WELL AS YOU WERE
BORN OR AIRCRAFT THE. REMOTE
SENSING TECHNOLOGIES. SO IT IT
ALSO SHOWED THIS WAS IN A MUCH
SMALLER IMAGE BUT HERE WE ARE
SHOWING THE LOSS OF WATER IN THE
AREAS OF ABOUT TWELVE YEARS. SO
THE GREEN- GOING TO THE RED
INDICATES THE LOSS OF WATER SO
AGAIN THIS IS FROM THE GRACE
MISSION. SO THE AMOUNT OF WATER
THAT IS SHOWN HERE AND THAT IS
BEING LOST THROUGH THE YEARS. IS
DETECTED FROM THE WEIGHT OF THAT
WATER SO IT'S A DIFFERENCE IN
GRAVITY. THAT WE'RE MEASURING
FROM SPACE SO WE CAN DO THIS FOR
ALMOST THE ENTIRE PLANET AND
THIS IS THAT YOU WERE SHOWING
ONLY CALIFORNIA WHICH IS LOSING
A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF WATER.
AS WE'VE BEEN DISCUSSING AND
DISSECTING OR. SO I THINK MY
POSITION IS SLIGHTLY HEAVY SO-
IT TAKES AWHILE FOR ME TO SWITCH
THE SIDES- SO. DO YOU KNOW WHEN
YOU LOSE WATER THERE ARE
CONSEQUENCES THERE ARE A- IT HAS
IMPACTS ON THE LAND AND- WE CAN
OBSERVE THAT FROM SPACE AND IT
WAS ALSO. A NEW DID BY- DOING
WANT TO SERVE BUT ALSO- YOU'RE
BIASED CINDY MESSER. SO HERE IS
A MAP OF THE LARGE FIGURE THAT
YOU SEE HERE WITH THE COLORS IS
A MAP OF GROUND SUBSIDENCE. AND
DE COLORS THAT YOU SEE GO FROM
ABOUT THE BLUE TO RED WHERE RED
INDICATES SUBSIDENCE. WITH RATES
OF ABOUT ALMOST ONE FOOT PER
YEAR. SO THESE ARE HUGE
SUBSIDENCE RATES SO THE GROUND
IS BASICALLY GOING DOWN. SO THE
HOUSE THAT HAS A REALLY
SIGNIFICANT REPERCUSSION ON
INFRASTRUCTURE- LADIES AS WELL
AS THE BACK WINDOW. IN FACT-
BECAUSE YOU KNOW THE WATER FLOWS
DOWN THE RIVER IT FLOWS DOWN THE
SLOPES SO IF YOU CHANGE THAT
SMOKE. YOU WILL ALSO CHANGE THE
FLOW OF WATER SO IT HAS BEEN
VERY IMPORTANT CONSEQUENCES AND
WE CAN OBSERVE THAT. EXTREMELY
ACCURATELY FROM SPACE AS WELL AS
WITH OUR SPACE BORNE
INSTRUMENTS. AND ALSO I JUST
WANTED TO. YOU USED TO KNOW THAT
THE DISTRICT KNOWLEDGE HE HAS
ACTUALLY. BEEN I GUESS ACCEPTED
BY. THAT AND THE CALIFORNIA'S
GROUNDWATER LIFE THAT- CINDY
MESSER WAS TALKING ABOUT EARLIER
ACTUALLY HAS A MAP BOTH FROM
SUBSIDENCE THAT ON IT'S A GREAT
SITE. SO I DID NOT MENTION SO IT
HAS IMPORTANT BECAUSE THE-
SUBSIDENCE HAS IMPORTANT
CONSEQUENCES- IN PARTICULAR- I
QUIT SO HERE WITH OUR INSTRUMENT
THE U. S. R. WHICH IS INSTALLED
ON AN AIRPLANE- WE COVERED THE-
CALIFORNIA I COULD LOOK. SEVERAL
TIMES AND HERE'S ONE OF THE
IMAGES THAT WERE RETRIEVED HER
FROM THIS ERA CROPS SHOWING
AGAIN SUBSIDENCE SO BECAUSE IT
IS AN AIRCRAFT IT'S NOT ONLY GET
ABLE TO PROVIDE YOU WITH THE
HIGHER RESOLUTION DATA. BUT IT'S
ALSO ON THE MEND- SO YOU WE CAN
FLY AT ANY TIME SO WE DECIDED TO
LIVE TO BE DO YOU HAVE TO WAIT A
WHILE OR THE- THE REPEAT OF THE
MEASUREMENT IT CAN CAN BE FOR US
A MONTH FOR A YEAR SO WE
DEMOCRATS IT'S REALLY- WEEKEND
THAT IT'S ON DEMAND- REMOTE
SENSING THAT. WE CAN ACHIEVE SO
HERE IS AN EXAMPLE OF ONE OF THE
SUBSIDENCE MEASUREMENTS- THAT-
WE- CAPTURED. THIS IS BETWEEN-
TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN AND TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN SO QUITE AWHILE
ALREADY. AND THAT IT SHOWS THAT
ONE OF THESE A SMALLER AREA-
SMALL AREAS WHICH IS JUST ALONG.
THE AQUEDUCT. AND YOU CAN SEE
THAT THE UPWARD UP IN THIS AREA
IN PARTICULAR IS UNDERGOING-
SUBSIDENCE RATES. OF NEARLY ONE.
ONE FOOT IN THAT YEARS SO THIS
IS A- COURTING TO MONITOR
BECAUSE IN FACT IT WILL IMPACT
THE SLOPE OF THAT THAT PRODUCT
AND THEREFORE TO SLOW WATER.
OTHER THINGS WE CAN DO WITH- OUR
AIRBORNE REMOTE SENSING
INSTRUMENT AS WELL AS THE
SPACEBORNE ONES. IS TO MONITOR
THE HEALTH OF LADIES THIS IS ONE
EXAMPLE IN THE SUMMER CAME AND I
SUBMIT TO SOME WORK IN DELTA.
AND BC IS THE INSURER ON SHERMAN
ISLAND SO WE HAVE OBSERVED USING
THIS UAV SUBSYSTEM AGAIN. BREACH
IN THE LEVEE- WHICH WAS DETECTED
DRESSER FROM- DEED TO SUSPECT
MOTOR G. THAT WE'RE ABLE TO
PROVIDE- AND AGAIN THIS IS SO
THIS ONE IS FROM. AN AIRCRAFT
AND WE CAN. ALSO DO THAT NOT
FROM SPACE. AS WE KNOW SO MANY.
WE CAN LOOK AT THE IMPACT OF THE
LANDSCAPE DON'T IMPACT OF THE
LOSS OF WATER. UNDERGROUND WATER
IN ON THE LANDSCAPE BUT WE CAN
ALSO LOOK AT D. S. STORAGE FOR
WATER IN OUR- SNOW PACKS AND
MOUNTAINS AND THIS IS ONE OF THE
EXAMPLES THAT- WE'RE SHOWN BY
DOING EARLIER. BUT BETWEEN
JANUARY TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
AND OF THE JUNE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN SO THERE WAS NO
ACTIVITY TO THE POINT FROM. THAT
ABOUT THIRTY CENTIMETERS OVER
THE WEEK TO. ABOUT. A METRE OF
SNOW HERE SO- THIS IS ONE OF-
THE EXAMPLES THAT BE SOMETHING
THAT WE CAN ALSO DO. WITH
AIRCRAFT MEASUREMENTS. BUT SOON
WILL HAVE THREE MISSIONS THAT
MIGHT BE LAUNCHED- THAT WILL
FACILITATE MEASUREMENTS OF FLOWS
OF WATER GLOBALLY AND- WE'RE
REALLY LOOKING FORWARD TO APPLY
THESE SEVEN EWE MEASUREMENTS TO
CALIFORNIA- WATER RIVER. WATER
MANAGEMENT SO- SWALLOW THE
SURFACE WATER AND OCEAN
TOPOGRAPHY WHICH IS- SHOWN HERE
AS AN ANIMATION WILL BE LAUNCHED
NEXT YEAR TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
TWO WOULD PROVIDE. NOT ONLY
WATER SURFACE ELEVATION OF THE
SEA BUT IT WILL ALSO PROVIDE US
WITH THE CAPABILITY OF MAKING A
MEASUREMENT. OF REFURBISHED
CHARGE. AND ALSO- PROVIDED A
WEEK TO MONITOR ALL THE
HYDROLOGY ALONG THE COAST
ITSELF. AND THE AMOUNT OF WATER
IN RESERVOIRS AND LAKES SO- DAN
THIS IS GLOBAL BUT OF COURSE IT
DEFINITELY WORKS IN CALIFORNIA
ITS SECOND MISSION HERE WHICH
WILL BE LAUNCHED IN TWENTY
TWENTY THREE IS MY SORRY- THAT
IS THE ONE THAT'S BEING. BUILT
IN COLLABORATION WITH THE INDIAN
SPACE AGENCY. AND WITH THIS
MISSION WE WILL BE ABLE TO
MONITOR THE FLOW OF WATER. UNDER
THE VEGETATION. SO THIS IS ONE
OF THE- THE- MEASUREMENTS THAT
HAS NOT BEEN. EXTENSIVELY USED
YET NOR FOR SCIENCE OR FOR
APPLICATIONS FOR THE WATER
MANAGEMENT SERVICE I SEE A GREAT
POTENTIAL IN THIS MISSION HERE
THE- OTHER- THE MEASUREMENT WILL
THIS MISSION WOULD PROVIDE. IS
GROUND SUBSIDENCE SO IT WILL BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE GROUND
SUBSIDENCE AGAIN HOPEFULLY. AND
THIS ONE WILL PROVIDE US OF
COURSE AND ALL THE DATA WOULD BE
FREE AS THE WIND SAID EARLIER
AND WE PROVIDE RADIUS- YES VERY
IMPORTANT TOOL FOR THE
MANAGEMENT OF OUR WATER
RESOURCES THE LAST MISSION HERE
IS B. G. WHICH STANDS FOR SIR
FIRST BIOLOGY AND GEOLOGY WHICH-
IS MOST LIKELY A LONG STAY IN
THE TWO THOUSAND TWENTY EIGHT
AND MAYBE LATER. AND THIS ONE
WOULD PROVIDE MEASUREMENTS OF
WATER QUALITY IN ADDITION TO
ENABLING- MONITORING. OF THE
HEALTH OF VEGETATION. SO I WILL
STOP HERE I WILL LEAVE YOU AND
THIS ANIMATION AND THE- LOOK
FORWARD TO YOUR QUESTIONS. FULL
THANK YOU TO ALL OF YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION SO I IT JUST. THIS
IS AN AREA THAT- JUST REALLY I'M
PERSONALLY REALLY INTERESTED AND
I THINK THAT IT IS A HUMAN
SECURITY ISSUE IT'S A- OUR-
CLEAN WATER ISSUE IT IS A FOOD
ISSUE AT THE END OF THE DAY AND-
THE FASCINATED BY THE WORK THEY
IF IT YOU'RE ALL DOING AND ALSO
THE WORK THAT. IS THAT YOU.
LOOKING AHEAD OF US AS WELL IN
TERMS OF THE WORK THAT- FRESNO
STATE AND THE DIFFERENT
PARTNERS. COLLABORATORS WITH
FRESNO STATE AND ALONG WITH AT
NASA. I- I HAVE IN DISTRICT I
THINK. NOT TOO MANY QUESTIONS
BUT I'M REALLY INTERESTED IN AND
- KIND OF GETTING A LITTLE BIT
OF A SENSE OF WHAT NASA. IN
TERMS OF SUBSIDENCE AND IN TERMS
OF LOOKING AT THE FUTURE OF
DELTA'S. WHAT WHAT IS IT THAT
YOU KNOW. THAT WE DON'T KNOW.
FOR EXAMPLE I KNOW THAT AROUND
THE WORLD IN OTHER ARTS OF THE
US AND CALIFORNIA THERE'S BEEN
REPORTS ABOUT SUBSIDENCE
OCCURRING. OBVIOUSLY THERE'S
GOING TO BE MORE LOOKING INTO
THAT ARE AT A GLOBAL SCALE. BUT
I MEAN WHAT IS IT THAT THAT KIND
AND- WHAT QUESTIONS ARE NOT HAVE
NOT BEEN ANSWERED YET IN TERMS
OF SUBSIDENCE IN TERMS OF- THE
FUTURE OF DELTAS WHAT WHAT. ARE
WE LOOKING AT WHAT SHOULD WE
EXPECT. YEAH I DON'T MAYBE I
START SO I- LAURA MENTIONED THAT
EARLIER WE NEED TO HAVE A
COORDINATED A WAY OF MANAGING
THE RESOURCES- THE WATER
RESOURCES IN THIS CASE. AND-
WHAT WE DON'T UNDERSTAND REALLY
IS THE CONNECTION BETWEEN ALL OF
THE D. DISPOSAL WHICH IS THE
LANDSCAPE RIGHT SO WE GO FROM
THE UPPER WATERSHED ALL THE WAY.
TO THE CITY. AND THE WATER GOES
THROUGH A DIFFERENT PROCESS SEES
WHICH- ARE DUE TO IT BEING A-
ACTIVITY OF- HUMAN. AT ALL THE
WAY TO A GEORGE COLLECTIVITIES-
BIOLOGICAL ACTIVITIES SO WHEN'S
THE INTERACTION. OF THE WATER
WITH THE- LANDSCAPE BASEL BUT I
THINK WE STILL DON'T FULLY
UNDERSTAND OR- ACTIVITIES THAT
QUANTITATIVELY WE HAVEN'T YET
QUANTIFIED EVERYTHING THERE AND
I THINK NOW WITH THESE TOOLS
THAT. YEAH WE HAVE- IT'S
POSSIBLE TO ADDRESS THIS- THIS
GAP IN KNOLEDGE. BECAUSE NOW WE
HAVE THIS THIS VERY LARGE SCALE
VIEW- WE USED TO HAVE JUST A
LITTLE GAUGE A LITTLE WATER
LEVEL GAUGE HERE ANOTHER ONE
THERE BUT NOW WE SEE EVERYTHING
WE SEE THE CONNECTION- ACROSS
THE LANDSCAPE. AND THAT IS
EXACTLY WHAT WATER SEAS OR THAT
I THINK ONLY WHEN WE LOOK AT THE
LANDSCAPE AND- WE- HAVE A
COORDINATED MODEL CAN WE
UNDERSTAND EVERYTHING THAT'S
GOING ON. R. S. AND- ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT THAT I ACTUALLY-
BECAUSE REALLY BECAME AWARE AND
FASCINATED LIKE YOU WERE
RECENTLY QUOTED AND- IT COULD BE
A P. ST AND ASSOCIATED PRESS AND
I JUST THOUGHT IT WAS REALLY
INTERESTING I DISCOURAGED TO
KNOW FROM YOU- KIND OF A LITTLE
BIT MORE WHAT YOU MEAN BY IT BUT
YOU SAID. IF YOU HAVE TO CHOOSE
BETWEEN SAVING AN AREA LOSING
ANOTHER INSTEAD OF LOSING
EVERYTHING HE WANT TO KNOW WHERE-TO PUT YOUR RESOURCES TO WORK TO
SAVE THE LIVELIHOOD. OF ALL THE
PEOPLE WHO LIVE THERE AND- YOU
KNOW IN TERMS OF THIS COMMITTEE
I MEAN IT THIS IS WHAT IT'S ALL
ABOUT RIGHT IT'S ABOUT HUMAN
SECURITY IT'S ABOUT PROTECTING
THE LIVELIHOOD OF ALL THE PEOPLE
WHO LIVE THERE AND- WHAT. YOU
KNOW NOT JUST THAT THE DISTRICT
THAT I REPRESENT BUT ALL
CALIFORNIANS IN PURE BILLY
PEOPLE ACROSS. IT JUST AROUND
THE WORLD RIGHT OBVIOUSLY
CLIMATE CHANGE IS SOMETHING THAT
IS NOT JUST IMPACTING MY SENATE
DISTRICT IT'S IMPACTING MANKIND
. SO I DON'T KNOW IF THERE'S
ANYTHING- ELSE THE TWO- A DOCTOR
SUMMER ONE TO KIND OF ADD TO THE
QUOTE THAT YOU PROVIDED. YEAH I
DIDN'T DO THAT I THINK THAT THAT
WOULD ENCAPSULATE MOST OF MY
THOUGHTS HERE. IT'S REALLY THE
WE DO HAVE TO CONSIDER THE
IMPACT. OF HUMAN ACTIVITY AND
ALSO THE FEEDBACK OF NATURE ON
THAT YOU MEANT ACTIVITY SO WHEN
YOU LOSE- SOMETHING IN A
LANDSCAPE BE PROCESSED YOU ALSO
LOSE OR ENDANGERED OR THREATENED
ALIVE YOU. WHICH IS QUITE
IMPORTANT THAT AND WE I THINK WE
CANNOT. TALK ABOUT THE DELTAS
AND VALLEYS WITHOUT TALKING
ABOUT PEOPLE- THE AVARICE IN A
ROW IN THERE AND THEY ARE
IMPACTED BY EVERYTHING THAT
HAPPENED. SO AGAIN MY- CITING
LAURA- WITH THE COSTS YOU KNOW
SEVEN SEVEN BILLION SEE THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA DECIDES TO
GIVE US FIVE BILLION AND THAT'S
SEVEN. WHAT DO YOU DO SO HOW DO
YOU OPTIMIZE THE BENEFITS TO
MOST PEOPLE. BEFORE I KNOW IT'S
A LOT OF U. S. MAIS BENEFITS SO
THAT THAT'S NOT REALLY MY
BUSINESS I PROVIDE INFORMATION
BUT- I HOPE THAT THE INFORMATION
WE CAN PROVIDE. CAN BE USED TO
MAKE S. N. O. SMARTER DECISIONS
AND MORE- YOU KNOW OPTIMIZE
SPEED THAT IS. YOUR RESOURCES I
USE THAT FIVE MINUTES FIVE
BILLION. IN THE BEST WAY
POSSIBLE AND- THAT'S WHAT WE
HOPE TO PROVIDE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND- AND ARE ALL
ALL. THOSE ARE ALL MY QUESTIONS
FOR THIS PANEL I KNOW THAT WE-
HAVE UP WITH SOME PEOPLE WAITING
IN THE QUEUE FOR WORK BACK FOR
COMMENTS. FOR THIS HEARING AND
SO I WANT TO GO AHEAD AND OPEN
IT UP TO A PUB PUBLIC COMMENT I
WANT TO THANK YOU THAT'S ONE
THING THE THIRD PANEL ONCE AGAIN
FOR JOINING US FOR ALL THE
INFORMATION AND- I WILL TAKE UP-
YOU UP ON YOUR OFFER AT SOME
POINT WHEN IT IS- ALLOWED AND
SAFE TO DO SO TO. TO GO FOR A
VISIT- TO YOUR STATION AND- I
ALSO LOOK FORWARD TO LEARNING
ABOUT ALL THE DIFFERENT
EXPLORATIONS THAT ARE UPCOMING
THAT I THINK ARE GOING TO BE
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT- IT'S
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT RESEARCH
THAT YOU'RE DOING AND IN REGARDS
TO. PROTECTING HUMANS AND-
MAKING SURE WE EAT THERE IS
HUMAN SECURITY FOR ALL SO THANK
YOU FOR THE WORK THAT YOU DO AND
I'LL GO AHEAD AT THIS POINT OPEN
IT UP TO- UP FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. IN LATE IN GERMAN ON THE PHONE
LINE IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENTS PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. NOT
VERY WILL PROVIDE YOU A NUMBER.
AND I WILL ANNOUNCE YOU BY THAT
NUMBER. ONCE AGAIN DID LIKE TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENTS PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AND THEN ONCE
AGAIN DUE TO CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH APPEARANCE
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS AND
CLEANING PROTOCOLS COMMITTEE.
CHAIRS ME INTO TWO TIME LIMITS
ON TESTIMONY ALL OTHERS WISHING
TO TESTIFY MUST LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS TO TWO MINUTES EACH. SO
WILL BEGIN OF COURSE- VIA THE
TELEPHONE LINES. AND WE'LL START
WITH THE LINE NUMBER TWELVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I LEARNED HOW
CAN I BE HEARD- IN A DROUGHT
COMMITTEE. TROUBLE CALLING IN
YES THIS IS ACUMEN SECURITY-
LOOKING GREAT- GREAT THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR TAKING COMMENT
YOUR YOUR COLLEAGUES YOU KNOW
THE COURT HEARING THEY DIDN'T
HAVE PUBLIC COMMENT- I WAS
HEARING THEY DIDN'T TAKE PHONE
COMMENT LEARNING ON DOLLARS SHE-
GETS COMMENTS. I APPRECIATE YOU
TAKING COMMENT- THAT BEING SAID
READING FROM- CALIFORNIA GLOBE
ARTICLE BY A KEY CRIMES FROM
DECEMBER SIXTH. CALIFORNIA HAS A
LONG HISTORY OF SQUANDERING ITS
PRECIOUS WATER. IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN CALIFORNIA VOTERS
APPROVED SEVEN POINT ONE TWO
BILLION IN BONDS FOR STATE WATER
SUPPLY INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS.
I'M NOT TWO POINT SEVEN BILLION
WAS DESIGNATED FOR WATER STORAGE
PROJECTS. BUT NEARLY EIGHT YEARS
LATER THERE ARE NO NEW DAMS OR
RESERVOIRS OR OTHER WATER
PROJECT. WHAT'S IN STORE
CALIFORNIA'S WINTER RUNOFF IN
CALIFORNIA IS IN YET ANOTHER
DROUGHT. THE STATE OFFICIALS IN
CHARGE BOW TO ENVIRONMENTALISTS
BY ALLOWING HALF OF THE STATE'S
WATER TO FLOW OUT TO THE OCEAN
LEAVING FARMERS AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO FIGHT FOR THE
OTHER FIFTY PERCENT. THE STATE
USES ABOUT FORTY SEVEN POINT 5%
OF IT THE LOCAL WATER SUPPLY FOR
THE ENVIRONMENT INCLUDING WILD
RIVER FLOWS MANAGED WETLAND. AND
WILDLIFE PRESERVE HABITAT AND
WATER QUALITY CONTROL FOR FISH
AND REQUIRED TO DELTA OUTFLOWS
ACCORDING TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES. WATER IS
DIVERTED IN TIMES OF DROUGHT TEN
TIMES OF PLENTY TO THE
SACRAMENTO SAN JOAQUIN DELTA
LEAVING MUCH LESSER IRRIGATION
OVER CALIFORNIA TO DRINK
APPROXIMATELY 10% OF THE
REMAINING WATER IS USED BY
CITIES AND 40% USED BY
AGRICULTURE. YET IT IS ALWAYS
URBAN USE AND AGRICULTURE FORCED
YOU CONCERN. IS WHY THE WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING ACT OF
TWENTY TWENTY TWO WAS WRITTEN
AND HAS BEGUN TO QUALIFY AS A
STATE BALLOT PROPOSITION MORE
WATER NOW AS IT IS KNOWN WILL BE
A BIPARTISAN PARTISAN INITIATIVE
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT SINCE
YOUR TWO THOUSAND. CALIFORNIA
VOTERS HAVE APPROVED A WATER
BONDS TOTALING MORE THAN THIRTY
BILLION ACCORDING TO THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE BUT
THE STATE BUREAUCRATS EMPOWERED
TO GET THESE PROJECTS HELLO. I
HAVE TO DEAL WITH AND LOOK FOR
TO GAUGE AND CONSTANTLY CHANGING
PERMITTING REQUIREMENTS FROM
DOZENS OF LOCAL STATE AND
FEDERAL AGENCIES INSTEAD THE
SUCCESSFUL BUREAUCRATS KEEP
THEIR JOBS BY CONDITIONING
PEOPLE TO THINK THAT IT'S
SUPPOSED TO TAKE THIRTY TO FORTY
YEARS TO BUILD A RESERVOIR OR
REPAIRING AQUEDUCT ONE WATER
EXPERT TOLD THE GLOBE. THEY'RE
DEAD WRONG. BUT THEY ARE IN
CHARGE. WATER MEAN MORE WHAT
BILL FOR WHAT. MORE WATER OF THE
FOR THE DELTA ECO SO AND MORE.
TO MANAGE CHRONIC DROUGHT AND
CLIMATE CHANGE MORE WATER NOW
SAYS. AND TO STATE WHAT OUGHT TO
BE OBVIOUS MORE WATER PROJECTS
ALSO MEANS LESS IMPORTED FOOD
AND MORE AFFORDABLE FOOD. L. U.
PEOPLE JUST HAD A THREE HOUR
HEARING AND YOU'RE BLAMING
EVERYTHING ON A DROUGHT ONE THIS
ISN'T YET ANOTHER AREA WHERE YOU
ARE FEELING CALIFORNIANS YOU'RE
CONTROLLING THE NARRATIVE THANK
YOU HAVE A POLICY ISSUE YOU DO
NOT HAVE A DROUGHT ISSUE AND THE
PEOPLE ARE Y. USED TO YOU AND
YOUR POLITBURO CORRUPTION. FOR
EUROPE SO KEEP YOUR- NOT WE WERE
GOING TO BUY. IT THANK YOU. HOW
DO WE HAVE ANOTHER CALLER
WAITING IN THE QUEUE. WE DO HAVE
ANOTHER ONE IN OUR QUEUE- WE'LL
GO TO LINE THIRTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD AND THIS IS JUST A
REMINDER FOR YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND OF COURSE WE
ARE LIMITED TO TWO MINUTES THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS ERIN I'VE BEEN HERE DONE AND
I'M REPRESENTING THE SANTA CLARA
VALLEY WATER DISTRICT. WHICH IS
ALSO KNOWN AS VALLEY WATER.
VALLEY WATER FACES A CHALLENGE
WITH WATER AFFORDABILITY FUTURE
CONFERENCE THE CALL. IS NOT
INCLUDED. CLIMATE CHANGE AND
DROUGHT THAT'S MAKING URGENT THE
NEED FOR A CLAIM FOR A LOSS THE
IRISH NO BLACKS. NO PACKED WITH
MORE COSTLY IN COUNTY STORAGE.
SECONDLY HIGH COST RECYCLED
WATER PROJECTS THAT ARE NEEDED
TO MAKE WATER I'M MORE RESILIENT
. THIRTY SEISMIC SAFETY ISSUES
WITH THEM OR IN DROUGHT INDUCED
COST OF EMERGENCY WATER
TRANSFERS AND THE EXHILARATION
OF CONSERVATION PROGRAM. THAT
STATE AND FEDERAL WATER
CONVEYANCES ARE COSTLY TO REPAIR
AND SUBJECT OUTAGES AND FAMILY
REGULATORY DELAYS THAT CAN
INFLATE THE COST OF WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS. THESE
COSTS ARE DUE TO CLIMATE CHANGE
ARE STILL HIGH FOR A WATER
DISTRICT RATEPAYERS IN BOTH
URBAN AND RURAL AREAS HE JUST
THERE ON THEIR OWN. SOME OF THE
LARGEST POPULATIONS OF
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES LIVE
IN MAJOR POPULATION CENTERS.
WHERE WATER AFFORDABILITY IS
BECOMING A SERIOUS CHALLENGE. WE
URGE THE STATE AND FEDERAL
GOVERNMENTS TO SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASE INVESTMENT IN WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE TO ADAPT TO THE
CHANGED CLIMATE AND FOR THE
CHANGE AT THE VERY TOP. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND I
APPRECIATE THE HEARING TODAY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH OUR
NEXT CALLER. AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE NO OTHERS IN OUR QUEUE-
GIVEN THAT WE HAVE HEARD FROM
AND ALL PUBLIC COMMENT SORRY. I
WANT TO GO AHEAD AND MAKE SURE
THAT WE DON'T HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL- INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO PROVIDE COMMENT AND ROOM-
TWENTY FORTY. THREE NINE- I
DON'T SEE ANY ADDITIONAL-
INDIVIDUALS HERE IN BROOME-
FORTY SEVENTY WAITING TO TESTIFY
AND THAT IT WILL ARE COMPLETE-
PUB PUBLIC COMMENT SECTION. I
WANT TO THANK ONCE AGAIN ALL FOR
A PANELIST- THAT WORK HERE
TODAY- I KNOW THAT IT WAS A
VERY- AT ITS THREE HOUR HEARING
ABOUT I THINK THIS IS ALL
INFORMATION THAT. THAT WE NEED
TO HAVE A CONVERSATION ABOUT AND
LEARN FROM THE EXPERTS. R. AT
THAT WE NEED TO HEAR ABOUT AND-
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO- THIS BEAN
AT THE FIRST OF MANY
CONVERSATIONS WITH- THE EXPERTS
THAT WERE ON A DIET THAT SPOKE
TODAY DURING THIS HEARING. N. AT
ONE OF PINK ONCE AGAIN SIR
MELINDA'S FOR BEING. HERE AT THE
HEARING AND- THAT WILL WRAP UP
FOR HEARING FOR TODAY- THANK YOU
GOT TO BE INDIVIDUALS WHO ALSO
PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC COMMENT-
IF YOU WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY
VIA THE TELECONFERENCE OR PRESS
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS
SUGGESTIONS AND WRITING. TO THE
SELECT COMMITTEE ON HUMAN
SECURITY OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT
TO INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY AND
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS THANK
YOU WE APPRECIATE. YOUR
PARTICIPATION. THANK YOU TO
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE FOR
COOPERATION FOR BEING ON THIS
CALL AND OF COURSE FOR THE
COMMITTEE STAFFER- EVERYTHING
THAT THEY DID TODAY WE HAVE
CONCLUDED THE AGENDA OF THE
SELECT. COMMITTEE ON HUMAN
SECURITY IS NOW ADJOURNED.